GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME THIS
IS THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEENUMBER ONE ON HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES AND TODAY'S
HEARING PRIMARILY COVERS THE
HEALTH RELATED PROPOSALS AND THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION
TOMORROW'S SUB ONE HEARING WILL
COVER THE HUMAN SERVICES
PROPOSAL WHICH WERE INCLUDED IN
THE MAY REVISION. AS USUAL I
HAVE BEEN ASKED TO READ SOME
DIRECTIONS REGARDING PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION IN TODAY'S HEARING
TO ENSURE THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE
HERE TODAY WHILE ALSO ALLOWING
FOR FULL PUBLIC PARTICIPATION IN
TODAY'S DISCUSSION. TODAY'S
HEARING IS IN THE SWING SPACE AT
TEN TWENTY ONE- STREET IN
HEARING ROOM ELEVEN HUNDRED.
MOST OF THE PANELISTS WILL BE
TESTIFYING IN PERSON WHILE
OTHERS WILL BE JOINING US
REMOTELY ON WEBEX. WE ARE
ACCEPTING PUBLIC COMMENT AT THE
END OF THE HEARING IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND ON THE PHONE.
THE PHONE NUMBER TO CONNECT IS
ON THE COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND
SHOULD BE ON THE SCREEN IF YOU
ARE WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET.
THE TOLL FREE NUMBER IS. ONE
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. THE
PUBLIC ACCESS CODE IS. ONE EIGHT
FIVE ZERO ELEVEN HUNDRED. IF YOU
ENCOUNTER ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE
CONTACT THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE. USE ME THE ASSEMBLY
BUDGET COMMITTEE AT 916-319-2090
NINE AND A STAFF MEMBER WILL
ASSIST YOU. WE WILL BEGIN PUBLIC
COMMENT AFTER ALL MEMBERS HAVE
CONCLUDED THEIR QUESTIONS FOR
THE SPEAKERS TODAY. WE ALSO WILL
ACCEPT WRITTEN PUBLIC COMMENTS
AND FEEDBACK THROUGH THE SUB ONE
EMAIL ACCOUNT AND THAT ADDRESS
IS BUDGET SUB ONE ACT ASM DOT CA
DOT GOV. FINALLY ALTHOUGH THE
AGENDA INDICATES THE POSSIBILITY
OF THE SUB COMMITTEE VOTING ON
AN AGENDA OF JANUARY IN APRIL
PROPOSALS THESE ACTIONS ARE
BEING POSTPONED UNTIL TOMORROW'S
HEARING. HENCE THERE WILL BE NO
VOTES TAKEN IN TODAY'S HEARING.
A FEW OPENING COMMENTS IF I CAN
BEFORE WE BEGIN. AS WE HEAD INTO
THE LEFT FOR THE FINAL MONTH OF
THE BUDGET CYCLE RECOGNIZING
THAT THIS WEEK'S HEARINGS MAY BE
OUR LAST SUBCOMMITTEE'S HEARINGS
I WANT TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY
TO SHARE WHAT I THINK SHOULD BE
OUR STATE'S HIGHEST PRIORITIES.
IN HEALTH. AS YOU ALL KNOW THE
PAST TWO YEARS HAVE BEEN
DIFFICULT FOR ALL OF US. MANY OF
US HAVE LOST LOVED ONES MANY OF
US HAVE BEEN ILL OURSELVES. AND
MANY OF OUR COLLEAGUES FRIENDS
AND FAMILY ARE SICK TODAY. AND
ALL OF US HAVE BATTLED THE
STRESS OF ISOLATION DIMINISHED
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE THE FEARS
ABOUT THE FUTURE OF COVERT.
MOREOVER THE PANDEMIC HAS
BROUGHT LONG STANDING HEALTH
EQUITY ISSUES INTO STARK RELIEF
OUR STATE'S INEQUITIES WERE NOT
CREATED BY THE PANDA. BUT THE
PANDEMIC HAS HIGHLIGHTED THEM
AND ELIMINATED ANY EXCUSES WE
MAY HAVE HAD TO NOT ADDRESS THEM
. IN MANY SIGNIFICANT WAYS THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSED BUDGET DOES
JUST THAT AND THEREFORE I WANT
TO THANK THE GOVERNOR AND
APPLAUD THE A MINUTE
ADMINISTRATION FOR A JOB WELL
DONE. BUT I ALSO CAME TO THE
STATE CAPITOL TO ELEVATE THESE
ISSUES. TO BRING TO SPEAK FOR
CALIFORNIANS WHOSE VOICES ARE
NOT TYPICALLY HEARD HERE AND TO
PUSH THE STATE TO DO MORE AND TO
DO BETTER. A FEW EXAMPLES. THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL. HIS BUDGET
PROPOSES HEALTH FOR ALL TO
EXPAND MEDICAL ELIGIBILITY TO
ALL ELIGIBLE ADULTS REGARDLESS
OF IMMIGRATION STATUS YET IT
DOES SO ALLOWING TWENTY SIX YEAR
OLDS TO LOSE COVERAGE OVER THE
NEXT TWO YEARS. WE CAN DO BETTER
. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET PROPOSES
TO MAKE HEALTH CARE MORE
AFFORDABLE I ELIMINATING
PREMIUMS FOR SELECT POPULATIONS
AND MEDICAL. YET IT LEAVES COST
SHARING FOR OTHER LOW INCOME
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES. AGAIN WE
CAN DO BETTER. THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET ELIMINATES SOME RECESSION
ERA AB NINETY SEVEN RATE
REDUCTIONS GET IT LEAVES MANY
OTHERS IN PLACE. WE CAN DO
BETTER. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PROPOSES SOME MODEST RESOURCES
FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION OF NINE
EIGHT EIGHT. YET FAILS TO
SUPPORT OTHER SUBSTANTIAL
RESOURCES OR A STATE PLANNING
PROCESS WE CAN DO BETTER.
FINALLY THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
INCLUDES VARIOUS MODEST
INVESTMENTS IN CALIFORNIA'S
SENIORS YET FAILS TO MAKE A
SERIOUS COMMITMENT TO WHOLESALE
REFORM OF OUR NURSING HOME
INDUSTRY. WE CAN AND WE MUST DO
BETTER. MY COMMITMENT TO ALL OF
YOU IS THAT I AND THE
LEGISLATURE WILL TAKE THE
GOVERNOR'S EXCELLENT BUDGET AND
MAKE IT EVEN BETTER. WE WILL
PUSH OURSELVES AND OUR STATE TO
LIFT UP THE LIVES AND HEALTH OF
AS MANY CALIFORNIANS AS POSSIBLE
. WITH THAT WE WILL BEGIN
TODAY'S HEARING. I WOULD LIKE TO
FIRST WELCOME UP MARK NOONAN
DEPUTY LEGISLATIVE ANALYST WITH
THE L. A. O. WHO IS GOING TO
PROVIDE A HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW OF
THE MAY REVISION. MR NOON.
THANKS VERY MUCH I MISTER CHAIR
MARK NEWTON WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST OFFICE AND IS THE TERM
MENTIONED WE ARE ASKED TO
PROVIDE AN HIGH LEVEL OVERVIEW
OF THE ALLEY OWES INITIAL TAKE
ON THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL- YESTERDAY OUR OFFICE
RELEASED- OUR INITIAL COMMENTS
ON THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL.
WHICH LARGELY FOCUS ON THE
OVERALL STRUCTURE AND BUDGET. IN
OVERALL CONDITION OF THE OF THE
BUDGET- I KNOW THAT OUR OFFICE
IS CURRENTLY ANALYZING THE
INDIVIDUAL PROPOSALS AND
CERTAINLY AS OUR UNDERSTANDING
CONTINUES TO INVOLVE AS WE GET
MORE INFORMATION FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION. WE WILL BE
ADVISING THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
COMING DAYS AND WEEKS AND AS
ALWAYS HAPPY TO PROVIDE WHATEVER
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE WE CAN
PROVIDE- AS THE LEGISLATURE-
DELIBERATES ON THE ON THE BUDGET
. SO WHAT ONE SUMMARIZE SOME OF
OUR KEY FINDINGS FROM OUR REPORT
THAT WAS RELEASED TO YESTERDAY.
THE FIRST FINDING. IS THAT THE
REVENUE GROWTH HAS BEEN
ABSOLUTELY EXTRAORDINARY OVER
THE LAST- TWO YEARS. MEANING
THAT THE GOVERNOR HAD A VERY
LARGE SURPLUS TO ALLOCATE. A
FIFTY TWO BILLION DOLLAR GENERAL
FUND SURPLUS- AND THEN A THIRTY
THREE AND A HALF BILLION DOLLAR
SURPLUS WHICH IS IN THE SCHOOL
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE- BUDGET.
BUT ONE CAN'T MENTION SURPLUS
WITHOUT MENTIONING THE OPERATION
OF THE STATE APPROPRIATIONS
LIMIT OUR OUR FINDING IS IT
CERTAINLY THE SAL STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT CONTINUES
TO BE A MAJOR CONSTRAINT ON THE
BUDGET WITHOUT GOING INTO ALL
THE TECHNICAL MECHANICS OF SOUTH
WHICH IS QUITE A QUITE
COMPLICATED IT ESSENTIALLY
ELIMINATES HOW THE STATE CAN USE
REVENUES WHEN REVENUES EXCEED A
CERTAIN A CERTAIN LIMIT AND WHEN
REVENUES EXCEED THAT LIMIT. THE
STATE IS DICTATED IN THE WAYS
THEY CAN SPEND FUNDING IT CAN IT
CAN SPEND ON TAX REFUNDS OR TAX
REBATES PAYMENTS TO SCHOOLS BUT
ALSO ON SPENDING THAT IS
EXCLUDED FROM THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT AND THAT
SUCH SPENDING AS SPENDING ON
CAPITAL OUTLAY ARE SPENDING ON
EMERGENCIES AND THAT SPENDING ON
LOCAL SO. SUBVENTIONS TO. I'M TO
LOCAL GOVERNMENT OR SO OUR WAYS
AND THE GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION
PROPOSAL CERTAINLY TAKES.
ADVANTAGE OF- OF THOSE VARIOUS
OBSERVE MEANS. SO OF THAT
SURPLUS ABOUT THIRTY NINE
BILLION DOLLARS OF A FIFTY TWO
BILLION DOLLARS SURPLUS IT IS
SPENT TOWARDS MEETING SORT OF
WHAT ARE CALLED THE CELL
REQUIREMENTS SO IT'S THE
DICTATED SORT OF USE OF REVENUES
THAT EXCEED A PARTICULAR LIMIT.
AND THE GOVERNOR THE TWO LARGEST
CATEGORIES IN THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL ARE SORT OF- TAX
REFUNDS ELEVEN HALF BILLION FOR
TAX REFUNDS AND THEN TWENTY TWO
BILLION DOLLARS IN. CAPITAL
OUTLAY I SHOULD MAYBE JUST BACK
UP A NODE IN TERMS OF THE
OVERALL ALLOCATION OF THE
SURPLUS THE POLICY AREAS THAT I
GUESS BENEFIT MOST FROM THE
ALLOCATION OF THE SURPLUS- ARE
TOO AND IT'S- A NATURAL
RESOURCES AND ANSWER
TRANSPORTATION OR THE TOO BIG
POLICY AREAS. WHICH ARE
RECEIVING- FUNDING FROM THE FROM
THE SURPLUS. SO WHAT DOES ALL
THIS MEAN FOR THE FOR THE BUDGET
YEAR AND THE OUT OF THE OUT
YEARS AND- A KEY POINT TO MAKE
IN A KEY FINDING IS THAT. THERE
IS A VERY SIGNIFICANT FISCAL
CLIFF THAT THE STATE IS GOING TO
HIT IN IN IN TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FOUR SO JUST ONE
YEAR OUT FROM FROM THE BUDGET
YEAR. AND THAT AND THIS IS SORT
OF DUE TO THE OPERATION OF THE
STATE APPROPRIATIONS LAMENT AND-
IT'S A FISCAL CLIFF THAT. CANNOT
BE AVOIDD JUST BY BY REVENUES
BEING DIFFERENT THAN WE MIGHT
PROJECT BUT THIS IS THIS IS A
SORT OF A CERTAINTY. AND THAT.
WHAT WHAT ARE OFFICE FOUND IS
THAT TEN TWENTY THREE TWENTY
FOUR THERE WILL BE STE WHAT A
CULT STYLE REQUIREMENTS SO. SORT
OF DICTATED SERVE ADDITIONAL
SPENDING THAT MUST BE MADE SORT
OF BECAUSE OF REVENUES BEING
OVER THE LIMIT. OF ABOUT TWENTY
FIVE BILLION DOLLARS BUT THE
SURPLUS THAT WE PROTECT THE
PROJECT FOR. FOR TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR IS ONE POINT SIX
BILLION DOLLARS SO JUST A MERE
PITTANCE OF THE TOTAL SPENDING
THAT THE- STATE IS REQUIRED TO
MAKE KIND UNDER THE STATE
APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT. MANY OF
YOU MAY BE ASKING ABOUT HER THE
RECESSION AND- OUR OFFICE IS NOT
PREDICTING A RECESSION BUT WE DO
FIND THAT THERE IS VERY MUCH A
HEIGHTENED RISK FOR RECESSION
OVER THE NEXT TWO YEARS BECAUSE
OF A NUMBER OF WARNING
INDICATORS THAT ARE
TRADITIONALLY USED. TO IN IN THE
PER PREDICTING NUMBER OF
RECESSIONS AND- THOSE ARE
HEIGHTENED THERE'S DEFINITELY A
HEIGHTENED RISKS FOR A RECESSION
SO. AGAIN NO CERTAINTY IN
FORECASTING BUT- DEFINITELY
HEIGHTENED RISK. SO WHAT THAT
ALL MEANS IN TERMS OF A BOTTOM
LINE ALLEY- RECOMMENDATION IS
THAT THERE IS VERY MUCH IN NEED
IN OUR RECOMMENDATION FROM OUR
OFFICE FOR MORE MONIES TO BE PUT
INTO RESERVES AND THAT HAS TO
BENEFITS AND THAT ONE BENEFIT IS
CERTAINLY TO- TO PREVENT
AGAINST- SERVER DRESS A BUDGET
PROBLEM THAT RESULTS FROM. A
RECESSION BUT ALSO TO ADDRESS
THESE VERY SIGNIFICANT
REQUIREMENTS UNDER THE STATE
APPROPRIATION LIMIT THAT ARE
GOING TO HIT IN TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR. BUT BEFORE THIS
HEARING TRANSITIONS TO
DISCUSSING SORT OF INDIVIDUAL
PROPOSALS IN THE IN THE HEALTH
AREA. I'D LIKE TO NOTE THAT THE
LARGEST WE CERTAINLY THE
LEGISLATURE WHO HAS INTEREST. IN
NET MAKING SIR SPENDING
AUGMENTATIONS AND ACROSS VARIOUS
POLICY AREAS INCLUDING THE
HEALTH AREA. AND DAD SO WHILE
THERE IS THIS SORT OF THECELL
REQUIREMENTS OF IN THE
BACKGROUND WE THINK THAT THE
LEGISLATURE OB. IS LIKELY TO IT
TO MAKE AUGMENTATIONS AND WHEN
IT DOES WE HAVE A JUST A
FRAMEWORK TO SUGGEST. TO YOU TO
HELP GUIDE YOUR OF YOUR
DELIBERATIONS AND WE THINK IT'S
A VERY VERY HIGH BAR THAT THAT
NEEDS TO BE PASSED. FOR A FOR A
SPENDING AUGMENTATION THAT
DOESN'T HELP THE STATE MEET THE
STATE APPROPRIATIONS LIMIT SO IF
IT WERE AN AUGMENTATION FOR
INSTANCE FOR CAPITAL OUTLAY OR
FOR EMERGENCY SPENDING THAT DOES
THAT DOES HELP. BUT SAID MANY
POTENTIAL AUGMENTATIONS ARE
OUTSIDE THAT TYPE OF TYPE OF
SPENDING. SO CLEARLY. WE WOULD.
WE WOULD RECOMMEND THAT TO
SPENDING AUGMENTATIONS BE ON
VERY HIGH PRIORITY LEGISLATIVE
OF THE NEEDS. OFFER A NO WIN
PROBLEM AND THAT THE SOLUTION
SORT OF IS PROVEN TO BE.
EFFECTIVE AND IT WOULD WORK
TOWARDS THE- TOWARDS THE GOAL.
R. AND MAY ALSO BE SOME VERY
SOME POTENTIAL FOR FISCAL
BENEFITS FROM SPENDING FRIENDS
OVER THE LONGER RUN- FOR
INSTANCE- SPENDING TODAY THAT
THAT TO. GREAT SAVINGS SERVE IN
THE IN THE FUTURE OR SPENDING
TODAY THAT. ARE DRAWS DOWN
FEDERAL FUNDS THAT'S VERY
RELEVANT IN THE IN THE IN THE
HEALTH AREA- SO JUST TO A FINAL
THOUGHT TO AS AS YOU'RE
CONSIDERING THE PROPOSALS- ADEN
AND WE'RE NOT SAYING THAT'S A
NON STARTER TO. IF IT'S A AN
AUGMENTATION BUT- BUT A HIGH BAR
AND WE'RE VERY HELP. VERY
WILLING TO SORT OF HELP BUT YOU
IN IN THE EVALUATION OF THE
MINISTRATIONS PROPOSALS AND
PROPOSALS THAT YOU MAY. YOU MAY
SUGGEST YOURSELVES- THE FOR TO
WORKING WITH YOU AND A TALKING
MORE ABOUT THE END. FOR AND
HAPPY ANSWERED ANY QUESTIONS
THAT RIGHT NOW THE CHAIR MEMBER
THANK YOU MR NOON WE'RE GOING TO
HOLD ALL QUESTIONS UNTIL AFTER
THE PRESENTATIONS AND- FOR.
MEDICAL RESEARCH. NEXTRA COULD
WE HAVE THE AGENCY SPEAKERS FOR
THE HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
AGENCY MAY REVISE PROPOSALS.
FOR
THESE BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY
THERE SHOULD BE A LITTLE MIKE
BUTTON RIGHT.
GOOD AFTERNOON A TRADE OFF GOT
IT. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME'S
JOHN HANG ON THE TO DATE OFFICER
FOR COLLEGE AGE US. OF A- OR IN
UNDER FIVE MINUTES HELP ME WITH
SERVICES PROFESSIONALS IN
CALIFORNIA TODAY. HAVE LIMITED
AN UNEVEN ACCESS TO MEDICAL
BEHAVIORAL AND HUMAN SERVICES
HISTORIES RESTRAINING THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THEIR SUPPORT.
WHILE SOME PARTICULARLY LARGE
ACUTE CARE HOSPITALS AND HEALTH
SYSTEMS ARE DEVELOPED DATA
EXCHANGES THAT ARE ALREADY
MAKING A DIFFERENCE IN THE LIVES
OF PEOPLE THEY SERVE. OTHERS ARE
STILL IN THE EARLY STAGES OF
THEIR DATA EXCHANGE JOURNEY. AND
SOME HAVE NO CAPACIY TO SHARE
THEIR INFORMATION ELECTRONICALLY
WHILE OTHER HELPING HIM AND
SERVICE ORGANIZATIONS. NEED
SUPPORT. THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
ORGANIZATIONS THAT NEED SUPPORT
IMPLEMENT SYSTEMS THAT WILL
ALLOW THEM TO CONNECT OTHER
ENTITIES. THE LATTER CASES
ESPECIALLY TRUE FOR SMALL OR
UNDER RESOURCE PROVIDERS
PARTICULARLY SMALL PHYSICIAN
PRACTICES ROLE HOSPITALS AND
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
PROVIDERS WHO OFTEN DELIVER
SERVICES THE MOST VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS. WITHOUT SUPPORT WE
WILL SEE A WIDENING DIGITAL
DIVIDE THAT ADVERSELY IMPACTS
POPULATIONS AND EXACERBATES
DISPARITIES THAT WERE LAID BARE
DURING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY. AB ONE THIRTY THREE
THE CALIFORNIA ON THE PATH TO
BUILDING ITS FIRST EVER
STATEWIDE. HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES DATA EXCHANGE
FRAMEWORK. A SINGLE SHARING DATA
SHARING AGREEMENT AND A COMMON
SET OF POLICIES PROCEDURES THAT
WILL GOVERN THE EXCHANGE OF
INFORMATION AMONG HEALTH CARE
ENTITIES. AND GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES. HOWEVER AB ONE THIRTY
THREE DID NOT INCLUDE FUNDING
THAT WOULD BE NECESSARY TO FILL
GAPS IN THAT CALIFORNIA STATE
EXCHANGE LANDSCAPE. AND
SUPPORTED FOR. ITS
IMPLEMENTATION PARTICULARLY
AMONG UNDER RESOURCE PROVIDERS.
INDEED WE HAVE HEARD FROM THE
PUBLIC IN OUR STAKEHOLDER
ADVISORY GROUP MEMBERS THAT WILL
BE ESSENTIAL FOR THE STATE OFFER
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE THESE
PROVIDERS THE HELP THEM
PARTICIPATE IN THE DATA EXCHANGE
FRAMEWORK AS REQUIRED. BY AB ONE
THIRTY THREE. THE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
GRANT PROGRAM PROPOSED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION IF
ENACTED WILL BE A SIGNIFICANT
STEP FORWARD IN SUPPORTING THESE
PROVIDERS IN IMPLEMENTING THE
DATA EXCHANGE FRAMEWORK. AS WELL
AS THE ADVANCEMENT OF DATA
EXCHANGE THROUGH THE STATE. AND
THE HEALTH AND WELL BEING OF
CALIFORNIA. WE WILL SOLICIT
STAKEHOLDER INPUT AS
APPROPRIATE. AS THE BEST WAY TO
ADMINISTER THESE GRANTS. AT THIS
THESE GRANT PROGRAMS LOOKING FOR
THE BEST PRACTICES FROM EXISTING
OR HISTORICAL GRANT PROGRAMS. OF
FOR EXAMPLE THE NOW EXPIRED CAL
CALIFORNIA TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM WHICH WAS HELPFUL IN
SUPPORTING PROVIDERS IN ADOPTING
EHRS THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
PANELS. GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR ARAMBULA AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I'M PROVIDING ON A
FEW ITEMS. THE FIRST ONE IS THE
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA FOR ALL- THE
FIFTEEN- BEFORE I DESCRIBE THE
PROPOSAL ORG I'LL GIVE SOME
BACKGROUND. THE TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET ACT ESTABLISHED A HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL COMMISSION.
WHICH WAS CHARGED WITH
DEVELOPING A PLAN THAT INCLUDES
OPTIONS FOR ADVANCING PROGRESS
TOWARD ACHIEVING A HEALTHCARE
DELIVERY SYSTEM. THAT PROVIDES
COVERAGE AND ACCESS FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS- UNIFY MASCOUTAH
SPEAK DIRECTLY INTO THE
MICROPHONE HARD TIME CAPTURING
YOURSELF THROUGH A UNIFIED
FINANCING SYSTEM. LOOTING BUT
NOT LIMITED TO A SINGLE PAYER
SYSTEM. SB ONE OF FOUR REQUIRED
THE COMMISSION TO SUBMIT A
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE. AND
THE GOVERNOR THAT INCLUDES
OPTIONS FOR KEY DESIGN
CONSIDERATIONS. FOR UNIFIED
FINANCING SYSTEM INCLUDING A
SINGLE PAYER SYSTEM. THE FINAL
COMMISSIONERS AT THE LAST
MEETING ON APRIL TWENTY FIFTH.
IT WILL BE TRANSMITTED TO THE
LEGISLATURE AND GOVERNOR AFTER
THE PUBLIC PERIOD OF PUBLIC
COMMENT PERIOD ENDS THIS FRIDAY
. THE FINAL REPORT ELEVATES A
SHARED VISION OF A HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL. I WILL MAKE
SURE THAT WILL MAKE SURE
HEALTHCARE IS ACCESSIBLE
AFFORDABLE. EQUITABLE I QUALITY
AND UNIVERSAL. THE REPORT
OUTLINES THE DECISIONS AND
ACTIONS THAT WILL MOVE
CALIFORNIA TOWARD A UNIFIED
FINANCING. FOR HEALTHCARE. THE
CONCEPT OF A UNIFIED FINANCING
SYSTEM- ENVISIONS A SYSTEM WHERE
CALIFORNIANS WILL BE ENTITLED TO
RECEIVE A STANDARD PACKAGE OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES ENTITLEMENT
WILL NOT BEAR VERY BY FACTORS
SUCH AS AGE INCOME IMMIGRATION
STATUS OR OTHER CHARACTERISTICS
. AND DISTINCTIONS AMONG
MEDICARE MEDI CAL EMPLOYER
SPONSORED INSURANCE AN
INDIVIDUAL MARKET COVERAGE WILL
BE ELIMINATED WITHIN THE SYSTEM
OF UNIFIED FINANCING. THE FINAL
REPORT RECOMMENDS THAT THE STATE
MAKE ADDITIONAL PROGRESS ON THE
PATH TOWARD UNIFIED FINANCING BY
SECURING AND TASKING DEDICATED
STAFF. AND RESOURCES TO DEVELOP
AND IMPLEMENT. A FEDERAL PARTNER
ENGAGEMENT STRATEGY. YOU
UNDERSTAND FEDERAL APPROVALS
NEEDED TO PROCEED WITH THE STATE
BASED UNIFIED FINANCING SYSTEM.
SUCH AS A SINGLE PAYER SYSTEM.
THIS PROCESS MAY START WITH
INFORMAL ENGAGEMENT BY KELLY
JUST OFF OF THEIR OF THEIR
COUNTERPARTS AT THE CENTERS FOR
MEDICARE AND MEDICAID SERVICES-
IF CONVERSATIONS WITH WITH
FEDERAL PARTNERS CONFIRMED THERE
ARE THERE IS A FEASIBLE PATH.
FORWARD ON PERMISSIONS AND
ADEQUATE AND SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING. L. HHS WOULD ENGAGE
WITH STAKEHOLDERS TO DEVELOP A
FULL PROPOSAL. I WILL NEED TO
CONTAIN DEFINE ELEMENTS SUCH AS
ELIGIBILITY AND ENROLLMENT
COVERED BENEFITS AND PAYMENT
APPROACHES. THIS BUDGET PROPOSAL
REQUESTS LIMITED TERM STAFF
RESOURCES THE CLUB WANTED TO
STOP POSITION. ADDITIONALLY THE
REQUEST- SIX ONE MILLION GENERAL
FUND TO CONTRACT FOR RESEARCH
AND CONSULTING SERVICES IN
SUPPORT OF THE FOLLOW UP WORK.
THESE CONTRACTING RESOURCES
WOULD BE USED TO OBTAIN
SPECIALIZED EXPERTISE ON
HEALTHCARE POLICY MATTERS.
LOADING BUT NOT LIMITED TO
FEDERAL WAIVERS UNDER CURRENT
LAW. AND SPECIALIZED TOPICS THAT
INCLUDE VALIDATING THE ROLE OF
HEALTH PLANS. AND WHAT FUNCTIONS
THEY COULD THEY COULD PERFORM IF
THEY ARE RETAINED AND REIMAGINED
UNDER UNDER UNIFIED FINANCING-
IN CLOSING THIS PROPOSAL WOULD
AUTHORIZE THAT THE NECESSARY
RESOURCES. TO MAKE ADDITIONAL
PROGRESS ON THE PATH TOWARDS
UNIFIED FINANCING. I CONSISTENT
WITH THE RECOMMENDATIONS OF THE
OF THE CALIFORNIA FROG
COMMISSION FINAL REPORT. ALL
POSITIVE IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS I CAN MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT ITEM WE WILL TAKE ALL
QUESTIONS AT THE CONCLUSION OF
THE PANELISTS IF WE CANNOT I MAY
ASK OUR PANELISTS TO BE. AT THE
CENTER IS POSSIBLE AS WE DO HAVE
A NUMBER OF PROPOSALS WERE
HEARING TODAY HAPPY TO HAVE
INFORMATION AND FOLLOW UP. ON
AND WE HAVE RECEIVED RECEIVED
WRITTEN INFORMATION ON ALL OF.
ONE OF REITERATE THAT. ARE
ENCOURAGED TO THE NEXT AGENCY
ITEM ON- THE STATE SUBSIDY THEIR
REVISION PROPOSAL- SO- BUT IF
FEDERAL ACTION- IS NOT TAKEN TO
EXPAND OUR PREMIUM SUBSIDIES FOR
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY THREE AND
BEYOND THE MAY REVISION INCLUDES
THREE HUNDRED AND FOUR MILLION
FROM THE HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY RESERVE FUND. FOR
BUDGET YEAR AND THREE HUNDRED
AND FOUR MILLION GENERAL FUND IN
TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. AND
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER TO
REINSTITUTE THE CALIFORNIA
PREMIUMS OF AROUND IT I THINK
THIS MAY BE MORE APPROPRIATE
WHEN WE DEAL WITH COVERED
CALIFORNIA LATER ON THE AGENDA
IF WE CAN. TO KEEP IT THE HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICES OKAY. OKAY
SO. YOUNG THE OTHER ITEM IS
GONNA PRESENT ON AS THE- OFFICE
OF RESPONSE AND RESILIENCE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE- IN
SUMMARY ESTABLISHING THE OFFICE
OF RESPONSE AND A RESILIENCE-
WITHIN THE CAL WITHIN COLLEGE
AGE US WILL. PROVIDE A DEDICATED
STAFF TO MANAGE THE DEPARTMENTS
AND OFFICES THROUGHOUT THE
DISASTER CONTINUUM OF THE
TRAILER BILL FOLLOWS- A PRIOR
HEARING ON THE BCP- THE TRAILER
BILL- WOULD REQUIRE A CONSISTENT
HOLE OF AGENCY PERSON CENTERED
APPROACH. TO ENSURE THAT ALL OF
OUR HEALTH AND SOCIAL SERVICES
PROGRAMS ARE MOVING TOGETHER THE
SERVER CALIFORNIANS BEFORE
DURING AND AFTER A DISASTER. IN
THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE THIS
OFFICE WILL COMMENCE ON JULY
FIRST. TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWO-
AS THE FOR THE FUNDING FOR THE
OFFICE OF THREE YEAR. THREE YEAR
LIMITED TERM THE OFFICE WILL
ALSO PROVIDE A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE AT THE END OF THE
SECOND YEAR. ON THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THE OFFICE TO
ENHANCE SERVICES FOR
CALIFORNIANS. AND WHETHER IT
ENHANCES- OR IMPROVED OPERATIONS
GROUP THROUGHOUT THEIR MERGING
SEA MANAGEMENT CONTINUE ON THANK
YOU. THANK YOU EXPOUNDS PLEASE.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURBULENT MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MELISSA
STAFFORD JONES DIRECTOR OF THE
CHILDREN YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR BEFORE YOU
TODAY. AS YOU KNOW AND AS THE
CHAIR ACTUALLY SPOKE ABOUT HIS
OPENING REMARKS. WALDRON AND
YOUTH ARE EXPERIENCING
TREMENDOUS MENTAL HEALTH
CHALLENGES THE STRESS. FROM MY
SOCIAL ISOLATION CAUSED BY THE
PANDEMIC. INTENSIFIED AN ALREADY
EXISTING MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS
AMONG CHILDREN AND YOUTH. THE
PARTICULARLY AS THE CHAIR ALSO
MENTIONED. FOR YOUTH OF COLOR IN
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES OF YOU
WHICH A FEW. AND OTHER GROUPS
I'M IN UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
MENTAL HEALTH IS NOW THE LEADING
CAUSE OF HOSPITALIZATION FOR
CHILDREN UNDER EIGHTEEN IN
CALIFORNIA. AND DEEPLY
CONCERNING. IS THE INCREASING
USE SUICIDE RATES OVER THE LAST
DECADE. CDPH DATA TRACKED A 20%
INCREASE IN SUICIDE AMONG TEN TO
EIGHTEEN YEAR OLDS FROM TWENTY
NINETEEN TO TWENTY TWENTY. ROCK
YOU FEMALE YOUTH AND HISPANIC
YOUTH ALL EXPERIENCED INCREASED
RATES OF SUICIDE IN THAT TIME
PERIOD. THE SUICIDE RATE FOR
BLACK YOUTH IN CALIFORNIA
DOUBLED BETWEEN TWENTY FOURTEEN
AND TWENTY TWENTY. A RECENT
STUDY SHOWS THAT 40% A TRANS
GENDER INDIVIDUALS HAVE
ATTEMPTED SUICIDE WITH SUICIDE
RISK BEING HIGHEST AMONGST
TRANSGENDER YOUTH. IN A RECENT
SURVEY OF CALIFORNIA STUDENTS
FOUND ABOUT ONE THIRD OF SEVENTH
AND EIGHTH GRADERS. AND ALMOST
HALF OF ELEVENTH GRADERS
EXPERIENCED CHRONIC SADNESS. THE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT OF ONE
TIME FUNDS THROUGH THE CHILDREN
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE WILL HAVE A
MEANINGFUL IMPACT ON OUTCOMES
FOR CHILDREN YOUTH IN THE LONG
TERM. HOWEVER AS WE CONTINUE TO
WORK HARD TO EFFECTIVELY DEVELOP
DESIGN AND IMPLEMENT THE
COMPONENTS OF THE CHILDREN YOU
THINK EVER HEALTH INITIATIVE.
THERE IS AN URGENT AND IMMEDIATE
NEED TO CONTINUE TO INVEST IN
EFFORTS TO ADDRESS CHILDREN'S
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. WITH A FOCUS
ON MORE IMMEDIATE ACTION. UNDER
THIS PROPOSAL CALLIE TO ADDRESS
WILL INVEST IT INVEST ADDITIONAL
RESOURCES IN TARGETED EFFORTS
NOW. TO ADDRESS URGENT AND
EMERGENT ISSUES IN CHILDREN WITH
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. THESE
PROPOSALS ARE CONSISTENT WITH
BUT ALSO ADDITIVE AND
COMPLEMENTARY OF THE INVESTMENTS
OF THE CHILDREN WITH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INITIATIVE I JUST WANT TO
BRIEFLY MENTION THE COMPONENTS
OF THE PROPOSAL. THE FIRST IS A
U. SUICIDE REPORTING AND CRISIS
RESPONSE PILOT PROGRAM IN WHICH
CDPH WOULD PILOT MAKING USE
SUICIDE AND SUICIDE ATTEMPTS A
REPORTABLE PUBLIC HEALTH EVENT.
AND WOULD THEN INCLUDE FOLLOW UP
CRISIS RESPONSE AND SERVICES IN
THE COMMUNITY INCLUDING IN
SCHOOLS. THE AIM IS TO APPLY A
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS APPROACH
RESPONSE TO THE CRISIS IN YOU
SEE THAT. SECONDLY INCREASING
WELLNESS WELLNESS RESILIENCE
BUILDING AND MINDFULNESS FOR
CHILDREN YOUTH AND PARENTS WERE
GRANT PROGRAM THE SCHOOL STRIDES
COUNTY CITIES COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION. I'LL SHARE WITH
YOU AND I'M SURE MANY IN THIS
ROOM HAVE HEARD THIS TO YOU IN A%
RECENT MEETING I WAS IN WITH YOU. THEY ARE OFTEN STILL FEEL
ISOLATED AND LONELY THEY SAID WE
NEED SUPPORT TO REGAIN
CONNECTION TO REGAIN THAT HUMAN
INTERACTION AND CONNECTION THAT
WE LOST DURING THIS TIME FOR OUR
OWN WELL BEING THAT IS PARTLY
WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO ADVANCE
HERE INCLUDING FOR PARENTS WITH
A REAL FOCUS INVESTING ON
SUPPORTS. A VIDEO SERIES IT
REALLY AIMS AT SUPPORTING
WELLBEING AND RESILIENCE FOR
PARENTS THAT THEY CAN HELP THEIR
KIDS COPE AND ADDRESS THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH. FUNDING IN THE
PROPOSAL WOULD ALSO BE USED TO
LEVERAGE EMERGING TECHNOLOGIES
TO REALLY FOCUS ON NEXT
GENERATION DIGITAL SUPPORT THAT.
AT PROMOTE POSITIVE MENTAL
HEALTH AND HELP AMELIORATE WHAT
WE KNOW CAN SOMETIMES BE OF SOME
TECHNOLOGIES A NEGATIVE IMPACT
ON CHILDREN AND YOUTH APRIL
HELPED. AND LAST WEEK IT WOULD
SUPPORT BUILDING THE PIPELINE OF
CULTURALLY DIVERSE FUTURE WORK
FORCE OF BEHAVIORAL HEALTH.
PARTICULARLY WITH THIS FOCUS ON
EMERGING NEXT GENERATION
TECHNOLOGIES HOPEFULLY BEING A
HOPE TO BRING AND THAT NEXT
GENERATION. SO WE'RE PROPOSING
NEEDS ADDITIONAL IMMEDIATE TERM
ACTIONS TO HELP ADDRESS THE
URGENT CRISIS IN YOUTH MENTAL
HEALTH. WHILE WE CONTINUE TO
EFFECTIVELY AND MEANINGFULLY
ADVANCE THE LONGER TERM ORK AND
THEIR CHILDREN. IF THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WAS PLEASE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCING A HUNGER
FOR THE COMMENTS. ANY COMMENTS
ON HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES.
THANK YOU TO THAT CHAIR AND
MEMBER- RATIO AT THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE WE JUST HAVE AN
OVER COMMENT TO RAISE ABOUT THE
FUNDING BEING PROPOSED FOR
VARIOUS ADDITIONAL CHILDREN AND
YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
AUGMENTATIONS- WE WOULD
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER HOW EXISTING FUNDING
WITHIN THE CHILDREN AND YOUTH
INITIATIVE I CAN BE LEVERAGED TO
ACHIEVE SOME OF THE GOALS OF
THIS NEW FUNDING. OF MUCH OF
THIS EXISTING FUNDING- WITHIN
THAT CHILL THEY SHOULD
INITIATIVE HAS NOT BEEN
DISTRIBUTED YET AND WITHIN THE
XISTING FUNDING FOR THE
INITIATIVE THEY ARE GRANT
PROGRAMS FOCUSED ON IMPROVING
SERVICES IN SCHOOLS- DEVELOPING
WORKFORCE THAT FUND EVIDENCE
BASED PRACTICES FOR CHILDREN AND
YOUTH. THESE BROAD CATEGORIES-
SEEM TO ENCOMPASS AT LEAST SOME
OF THE PRIORITIES REFLECTED IN
THIS NEW PROPOSED FUNDING. GIVEN
THESE CONSIDERATIONS IF THE
LEGISLATURE WISHES TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH THESE NEW
INVESTMENTS WE WOULDN'T WE WOULD
SUGGEST DISTRIBUTING THESE NEWLY
PROPOSED GRANT DOLLARS THROUGH
THE STRUCTURE OF EXISTING
CHILDREN AND YOUTH BEHAVIOR
HEALTH INITIATIVE PROGRAMS. TO
HELP ENSURE MORE- STREAMLINED
IMPLEMENTATION- THOSE ARE ALL
OUR COMMENTS ON THE HHS AGENCY
PORTION OF THE AGENDA TODAY
WE'RE HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
AT THE END. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NEXT COULD WE PLEASE HAVE THE
EMERGENCY MEDICAL SERVICES.
AUTHORITY COME FORWARD AND- HAVE
THOSE. IT SHOULD BE THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WILL BE
PRESENTING ON BEHALF OF EMSA- ON
THERE MAY REVISED PROPOSAL. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR ARAMBULA MEMBERS. THAT WORK. THANK YOU
UNLISTENABLE TELL DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- I AM PRESENTING ON AN
ADJUSTMENT TO THE EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES AUTHORITY OR
AND FAST AND THE REQUEST TO
INCREASE THE GENERAL FUND
REIMBURSEMENTS BY ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE THE REQUESTED LEVEL
IN REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE LEVEL OF
FUNDING PROPOSED IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
BUDGET FOR MEDICAL SURGE
FUNDING. I WOULD NOTE THAT
EFFECTIVE APRIL ONE FACILITIES
THAT UTILIZE STATE- THE UTILIZED
THE STATE FOR MEDICAL STAFF
URGED ARE REQUIRED TO REIMBURSE
THE STATE FOR SUCH SERVICE. AND
I CAN TAKE ANY OTHER FROM
REQUEST AND I AM SO COLLEAGUES
ON THE LINE TO THERE BE ANY
PROBLEM. PROGRAMMATIC YEAH HELLO
ANY COMMENT. I'M WE'RE CURRENTLY
REVIEWING THE PROPOSALSNO AT NO
INITIAL COMMENTS. THANK YOU NEXT
COULD WE HAVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE ACCESS AND
INFORMATION SPEAKERS FOR THE H.
KILEY MAY REVISE PROPOSALS COME
FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHRISTMANN CHIEF
DEPUTY DIRECTOR DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE ACCESS AND
INFORMATION. FOR H. GAC- IF YOU
WANNA THREE UNCOMPENSATED CARE
FUND FOR ABORTION SERVICES THE
DEPARTMENT REQUESTS FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS ONE TIME
AUTHORIZED FOR ENCUMBRANCE
EXPENDITURE OVER SIX YEARS. TO
ESTABLISH AN UNCOMPENSATED CARE
FUND FOR GRANTS REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS IN ORDER
TO OFFSET CARE. FOSTER CARE OF
FOR ABORTION CARE AND
CONTRACEPTION SERVICES TO LOW
INCOME AND MODERATE INCOME
INDIVIDUALS WITHOUT HEALTH
COVERAGE. THOSE REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE SERVICES- AS WE
LEARN FROM THE CALIFORNIA FUTURE
OF ABORTION COUNSEL REPRODUCTIVE
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN UNDER
INCREASING PRESSURE TO EXPAND
SERVICES TO THEIR COMMUNITIES
WHILE PROVIDING UNCOMPENSATED
CARE AND SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA
. PLANNED PARENTHOOD HEALTH
CENTERS ALONE WROTE OFF ALMOST
NINE MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
NINETEEN. TO COVER COSTS OF
PROVIDING CARE TO PATIENTS WHO
CANNOT AFFORD. ATIONS MAY BE IN
THIS SITUATION BECAUSE THEIR
INCOME AND PROGRAM ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS. OR BECAUSE THEY
LACK COVERAGE FOR ABORTION AND
OTHER REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES INCLUDING THOSE WHO ARE
UNINSURED. OR OTHERWISE
EXPERIENCING GAPS IN PERSONAL
COVERAGE BETWEEN EMPLOYERS
RELIGIOUS EXEMPTION. BECAUSE
THEIR EMPLOYERS INSURANCE IS
REGULATED BY FEDERAL LAW. THE
AVAILABILITY AND FINANCIAL
STABILITY OF REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS IN CALIFORNIA THE
NEAR TERM REQUIRES THAT WE
ADDRESS THESE COSTS OF
UNCOMPENSATED CARE. THERE ARE
NEXT PANELIST EXCEPT. A COUPLE
MORE ITEMS PLEASE GIVE ME IF YOU
WANNA FOR SMALL ROLE OF HOSPITAL
TREATMENT PROGRAM INCREASE IN
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY DEPARTMENT
REQUEST AN INCREASE IN
EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY OF SEVENTY
ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS AND- TWENTY
TWO TWENTY THREE AN ONGOING FROM
THE FEDERAL TRUST FUND TO
CONTINUE SUPPORT FOR THE SMALL
RURAL HOSPITAL IMPROVEMENT
PROGRAM. WORSHIP THE INCREASED
AUTHORITIES NEEDED TO
ACCOMMODATE AN ADDITIONAL AWARD
AMOUNT WERE THE SHIP GRANT. IF
YOU WANT TO FIVE HEALTH AND HOME
CARE WORKFORCE ADJUSTMENT. THE
BUDGET PROPOSAL INCLUDES REQUEST
TO SHIFT FUNDING BETWEEN
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES
REFLECTING CHANGES SINCE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET. THE
DEPARTMENT REQUEST A REDUCTION
OF FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS OVER
THREE YEARS FROM EACH BECAUSE
INITIATIVES IN THE CARE ECONOMY
PROPOSAL INCLUDED IT GOVERNMENT
BUDGET. THIS REDUCTION IS OFFSET
BY ME REVISION PROPOSAL FOR THE
pTO EXPAND NONTRADITIONAL
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS. AND
SUPPORT ADDITIONAL APPRENTICE
ACTIVITIES. WE ALSO ASKED TO
MOVE THE TOTAL TWENTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IN FUNDING. FOR
OPIOID RELATED PROGRAMS FROM
EACH GUY TO TE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES INCLUDING
TWENTY MILLION. FOR OPIOID
PROVIDER TRAINING AND TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF REHABILITATION.
INCLUDING FOR MILLION FOR
VOCATIONAL REHABILITATION
SERVICES FOR CONSUMERS WITH
SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS. AND
FINALLY COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS
. THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET INCLUDED
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS OVER THREE YEARS FOR
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS AS PART
OF A LARGER CARE CONNIE
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROPOSAL.
EACH CAR REQUEST EDITORIAL
CHANGES BE ADOPTED THE DEFINED
THE ROLE IN ELIGIBILITY
REQUIREMENTS OF COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS. THE STATUTORY CHANGES
WILL ALSO REQUIRE. STATEWIDE
REQUIREMENTS FOR TRAINING. AND
CERTIFICATION PROGRAMS. EACH CAR
IS TAKING DELIBERATE STEPS TO
ENSURE RETENTION THE GRASSROOTS
CULTURALLY COMPETENT WORK OF THE
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS. THE
FOR THIS PROPOSAL OVER THE PAST
FIFTY YEARS H. CARLY LOOKS TO
MAXIMIZE THE EXPERIENCE INVOICE
EXISTING COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS THE PRODUCTS. THE
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE FOR
COMMITTEE HEALTH WORKERS
ESTABLISHES A PROCESS BY WHICH
THE STATE APPROVES EACH W.
TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT MEET
NATIONALLY RECOGNIZED FOR
COMPETENCY. WELL SEATS W. CORE
COMPETENCIES ARE ESTABLISHED
THROUGH NATIONAL CONSENSUS
WORKGROUPS AND PEER REVIEWED
LITERATURE. CALIFORNIA WILL
ENSURE ALIGNMENT BY
COLLABORATING WITH COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS AND FROM A DOOR
STAKEHOLDERS. THE STATE WILL NOT
BE CREATING ITS OWN TRAINING
PROGRAM BUT INSTEAD APPROVING
PROGRAMS THAT MEET THE NATIONAL
OR COMPETENCIES. THIS EMPOWERS
EXISTING PROGRAMS TO EXPAND.
ALLOWS THE CREATION OF NEW
TRAINING PROGRAMS AS WELL. THE
PROPOSED LANGUAGE ALSO ALLOWS
EXISTING OR NEW TRAINING
PROGRAMS TO PETITION THE STATE
TO BECOME. AN APPROVED TRAINING
PROGRAM AUTHORIZED TO ISSUE. A
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKER
CERTIFICATE DEMONSTRATING
INDIVIDUAL. THAT'S COMPLETED
TRAINING THAT MEETS THE
STANDARDS ESTABLISHED BY THE
STATE AND STAKEHOLDERS. THANK
YOU NEXT PROPOSED. YEAH JUST THE
DAWSON FROM AN APARTMENT FINANCE
NO ADDITIONAL COMMENT AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU HELLO. THANK YOU
DR AMBULATORY WITH THE L. A.
WE'RE STILL REVIEWING H. GUYS
PROPOSALS AND WILL FOLLOW UP IF
WE HAVE ANY ISSUES THE FLAG.
THANK YOU NEXT COULD WE HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES SPEAKERS FOR THE DH CS
MAY REVISED PROPOSALS PLEASE
COME FORWARD.
THEY GIVE THE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR- SHAHBAZ DIRECTOR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES THE MAY REVISION
PROPOSES A TOTAL OF A HUNDRED
FORTY ONE POINT EIGHT BILLION
AND ABOUT 400-400-0600 POSITIONS
FOR THE SUPPORT DH CS OF THAT
ABOUT A HUNDRED FORTY BILLION IS
FOR LOCAL ASSISTANCE I'M GONNA
HIGHLIGHT QUICKLY A FEW OF OUR
MAY REVISION PROPOSALS AND TURN
IT OVER TO ADD MISS COOPER TO
PROVIDE ADDITIONAL DETAILS. THE
MAY EVISION PROPOSES NINE
HUNDRED AND THIRTY THREE MILLION
FOR NEW RETENTION PAYMENTS FOR
HOSPITAL AND SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY WORKERS THE GOAL OF
THESE A RETENTION PAYMENTS IS
REALLY TO RECOGNIZE THE VALUE OF
THIS WORK FORCE ON THE FRONTLINE
OF THAT MAKE I MEAN VALUE
CRITICAL WORKFORCE WE ARE ALSO
PROPOSING A NEW SKILLED NURSING
FACILITY FINANCING REPORT FOR
OUR PACKAGE WHICH INCLUDES BOTH
NEW WORKFORCE QUALITY INCENTIVE
PROGRAM AND ALSO ACCOUNTABILITY
A THIRTY FOR THE DEPARTMENT IS
THE FIRST TIME EVER THE
DEPARTMENT WILL HAVE THE
ABILITY. TO HOLD SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES ACCOUNTABLE FOR
QUALITY OF CARE PROVIDED TERM
MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES- WE ARE
NOT WE ARE ALSO PROPOSING A NEW
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE WITH
REGARD OR UPDATES TO OUR- DIRECT
CONTRACT. WITH KAISER I THIS
LANGUAGE INCLUDES CLARIFICATION
THAT FORMER FOSTER YOUTH ARE
INCLUDED IN THE ROMAN PROVISIONS
RELATED TO FOSTER YOUTH. ADDING
THE DEFAULT LANGUAGE THAT WE'VE
COMMUNICATED AS PART OF OUR OUR
PACKAGE. SPECIFYING THAT KAISER
CANNOT DENY OR DESCEND ROLE
INDIVIDUAL THAT MEETS THESE
CRITERIA. AS A FIND THAT KAISER
SUBJECT TO ALL THE SAME
STANDARDS AND REQUIREMENTS AS
ARE OTHER MEDICAL MANAGED CARE
PLANS. REQUIRING THAT THE
CONTRACT OR THE MO YOU ENTERED
INTO BETWEEN THE H. YES AND
KAISER THAT OUTLINES ADDITIONAL
PROVISIONS THAT ARE UNRELATED TO
THE NORMAL- MEDICAL MANAGEDCARE
I REQUIREMENTS BE POSTED
PUBLICLY ONLINE AND INCLUDE
ANNUAL REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
PARCHMENT I WITH REGARDS TO
THOSE PROVISIONS AS RELATE TO
THE FQHC REQUIREMENTS- OVER THE
COURSE OF THE OF THE PERIOD AND
THEN ALSO ARE PROVIDING THAT
KAISER MOST I'M IMPLEMENTED
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S SERVICES
WHOLE CHART CHILD MODEL IN THE
COAST COUNTIES WERE. THIS THIS
WOULD APPLY. WE ARE ALSO
PROPOSING BUDGET BILL LANGUAGE
TO USE HEALTH PLAN MONETARY
SANCTIONS COLLECTED IN THE
BUDGET YEAR TO AWARD GRANTS TO
NONPROFIT LEGAL AID PROGRAMS AND
ENTITIES. IN THE BUDGET YEAR
CURRENTLY THE HEALTH PLAN
SANCTIONED DOLLARS IS I'VE JUST
GO TOWARDS THE GENERAL FUND AND
WE'RE PROPOSING TO USE THESE
DOLLARS TO AWARD GRANTS TO
NONPROFIT LEGAL AID TO REALLY
IMPROVE ACCESS. IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND THEN FINALLY
JUST WANNA HIGHLIGHT WE HAVE THE
MAY REVISION PROPOSES TO ADD
SIXTY MILLION A TOTAL FUNDS FOR
THE HEALTH ENROLLMENT
NAVIGATORS. REALLY BUILDING ON
THE SUCCESS THAT WE'VE HAD IN
THE PAST AND RECOGNIZING WITH
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
UNWINDING AND ARE UNDOCUMENTED
EXPENSES THESE ARE CRITICAL
PARTNERS TO REACH THOSE TARGETED
COMMUNITIES. IN AND OUT IN A
BRAZEN. RETENTION AND
SUSTAINABILITY. I'M BUILDING OFF
OF THE NAVIGATION INVESTMENTS IN
THE BUDGET YOU'LL SEE THAT
THEIR- WE ARE ALSO SCORING AND
EVERYTHING FROM THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY. THOUGH OF THE
MAY REVISION CURRENTLY REFLECTS
THE INVESTMENTS OF TWELVE POINT
FOUR BILLION TOTAL FUNDS. UPPER
CURRENT YEAR AND ELEVEN POINT
FIVE BILLION TOTAL FUNDS FOR- A
BUDGET YEAR. I ONE THING I WOULD
NOTICE THE BUDGET CURRENTLY
REFLECTS THE PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY ENDING ON JULY
FIFTEENTH OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
HOWEVER THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
DID NOT PROVIDE NOTICE YOU- THE
DEPARTMENT YESTERDAY IN REGARDS
TO THAT AND SO WE WILL HAVE TO
MAKE THOSE ADJUSTMENTS
COLLECTIVELY. ARE MOVING FORWARD
ON THEIR OTHER INVESTMENTS. IN
THE BUDGET WHERE YOU WILL SEE
AROUND A TWENTY FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR PUBLIC CAMPAIGN TO REALLY
FOCUS ON THE UNWINDING OF THE
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY. GETTING
AS MANY PEOPLE INTO COVERAGE OF
POSSIBLE COUNTY FUNDING AND THE
NAVIGATORS MENTIONED BY A
DIRECTOR BUS YOU'LL ALSO SEE NEW
BUDGET ASK AROUND. TO ASIAN OF
CERTAIN PERMANENT ITEMS WITHIN
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY AND
WINDING I WOULD ALSO NOTE THE
DEPARTMENT RELEASED TODAY A
COMPREHENSIVE. PUBLIC HEALTH
EMERGENCY UNWINDING PLAN
OUTLINING ALL ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FLEXIBILITY THAT WE
EXECUTED DURING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY WHAT ARE WE
PROPOSING TO CONTINUE WHAT ARE
WE PROPOSING TO END AND ALL OF
THAT IS REFLECTED WITHIN THE
BUDGET AS WELL. THE WOULD KNOW
THAT IS A COMPREHENSIVE REPORT
THAT WE RELEASED THS MORNING
FOR EVERYBODY TO REVIEW. THEM
HIGHLIGHTS INTERVIEW IN REGARDS
TO THINGS THAT WERE NOT
PREVIOUSLY IN THE BUDGET FOR A
PERMANENT WHEN HAVE FOR THE- U.
AG INCLUDES THE SEPARATE BILLING
FOR FQHCS FOR THE COVERT VACCINE
ADMINISTRATION THIS IS WHEN
THEY'RE BUILDING ABOVE THERE
ARE. OUTSIDE OF THEIR PEOPLE YES
THEY CAN. BE A REIMBURSE FOR
THEIR P. TODAY. THIS WITH OTHERS
IN AN ON GOING BASIS IF YOU. TO
PROVIDE. A THAT. REIMBURSED FOR
THOSE. SO YOU FOR SOMETHING
INDIVIDUALS FIVE OR ALL BLIND OR
DEAF IN A PERMANENT BASIS MOVING
FORWARD IT INCREASES THE RATES
FOR THE ICY FTD PATHOLOGY THAT
THE 10% IN WHICH WE DID DURING
THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
PERMANENT AND ONGOING IN THE
BUDGET YOU WILL ALSO SEE A
PROPOSAL FOR THE OXYGEN AND
RESPIRATORY DHEA MEETING AT A
100% MEDICARE ON GOING WITHIN
THE PROPOSED BUDGET. THEIR
TRAILER BILLS TO REFLECT ALL OF
THESE CHANGES AS WELL I WITHIN
THE PROPOSAL. ADDITIONALLY WE
HAD PREVIOUSLY PROPOSED THE
EQUITY IN A PRACTICE
TRANSFORMATION PAYMENTS. IN
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET WITH FOUR
HUNDRED MILLION IN MAY RENEE
REVISION IT IS NOW A TOTAL OF
SEVEN HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
TOTAL FUND. THE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION NEW DOLLARS. OF THE
FUNDS ARE BEING SPLIT WITH
TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOCUSED ON
STATEWIDE LEARNING COLLABORATIVE
FOR GRANTEES FEEDBACK WE
RECEIVED IN REGARDS TO NEEDING
THAT. A DOLLAR EARMARKED FOR
THE- V. TWENTY FIVE MILLION FOR
INITIAL PLANNING GRANTS THE
REMAINING SIX HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION IS TOWARDS THOSE
PRACTICE A TRANSFORMATION OF
PAYMENTS. OF WHICH TWO HUNDRED
MILLION HAS BEEN EARMARKED
SPECIFICALLY FOR FUNDS AROUND
PAYMENTS FOR HEALTH INFORMATION
EXCHANGE VALUE BASED CARE
IMPLEMENTING PRACTICE
TRANSFORMATION. WITHIN SYSTEMS
DATA COLLECTION EXCHANGE
SPECIFICALLY. BUT WE ARE ALSO
PROPOSING CAL HOPE FUNDING OF
THE CURRENT CAO H<c.cyan>S BUT BY.</c>
AND IT IS CURRENTLY SET TO
EXPIRE BY THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
NAY YOU'RE PROPOSING AND CURRENT
YEAR CONTINUATION OF THOSE
FUNDS. AS WELL AS IN A BUDGET
YEAR TO CONTINUE ALL THE WAY
UNTIL JANUARY ONE OF TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR WHERE WE WERE HOPING
TO HAVE THE BUILD OUT OF THE
PRICES CONTINUE ON AND THE
CHILDREN YOUTH BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
INITIATIVE IS WHAT'S PROPOSED.
YOU'LL ALSO SEE SOME PROPOSALS
INOUR BUDGETS AROUND NEW TRIBAL
INVESTMENTS OF SPECIFICALLY. OF
THE VILLAGE OF SAN FRANCISCO IN.
A EURO CREEK TRIBE OF CASH OF
CALIFORNIA REGIONAL WELLNESS
CENTERS AND INVESTMENTS FOR BOTH
OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS. WE HAVE
MODIFIED OUR DOULA BENEFITS
PROPOSAL- BASED ON DISCUSSIONS
EXTENSIVE DISCUSSIONS WITH
STAKEHOLDERS A SPECIFICALLY
AROUND THE PAYMENT WE HAVE
INCREASED THE AVERAGE PAYMENT
PROPOSED IN THE BUDGET FOR
AROUND FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY. A TO
ABOUT ONE THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED-
NINETY FOUR DOLLARS I WOULD JUST
NOTE WE ARE PROPOSING TO USE THE
PROFESSIONAL RATES WITHIN A
MINUTE CAL FEES OF SCHEDULE AND
THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO BILL FOR
ALL SERVICES PRIOR TO DURING
LABOR AND AFTER WITHIN THAT
PROPOSAL. WE ARE ALSO PROPOSING
TO SHIP THE IMPLEMENTATION DATE
FROM JULY OF TWENTY TWO TO
JANUARY TWENTY THREE TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS IN
REGARDS TO ENROLLMENT IN OTHER
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE NEEDED AS
WELL AS GETTING FEDERAL APPROVAL
FOR THE MODIFIED PROPOSAL ON THE
MAY REVISION. YOU WILL SEE THAT
WE ALSO PUT FORWARD A NUMBER OF
REVISIONS IN REGARDS TO YOU ARE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AB NINETY
SEVEN- ELIMINATION. A WE HAVE
ADDED ADDITIONAL ITEMS TO THAT
LIST A DONNELLY ITEMS THAT WERE
FOR APPROVED IN THE BUDGET LAST
YEAR IN WHERE WE HAD NOT
ACTUALLY SCORED THE AB NINETY
SEVEN REDUCTION. AND WANTED TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T GO BACK
IN AND REDUCE THOSE RATES. ARE
THAT WOULD INCLUDE FOR THE
DEALER SERVICES COMMUNITY HEALTH
WORKERS CONTINUOUS GLUCOSE
MONITORING. ON HEALTH ACCESS
SERVICES FOR REMOTE PATIENT
MONITORING ASTHMA PREVENTION
SERVICES DYADIC SERVICES AND
MEDICATION THERAPY MANAGEMENT.
WE ARE ALSO PROPOSING TO MAKE A
MODIFICATION TO THE CONTINUOUS
GLUCOSE. REAL METHODOLOGY. SO I
WE DO HAVE A TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO AMEND THE DEFINITION
OF MEDICAL SUPPLIES UNDER THE
PHARMACY BENEFIT. TO BE
INCLUSIVE OF DIAETIC PRODUCTS
EFFECTIVE JULY ONE OF TWENTY
TWENTY TO. OF THE CHANGE WOULD
ALLOW DHS TO IMPLEMENT THE
REVISED- REIMBURSEMENT
METHODOLOGY FOR CGM'S FROM THE
CURRENT ESTIMATED ACQUISITION
COST PLUS PHARMACY A
PROFESSIONAL DISPENSING FEE. FOR
THE MAXIMUM ACQUISITION COST
PLUS 23% ESSENTIALLY AN INCREASE
IN REGARDS TO THE REIMBURSEMENT
YOU HEARD LOUD AND CLEAR FROM
PEOPLE. OF THE CURRENT
REIMBURSEMENT WAS NOT COVERING
CUSTOMER TO MAKE QUICK
ADJUSTMENTS IN REGARDS TO THE
EFFECTIVENESS. OF THAT NEW
BENEFIT- WE ALSO ARE MAKING AN
AUGMENTATION IN REGARDS TO THE
DENTAL TRANSFORMATION INITIATIVE
WHERE WE HAD PREVIOUSLY AUTHOR
PASSED THE SURPLUS WITH IN THE
WAIVER AND WHAT WE CAN DRAW DOWN
FEDERAL FUNDS. THERE WAS A GAP
OF THIRTY POINT TWO BILLION
DOLLARS AND WE ARE PROPOSING TO
COVER THAT WITH GENERAL FUND
BUDGET. YOU WILL ALSO SEE A
REQUEST FROM THE DEPARTMENT IN
REGARDS TO RESOURCES NEEDED TO
IMPLEMENT THE KERR COURT IN
REGARDS TO DH CS IS ROLE- THERE.
A SPECIFICALLY AROUND SUPPORT
NEEDED FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
CARE COURT THE TRAINING
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE DATA
COLLECTION REPORTING AND AN
INDEPENDENT EVALUATION. OF THE
CARE COR PROPOSAL. I ALSO EIGHT
ONE HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT FOR LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SPECIFICALLY AROUND THE
CAPITAL COST TO CONSTRUCT
ACQUIRE AND REHABILITATE
TREATMENT. THE HOUSING
FACILITIES AS WELL AS RENTAL
SUBSIDIES TO SUPPORT PLACEMENT
FOR INDIVIDUALS FOUND.
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL. ON
IT A MISDEMEANOR CHARGES- IN
RESIDENTIAL SETTINGS.
ADDITIONALLY YOU'LL SEE A NUMBER
OF UPDATES IN REGARDS TO CALAIS
SPECIFICALLY A PROPOSED DELAY IN
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF CARVING IN
I. C. F. T. D.'S FROM JANUARY
ONE OF TWENTY THREE. A TO JULY
OF TWENTY THREE REALLY JUST
GIVING US MORE TIME TO HAVE
CONVERSATIONS BETWEEN THESE
CRITICAL PARTNERS. AND OUR
MANAGED CARE PLANS. YOU ALSO SEE
A FLIGHT OF THE IMPLEMENTATION
UPDATE IN REGARDS TO THE
POPULATION HEALTH MANAGEMENT
SERVICE A WELL WE ARE OUT FOR
OUR A FEW RIGHT NOW WE DO WANT
TO MAKE SURE WE DO SOME SMALL
TESTING AND PILOTING WITH KEY
GROUPS. AND SO WE ARE ALSO
DELAYING THAT FROM JULY ONE OF
TWENTY THREE. A SORRY JANUARY
ONE OF TWENTY THREE TO JULY OF
TWENTY THREE I WITHIN THE BUDGET
PROPOSAL- WE ALSO ARE MAKING A
NUMBER OF ADJUSTMENTS IN REGARDS
TO TRANSITIONS IN MANAGED CARE.
IDENTIFYING SOME KEY POPULATION
THE MOVE IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWO AND ENSURING THAT THOSE
SMOOTHLY TRANSITION IN JULY OF
TWENTY THREE ALL IN ALIGNMENT
WITH OUR PREVIOUS CALLING EIGHT
CODES AND PROPOSALS. YOU HAVE
UPDATED THE JUSTICE PACKAGE A TO
MAKE SURE IT REFLECTS IN
EXPANDED PHARMACY SERVICE FOR
THE IN RE SERVICES THAT WE WOULD
BE. COVERING OFF SOMEONE IS
INCARCERATED WITH IN OUR CALLIN
JUSTICE PROPOSAL. UP AND WE HAVE
UPDATED THE TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO INCLUDE THE NINETY
DAYS THAT ULTIMATELY WAS-
CURRENTLY BEING NEGOTIATED WITH
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT- WE ALSO
INCLUDED GENERAL FUND TO COVER
THE DISH BE FUNDS. CONTINUE TO
NEGOTIATE WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HOPING TO BRING THE
THINGS THE CONCLUSION IN EARLY
SUMMER. YOU ALL SUPPOSED.
FAILING TRAILER BILL REALLY
TOOK. THE FINAL S. BETWEEN US
AND THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. OF
IN REGARDS TO THE BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH COUNTY RECRUITMENT UPDATE
WITHIN THE- THE BUDGET WE WOULD
JUST NOTE THAT THE MAY REVISION
UPDATES THE COUNTY RECRUITMENT
AMOUNTS- FOR BOTH ISSUES ARE ALL
ISSUES AROUND COUNTY RECRUITMENT
AND WE DO DELAY THOSE
RECRUITMENT BY ONE YEAR WITHIN
THE BUDGET. ADDITIONALLY THERE
ARE NEW OPIOID SETTLEMENT FUNDS
BEING PROPOSED I WOULD THINK
THIRTY POINT ONE MILLION TIME
OPIOID SETTLEMENT. MAINLY GOING
NALOXONE TO HOMELESS A SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER UP PROVIDER WORKFORCE
TRAINING BOTH PREVIOUSLY
PROPOSED ADDITIONAL DOLLARS TO
THOSE. ALREADY PROPOSED.
INVESTMENT WE ARE ALSO ASKING
FOR- DOLLARS FOR A- CAL HSS IN
REGARDS TO THE LAUNCHING OF THE
STAKEHOLDER PLANNING PROCESS FOR
THE LONG TERM PLANNING AROUND
THE CRISIS CONTINUE ON. A TO
PLAN OUT FOR THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF NINE EIGHT EIGHT CRISIS
INTERVENTION STATEWIDE AS WE
BUILD OUT THOSE INVEST. AND WE
ALSO ARE ASKING FOR US IN
CHANGES IN REGARDS TO CLINICAL
TRIALS TO COME INTO COMPLIANCE
WITH FEDERAL LAW- WHICH HAS IT
IN A REMARK ABOUT FOUR POINT
THREE MILLION TOTAL FUNDS IN
TRAILER BILL TO COME INTO.
COMPLIANCE THEIR- OF WE'RE ALSO
HAVE A JOINT PRESENTED A REQUEST
BETWEEN US AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF AGING TO TRANSFER
THE CARE GIVER RESOURCE CENTER
EXPENDITURES FORTY. A TO THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF AGING.
AND LASTLY WOULD JUST KNOW
THERE'S A NUMBER OF BUDGET
UPDATES IN REGARDS TO THE
CHILDREN AND YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH INITIATIVE A DOLLAR
FIFTEEN THE HOME COMMUNITY BASED
SPENDING PLAN A PROP FIFTY SIX
PAYMENTS AND LASTLY UPDATED
NUMBERS IN REGARDS TO THIS
EXPANSION A FULL SCOPE MEDI CAL
COVERAGE REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS. THAT
CONCLUDES OUR COM. THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ANY
COMMENTS. PATTERSON SHEFFIELD
BERMAN FINANCE NO COMMENTS.
THANK YOU HELLO IN THE COMMENTS
. AFTERNOON LIQUOR'S MORROW THE
L. L. YOU HEAR ME OK. AND WE ARE
CONTINUING TO VIEW THE
PROPOSALS- BUT A FEW OF THEM
WE'VE BROUGHT ONE TO DISCUSS ANY
OF THE CAR AFTER I'VE HAD SHE'D
AFTER I FINISH MY COMMENTS ON
FIRST ON THE RETENTION PAYMENTS
TO HEALTH CARE WORKERS- WE ARE
WAITING FOR THE DETAILS ON THE
STRUCTURE. OF THE PAYMENTS
INCLUDE THE SPECIFIC CRITERIA OF
WHO WOULD BE ELIGIBLE FOR THE
PAYMENTS- BUTTOCK. AND WE'D ALSO
NOTE THAT ON. THE QUESTION OF TO
THE EXTENT TO WHICH THE PAYMENTS
WOULD ACTUALLY IMPROVE RETENTION
WHICH WE UNDERSTAND IS ONE OF
THE GOALS OF THE PAYMENTS- WE
ALSO ARE LOOKING INTO WHETHER OR
THIS WOULD BE A CONSTITUTIONAL
USE OF THE FUNDS AND OF THE
STATE CONSTITUTION. THAT'S THERE
IS A RESTRICTION ON THE USE OF
PUBLIC FUNDS WHEN GIVEN TO
PRIVATE ENTITIES. IT'S UNCLEAR
THAT IS PUTTING ITS APARTMENTS-
I WILL NOW TURN IT OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE CORY ISHIDA. THANK YOU
DR AMBULANT AND MEMBERS- KOREAN
SHEET WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S OFFICE- WE HAVE SOME
INITIAL COMMENTS TO RAISE ON THE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISION CARE
COURT PROPOSALS- WHICH CUT
ACROSS MULTIPLE DEPARTMENTS
INCLUDING BCS- WE HAVE NOT.
FULLY REVIEWED THE- DIETZ THE S.
B. C. P. ATTACHED TO CARE COURT
YET BUT WE ANTICIPATE DOING THAT
SOON- IN ADDITION TO THE-
ROUGHLY FIFTEEN MILLION WITH ONE
MILLION ON GOING PROPOSED. FOR
DH CS THE GOVERNOR ALSO PROPOSES
ROUGHLY FORTY MILLION WITH ABOUT
THIRTY EIGHT MILLION ON GOING.
TO THE JUDICIAL BRANCH TO FOR
COURT PROCEEDINGS ASSOCIATED
WITH CARE COURT. AND TEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
AGING TO ADMINISTER THE CARE
COURT. A SUPPORTER PROGRAM- WE
UNDERSTAND THAT THE IMPLEMENTING
LANGUAGE FOR CARE COURT IS
CURRENTLY AND SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT. OF THIS
BILL IS CURRENTLY GOING THROUGH
THE POLICY PROCESS AND MAY
CONTINUE TO CHANGE AND EVOLVE
GOING FORWARD. ACCORDINGLY THIS
MEANS THAT THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF
FUNDING NEEDED AT THE STATE AND
LOCAL LEVEL TO ENSURE CARE
COURTS OPERATE AS INTENDED-
DEPENDS STRONGLY ON THE SPECIFIC
PROCESSES AND REQUIREMENTS
INCLUDED IN THE FINAL
LEGISLATION. ADDITIONALLY WE
WOULD NOTE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION ACKNOWLEDGES THAT
IT IS STILL WORKING WITH
COUNTIES. TO IDENTIFY ASSOCIATED
COSTS. WHICH ARE LIKELY
SIGNIFICANT- WHEN YOU WHEN
THINKING ABOUT CARE COURT-
WITHOUT FULLY IDENTIFIED STATE
AND LOCAL BECAUSE IT'S DIFFICULT
FOR THE TO WEIGH
THIS PROPOSAL AGAINST THE OTHER
GENERAL FUND PRIORITIES- IN
ADDITION THERE ARE A NUMBER OF
KEY CONSIDERATIONS. THAT COULD
ALSO IMPACT WHAT LEVEL OF
FUNDING IS NEEDED TO ADMINISTER
THE CARE COURT PROGRAM. THESE
INCLUDE FOR EXAMPLE HOW EXISTING
PROGRAMS SUCH AS MEDICARE OUR
ARE SUPPOSED TO INTERACT WITH
CARE COURT- AND WHAT IF ANY
ADDITIONAL LOCAL CAPACITY IS
NEEDED TO ENSURE THE PROGRAM
RUNS WELL- ACCORDINGLY WE THINK
THAT IT'S PREMATURE TO CONSIDER
THE GOVERNOR'S. MAY REVISION
BUDGET PROPOSALS IN THIS AREA AT
THIS TIME- THOSE ARE ALL OF OUR
COMMENTS ON ON THE DCS ITEMS
TODAY AND- WORK. ANSWER ANY
FURTHER QUESTIONS AT THE AT THE
END OF THE PRESENTATION. THANK
YOU NEXT COULD WE HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH. WHO
WILL BE APPEARING REMOTELY. FOR
THE CDPH MAY REVISE PROPOSAL.
YOU MISTER CHAIR CAN YOU HEAR ME
OK. LOUD AND CLEAR RIGHT. SURE
MY NAME'S BRANDON ANDERSON THE
CHIEF DEPUTY FOR OPERATIONS HERE
AT THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND I'M GONNA GO THROUGH
SOME OF OUR DEPARTMENTS MAY
REVISION HIGHLIGHTS AS WELL SOME
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS. THE FIRST
ITEM THAT I'D HIGHLIGHT FOR YOU
OUR UPDATES OR CO IN NINETEEN
DIRECT RESPONSE EXPENDITURES
SPECIFICALLY THREE ITEMS THREE
FIFTY TO THREE EIGHTY TWO AND
THREE EIGHTY THREE IN OUR MAYOR
VIDEO LETTER. THESE ISSUES REAL
TO PREVIOUS CONVERSATIONS WE'VE
BEEN HAVING WITH YOU IN THE
LEGISLATURE RELATED TO OUR
CALVET NINETEEN RESPONSE NEEDS-
AS YOU'RE ALL AWARE THE
ADMINISTRATION SMARTER PLAN WAS
RELEASED IN FEBRUARY- IN ORDER
TO IMPLEMENT THE SMARTER PLAN
THE MAYOR VISION INCLUDES AN
INCREASE OF ONE POINT ONE
BILLION FOR KOBE NINETEEN
RELATED RESPONSE COSTS. THIS
WILL CONTINUE TO HELP US SUPPORT
OUR ONGOING TESTING AND
LABORATORY NETWORK COST
VACCINATION DISTRIBUTION AND
MEDICAL SEARCH STAFFING TO
HIGHLIGHT A FEW. ARM THE MAYOR
VISION LETTER BEFORE YOU IS
REQUESTING ONE POINT EIGHT
BILLION FROM THE CALIFORNIA
MERCY RELIEF FUND- THIS RELIEF
FUND WILL NOW BE SUPPORTING THE
COVER NINETEEN RESPONSE EFFORTS
GOING FORWARD. AND INCLUDES THE
ONE POINT ONE BILLION THAT I
JUST MENTIONED FOR THE MAYOR
VISION UPDATE AS WELL AS SEVEN
HUNDRED MILLION THAT WAS
ORIGINALLY INCLUDED ACT
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FOR COVERED
RELATED BECAUSE IT'S BEING
SHIFTED FROM THE GENERAL FUND-
THE INITIAL GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
PLAN FOR COVERED COSTS-
ORIGINALLY IDENTIFIED COSTS
THROUGH DECEMBER THIRTY FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY TWO. HOWEVER THE
EXTENT AND DURATION OF DIRECT
RESPONSE ACTIVITIES HAS EXCEEDED
THOSE EARLIER ASSUMPTIONS AND SO
NOW WE'RE ANTICIPATING FOR YOUR
COST FOR BUDGET YEAR TO JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY THREE- WHICH
AND THE ESTIMATE ALSO INCLUDES-
INCORPORATES ACTIVITIES RELATED
TO THE SMARTER PLAN- THIS ISSUE
ALSO INCLUDES THE INCREASE
REIMBURSEMENTS BY A HUNDRED
MILLION TO RECOVER COSTS FOR THE
DEPLOYMENT OF MEDICAL SEARCH
STAFF THAT WAS BROUGHT UP IN THE
M. SAID GENDER EARLIER- AND ALSO
A NEW TO THE MAYOR VERSION
INCLUDES A TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS CONTINGENCY
FUNDING FOR CODE RELATED
ACTIVITIES- OUTSIDE OF COVERT
RESPONSE THERE'S A COUPLE OF-
HIGH LEVEL ITEMS THAT I'D- LIKE
FOR YOU- IN THE AREA OF
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH AWARENESS
EDUCATION AND RESEARCH- WE HAVE
A SEVENTEEN MILLION DOLLAR ONE
TIME GENERAL FUND APPROPRIATION
REQUEST TO SUPPORT THE BROADER
ADMINISTRATIONS- INITIATIVE
PROTECT THE RIGHT. TO SAVE AN
EXTRA PROTECT HEALTHCARE
SERVICES- SPECIFICALLY FOR OUR
DEPARTMENT THE FUNDING INCLUDES
FIFTEEN MILLION GENERAL FUND FOR
GRANTS TO CBO'S TO CONDUCT
MEDICALLY ACCURATE AND
CULTURALLY COMPETENT OUTREACH
AND EDUCATION ON SEXUAL HEALTH
AND REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH ISSUES
ANOTHER MILLION IS BEING
PROVIDED FOR US TO DEVELOP AND
MAINTAIN A COMPREHENSIVE
REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS WEBSITE AND
THEN ANOTHER MILLION TO GENERAL
FUND TO- FOR RESEARCH- ON THE
UNMET NEEDS FOR ACCESS TO
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE
SERVICES. IN THE AREA OF
CHILDREN YOU SUICIDE PREVENTION-
THERE WAS FORTY MILLION GENERAL
FUND ONE TIME INCLUDED IN OUR
BUDGET- AVAILABLE FOR US FOR
EXPENDITURE THROUGH JUNE
THIRTIETH OF TWENTY FIVE- AND
THIS IS PART OF THE
ADMINISTRATION'S INITIATIVE TO
ADDRESS BEHAVIORAL HEALTH NEEDS
OF CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
YOUTH I'M FOR US THE FUNDING
WILL BE USED TO DEVELOP AND
IMPLEMENT A DATA DRIVEN TARGETED
COMMUNITY BASED USE SUICIDE
PREVENTION PROGRAM FOR USE AT.
INCREASED RISK OF SUICIDE AND
LUDING BLACK NATIVE. HISPANIC
AND FOSTER USE- THERE'S ALSO A
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR ONE TIME
GENERAL FUND INCREASE TO SUPPORT
GRANTS TO COUNTIES AND
EXPERIENCE CBO'S TO PARTNER TO
IMPROVE CAPACITY TRAINING. AND
CULTURALLY RESPONSIVE CARE TO
THE NEEDS AND PROTECTIONS OF
LGBTQ PLUS YOU- IN THE AREA OF
SICKLE CELL THERE'S BEEN A
NUMBER OF INVESTMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN INCLUDED IN OUR BUDGET OVER
THE YEAR- THIS TIME THE MAY
REVISION- THERE'S A FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR GENERAL FUND ONE TIME-
INCREASED TO SUPPORT THE
NETWORKING CALIFORNIA SICKLE
CELL CARE INITIATIVE- AS I
MENTIONED THIS INITIATIVE BUILDS
ON INVESTMENTS OF. FIFTEEN
MILLION THAT WAS INCLUDED IN THE
TWENTY NINETEEN BUDGET ACT- THAT
WAS A MADE IT MADE AVAILABLE TO
US THROUGH JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY
TWO AND THEN ONE AND A HALF
MILLION THAT WAS- APPROPRIATED
AND NEED TWENTY ONE BUDGET ACT.
I'M IN THE AREA OF EXTREME HEAT-
THERE'S A INCREASE IN OUR BUDGET
THAT REFLECTS A THREE MILLION
DOLLAR ONE TIME INCREASE. THAT
AGAIN IS AVAILABLE TO US THROUGH
JUNE OF TWENTY TWENTY FIVE- TO
IMPLEMENT THE EXTREME HEAT
ACTION PLAN N. AS THIS IS ALSO
PART OF THE ADMINISTRATION'S
LARGER EXTREME HE PLANNED
EFFORT- IN THIS PART OF THE
PROPOSAL WILL HELP FACILITATE.
ENHANCED PROTECTIONS FOR
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS THAT WILL
BE ADMINISTERED THROUGH OUR
CENTER FOR HEALTHY COMMUNITIES-
SPECIFICALLY OCCUPATIONAL HEALTH
BRANCH. ALONG WITH- ARE ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION GOING TO OUR
CENTER FOR HEALTH CARE QUALITY
SO ONE POINT FIVE MILLION EACH
OF THE THREE MILLION TO THOSE
TWO CENTERS. I'M RELATED TO
OPIOID PUBLIC AWARENESS- THERE
IS TWO POINT SEVEN MILLION. IN
OPIOID SETTLEMENT FUNDS THAT'S
INCLUDED IN OUR BUDGET TO
DEVELOP AND SUPPORT TO PUBLIC
AWARENESS CAMPAIGNS. TARGETED
TOWARDS USED. OPIOID EDUCATION
AND FAT NOW RISK EDUCATION. AND
THEN FINALLY THE LAST THING I'D
HIGHLIGHT BEFORE SOME TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENTS INCLUDE THE SKILLED
NURSING FACILITIES STAFF IN
AUDITS. THE ITEM HERE INCLUDE
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL
FUND- ONE TIME TO SUPPORT. TRADE
ACTIVITIES ASSOCIATE WITH THE
SKILLED NURSING FACILITY
WORKFORCE AND QUALITY INCENTIVE
PROGRAM- SPECIFICALLY THIS
FUNDING IS GOING TO BE USED TO
SUPPORT THE WORKLOAD OF THE
STAFFING AUDIT SECTION. FOR
SKINNER SANTA SORTIES- MINIMUM
STAFFING REQUIREMENTS AUDITS.
AND THEN FINALLY THE REMAINDER
OF OUR MAYOR VISION LETTER
INCLUDES SOME TECHNICAL.
ADJUSTMENTS SPECIFICALLY WE HAVE
FOR REAPPROPRIATION ITEMS-
RELATED TO ONE RELATED TO
CHILDREN AND YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
AND HIS DEATH- A PUBLIC. YOU CAN
RE APPROPRIATE- WE RECEIVED FIVE
NO IN THE- TWENTY TWENTY ONE
BUDGET ACT- THAT WERE LOOKING TO
RE APPROPRIATE AND MAKE THAT
AVAILABLE TO US OR JUNE OF JUNE
THIRTIETH OF TWENTY FOUR- SOME
FUNDING RELATED TO TRANSGENDER
WELLNESS AND EQUITY FUND AT THE
EQUITY FUND WE RECEIVED THIRTEEN
MILLION IN THE BUDGET ACT OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE- WE LOOK TO RE
APPROPRIATE THAT AND MAKE THAT
AVAILABLE THROUGH JUNE OF TWENTY
FIVE- THIS FUNDING WOULD
ADMINISTER THE TRANSGENDER
WELLNESS IN EQUITY FUND GRANT
PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES GRANTS TO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS.
THAT SERVE TRANSGENDER GENDER
NON CONFORMING OR INTERSEX
INDIVIDUALS- AND THEN FINALLY WE
HAVE ANOTHER APPROPRIATE
REAPPROPRIATION RATHER ITEM FOR
THE ALL CHILDREN THRIVE
IMPLEMENTATION. PROGRAM THIS IS
AGAIN ANOTHER TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENT THAT REVERBERATES TWO
POINT SIX MILLION IN MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES ACT FUNDS FROM
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN BUDGET ACT.
TO MAKE PAYMENT ON SOME INVOICES
INTO COMPLETE EVALUATION
ACTIVITIES FORTY ALL CHILDREN
THRIVE PROGRAM. AND THEN FINALLY
WE HAVE A COUPLE DIFFERENT
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS BASED ON
BCPS ARE ESTIMATES THAT WERE
PROVIDED AT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET- SPECIFICALLY TO
HIGHLIGHT- OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
ELECTRONIC LICENSING PROGRAM
WE'RE GOING TO THE PROCESS OF
AUTOMATING- SOME- MANUALLY BASED
SYSTEMS WITH OUR LAB FIELD
SERVICES PROGRAM- TWO DIFFERENT
SPECIAL FUNDS GO TO SUPPORT THAT
UPON FURTHER REVIEW WE
IDENTIFIED THAT- THE KIND OF.
THERE NEEDED TO BEA NEW MIX OF
FUNDING SOURCES FOR THAT SO THIS
MAYOR VISION- ADJUSTMENT MAKES
THAT TECHNICAL CORRECTION- WE
HAVE UPDATES TO OUR THREE
ESTIMATES THAT WE- UPDATED MAYOR
VISION SPECIFICALLY FOR OUR AIDS
DRUG ASSISTANCE PROGRAM. ARE
WOMEN INFANTS AND CHILDREN
PROGRAM AND OUR GENETIC DISEASE
SCREENING PROGRAM ALL OF THOSE
ARE SIMPLY TECHNICAL ARCHIE
UPDATES RELATED TO EITHER-
CASELOAD JUDGMENTS BASED ON NEW
DATA THAT'S BEEN PROVIDED TO US
OR- BASED ON IN THE- RELATED TO
THE JAGS YOU SCREAM- YOU BIRTH
DATA FROM DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
AND THEN FINALLY- RELATED TO
SOME OF OUR- PROP NINETY NINE
TOBACCO EXPENDITURE ACCOUNTS ON
THESE AGAIN ARE JUST TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENTS FOR OUR TOBACCO TAX
SUPPORTED PROGRAMS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE MAKES UPDATES TO THESE
DIFFERENT FUNDS- AT A REVISION.
SO THESE CHANGES THAT ARE
HIGHLIGHTED IN THE MAYOR VISION
ARE SIMPLY TO- THAT TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT THOSE NEW REVENUE
PROJECTIONS AND MAKE-
APPROPRIATION CHANGES
ACCORDINGLY. AND THAT CONCLUDES
MY PRESENTATION HAPPY TO TAKE.
QUESTIONS WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT OF.
AFTERNOON EXPELS DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE NOTHING TO ADD AT THIS
TIME LEO IN THE COMMONS. THANK
YOU MISTER. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS MARK NEWTON WITH
THE ALEJO WHILE WE'RE STILL
REVIEWING THE VARIOUS CD PH
PROPOSALS WE DO HAVE ONE
PROPOSAL ARE ON WHERE WE HAVE
INITIAL TAKE ON THE PROPOSAL.
GIVEN THAT IT RAISES SOME
INITIAL CONCERNS ARE THE
PROPOSAL RELATES TO THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
SHIFT A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS GENERAL FUND ON
THE DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
TO A NEW OFFICE WITHIN THE
OFFICE OF PLANNING RESEARCH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF PLANNING
RESEARCH THE SUPPORT COVERT
NINETEEN VACCINE RELATED PUBLIC
EDUCATION AND OUTREACH. OUR
INTERVIEW IS THAT SHIFTING THIS
RESPONSIBILITY WHILE THE
PANDEMIC REMAINS SERVE ON GOING
ON COULD DELAY THE DISSEMINATION
OF IMPORTANT INFORMATION ON
VACCINES AND OTHER PUBLIC HEALTH
LAB RELATED- MEASURES. THE SHIFT
COULD RESULT IN POTENTIAL
DUPLICATION AND MIXED MESSAGING.
AND AVOIDING THESE OUTCOMES SUCH
AS MIXED MESSAGING AS WE THINK
ONE OF THE LESSONS THAT HAS BEEN
LEARNED FROM THE PANDEMIC. SO AS
WE FIND OUT MORE DETAILS OF THIS
PROPOSAL- WE WILL PROVIDE
FURTHER ANALYSIS TO THE
LEGISLATURE BUT WE THINK IT DOES
RAISE SOME INITIAL- INITIAL
CONCERNS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT COULD WE HAVE THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
SPEAKERS FOR THE D. S. H. MAY
REVISE PROPOSALS COME FORWARD.
GOOD AFTERNOON RIGHT. A GOOD
AFTERNOON SHERRIN MEMBERS-
STEPHANIE CLENDENIN DIRECTOR FOR
THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE. THE
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
GOVERNOR'S MAY REVISE THE VISION
BUDGET INCLUDES A BUDGET OF
THREE POINT TWO BILLION THREE
BILLION GENERAL FUND FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF STATE HOSPITALS
THE PROPOSED BUDGET INCLUDES
INVESTMENTS TO CONTINUE THE
DEPARTMENT'S EFFORTS TOWARDS
MEETING THE NEEDS OF AN INCREASE
SERVICES DEMANDS FOR.
INDIVIDUALS FOUND DEEMED
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL
IMPROVING THE DEPARTMENT'S
OPERATIONS AND DELIVERY OF
SERVICES AND STATE HOSPITAL
FACILITY REPAIRS AND
IMPROVEMENTS. I'M A PROVIDE A
BRIEF OVERVIEW OF THE ITEMS
CONTAINED IN THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCE LETTER. OF FOR I. S. T.
SOLUTIONS THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
DID INCLUDE FUNDING AS A SET
ASIDE FOR THE DEPARTMENT- TO
IMPLEMENT SOLUTIONS- TO ADDRESS
THE WAIT LIST OF INDIVIDUALS
FOUND INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL
AND WHO ARE NEEDING RESTORATION
OF COMPETENCIES TREATMENT
SERVICES. AND THIS INCLUDED
IMPLEMENTING EARLY STABILIZATION
SERVICES IMPLEMENTING CARE
COORDINATION TEAMS AN INCREASE
WAITLIST MANAGEMENT MANNING I S.
T. DIVERSION A COMMUNITY BASED
RESTORATION ESTABLISHING A NEW
INDEPENDENT PLACEMENT
DETERMINATION PANEL AND
IMPLEMENTING A COUNTY I S. T.
REFERRAL GROWTH CAP. OVERALL THE
MAY REVISION PROPOSES TO NOW
MOVE THAT FUNDING INTO. THE
DEPARTMENT- THE BUDGET FROM THE
SENATE. AND IT RIGHT AN INCREASE
OF SIXTY SIX POINT FIVE MILLION
ONGOING AND TOTAL FOR I USED TO
REASONS ABOUT THE GOVERNOR'S
BUDGET LEVEL. THE MAY REVISION
UPDATES TO THIS PROPOSAL ARE
BASED UPON STAKEHOLDER FEEDBACK
THAT WE'VE OBTAINED SENSE I'M
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET AND NEEDS THAT
ARE IDENTIFIED DURING
IMPLEMENTATION PLANNING. AND
ADDS TO ADDITIONAL AYE IT'S T.
SOLUTIONS SOME OF THE
SIGNIFICANT CHANGES TO THE
PREVIOUSLY PROPOSED SOLUTION
INCLUDE FUNDING FOR SHERIFF'S
DEPUTY COSTS TO SUPPORT
PROVIDING EARLY STABILIZATION
SERVICES WHILE THE HIGHEST HE'S
ARE IN JAIL. UPDATES TO- THE
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDING SCHEDULE
FROM THREE YEARS TO FOUR YEARS
TO FULLY IMPLEMENT THE FIVE
THOUSAND DEDICATED BEDS.
INCREASING THE ONE TIME FUNDING
FOR INFRASTRUCTURE FROM AN
AVERAGE OF THREE HUNDRED FIFTY
PER UNIT TO SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
PER UNIT SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND PER UNIT. ADDING TWENTY
SUPPORT CAN A MINISTRY COSTS
CONSISTENT WITH A OVERHEAD RATES
ALLOWED BY MEDIKAL. ADDING
FUNDING FOR COURT LAYS IN
POSITIONS I'M INCREASING THE
REIMBURSEMENT- I'M PAID TO SHARE
ARMS OR A- THEIR COSTS FOR AN
ICED TEA REEVALUATION. AND
UPDATES TO THE ICE TO GROWTH.
HAVE YOU NEW SOLUTIONS WERE
ADDED AND THIS- THESE INCLUDE
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
TO THE DEPARTMENT TO SUPPORT BY
S. T. DISCHARGE PLANNING AND
COORDINATION. WITH THE COUNTY IS
TO ENABLE COUNTIES TO PLAN FOR
CONTINUITY OF TREATMENT WHEN THE
AYE IS HE IS RELEASED FROM JAIL.
AND PROVIDES FUNDING FOR D. S.
H. TO PARTNER WITH THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL TO PROVIDE TRAINING FOR
EMAILING US TO IMPROVE THE
QUALITY OF EVALUATION USE FOR
IDEAS TO DETERMINATIONS AND
DECISIONS NEEDING THE- AND THEN
AND- GIVE ME A NEED FOR MEDICAID. I WITH THREE TO THE BAY REVIEW
WERE FOR DEVELOPMENT PROPOS. A
THE MAY RIVER FROM AHEAD AND
SOME NINE. AND TWENTY TWO THREE
TO FIND A LIMB TERM BECAUSE
THEY- TO SUPPORT A PLANT EFFORTS
TO FUTURE. TOOK THANK YOU
ENTERED RESERVING TRAINING. TO
OTHER STATE. WE HAVE THIS.
PSYCHIATRY RESIDENCY AT OUR
STATE HOW. THAT STARTED A TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WITH SEVEN RESIN AND
JUST RECENTLY MET SEVEN ADDITION
RESIN. THAT WILL START THE
SUMMER VERY PROBLEM. I WE FOR
THE BAY REVIEW. TEAM HOW TO DO.
OF EIGHT POINT THREE MILLION IN
GENERAL FUND INTO TWO TO THREE.
NINE POINT FORMALLY AND THREE
TWENTY FOUR. AND TWENTY FOUR TO
FIVE AND POINT FOUR POINT SEVEN
IN TWENTY TWENTY. AND THIS
REFLECTS TIME. THIS WITH THE
HIRING FOR TEAM REESE. THIS IS
RELATED TO TWENTY NINE POINT
FIVE. THAT WERE PRE OFF THEIR TO
PAY IN A THE BY YEAR. THIS WAS
THE POSITIONS TO FUTURE- OF THE
FOR YEAR PHASE IN PLAN. THAT WAS
ORIGINALLY ALL RIGHT INTO NOT IN
THE- OVERALL TIME PERIOD FOR THE
TREATMENT RE. TO BE. HAVE FOR
KOBE NINETY DIRECT RESPONSE
EXPENDITURES. PROPOSES AN-
EIGHTEEN POINT FIVE MILLION AND
TWO THREE. AN HOUR. THE COVER
NINETEEN. IN THE- EMERGENCY
RELIEF I RATHER THE GENERAL FOR
THAT OF. AND THE FUNDING A TRUST
THREE REFLECTS IN. PERSONAL
SERVER. OPERATING EXPENSE INTO
POP BASED ON CURRENT ACTION. AND
THEY CAN. USE OF THE NORM
ALTERNATE CARE FACILITY PRINTED
. APPROVED COOLING FREDDIE IT CO
GOVERNOR. TO CONFER A
RESIDENTIAL. UNIT AND IF FOR TO
MY DOLLARS TWENTY SEVEN POINT
THREE THREE POSITIONS TO CONVERT
IT AN INTER. CARE FACILITY AND
IS TO ADDRESS HIGHER LEVEL- OF
CARE NEEDED FOR OUR AGING
POPULATION ABOUT THE FACILITY. I
THE CONDITION REALLY PRO FOR
INSECT VIOLENT. PROPOSES POINTS
MILLION IN TWO POSITIONS IN
TWENTY TWO TWENTY THREE AND
THREE POINT ONE MILLION IN TWO
POSITIONS ON GOING TO SUPPORT A
PROJECTED INCREASE IN CASE WE-
AND PROGRAM OPERATING COSTS FOR
STAFFING HOUSING SB FEES THAT
WE BEEN WORK TO CAN RELEASE IN
THE- OUR JAIL BASED. TREATMENT
AND EXISTING PROGRAMS PROPOSES
THREE SEVEN MILLION TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE. AND FOUR POINT
EIGHT MILLION IN TWENTY THREE
TWENTY FOUR AND I'M GOING TO.
THE INCREASE. AND OPERATIONAL
COSTS TO MAINTAIN AND EXPAND
EXISTING GBC TO PROGRAMS. OR-
ALSO FOR JAIL BASED COMPETENCY
TREATMENT PROGRAMS THE BUDGET-
PROPOSED BUDGET INCLUDES TWO
HUNDRED AND FOUR THOUSAND IN THE
BUDGET YEAR TO SUPPORT THE
ACTIVATION OF ONE NEW JOB IS
COME TO SEEK TREATMENT PROGRAM.
AND PROVIDE CORRESPONDING
PATIENTS RIGHT ADVOCACY SERVICES
FOR THE PROGRAM. OR OF THE
CONDITIONALLY CONDITIONAL
RELEASE PROGRAM FOR. ALL OF OUR
OTHER PATIENTS OF THE NON
SEXUALLY VIOLENT PREDATOR
PATIENTS THIS INCLUDES AN
INCREASE OF THREE POINT SEVEN
MILLION IN TWENTY TWO TWENTY
THREE AND TWO POINT FIVE
POSITIONS AND FOUR POINT TWO
MILLION ONGOING TO SUPPORT NEW%
PROGRAM ACTIVATION STAFFING AN
INCREASE OF A SLIM COSTS. OR THE
ENHANCE TREATMENT PROGRAM
STAFFING. INCLUDES A ONE TIME
INCREASE OF TWO HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THREE THOUSAND AND BUDGET
YEAR. AND THIS IS ADJUSTING THE
REDUCTION THAT WOULD PROPOSE THE
GOVERNOR'S BUDGET FROM EIGHT
POINT NINE MILLION DOWN TO EIGHT
POINT SIX MILLION. FUNDING WILL
BE USED FOR AN ANTICIPATED
EQUIPMENT FACILITY MODIFICATIONS
AND- NEEDED FOR THE NEW ENHANCE
MY PROGRAM. I FOR THE COUNTY BED
BILLING REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY
ITEM THIS IS AN INCREASE OF NINE
POINT TWO MILLION IN GENERAL
FUND REIMBURSEMENT AUTHORITY TO
REFLECT ANTICIPATED INCREASE. IN
COLLECTIONS FROM THE COUNTY IS
DUE TO AN UPDATED DAILY BED RATE
FOR THE LANTERN AND PAT SHORT
PATIENCE AND I. S. T. DEPENDENCE
THAT- I'VE BEEN DEEMED NON
RESTORE BALL OR REACH ME. THE
MOMENT. WHO ARE NOT TRANSPORTED
AND RETURN TO THE COMMITTEE
COUNTY AND IT MANNER. THE NEW
RATES AND NEGOTIATED WITH THE
COUNTY SAN ARE ANTICIPATED TO
BECOME EFFECTIVE JULY ONE. FOR
THAT- THE NEXT- SOME TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENTS ON THE- REVISION-
PROPOSES THREE APPROPRIATIONS OF
UNSPENT FUNDING FOR FIVE ITEMS.
AND THIS WOULD BE TO CONTINUE
FUNDING ABILITY FOR AVAILABILITY
THREE JUNE THIRTIETH TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. THIS IS FIVE POINT
FOUR MILLION FOR THE HEALTHCARE
PROVIDER NETWORK APPOINT ONE
MILLION FOR THE MISSION BASED
REVIEW TREATMENT TEAM. FOUR
POINT ONE MILLION FOR THE I. S.
T. RE EVALUATIONS. FIVE MILLION
PER I. S. T. VERSION AND FIFTEEN
POINT THREE MILLION PRIZE. AND
FINALLY- OR WITH RESPECT TO
CAPITAL OUTLAY THE MAY REVISION
REVISION INCLUDES ADJUSTMENTS
FOR THREE EXISTING PROJECTS. A
FOR THE ATASCADERO- POSSIBLE
WATER BOOSTER PUMP SYSTEM
PROJECT. PROPOSES A HUNDRED
FORTY THOUSAND ONE TIME FOR
CONSTRUCTION COST- INCREASES IN
THE RELATED TO THAT. CREASE IN
THE CALIFORNIA CONSTRUCTION COST
INDEX. FOR THE METROPOLITAN
CONSOLIDATION OF POLICE
OPERATIONS PROJECT. PROPOSES TO
RE APPROPRIATE THE CONSTRUCTION
PHASE FOR THE FUNDING TO ALLOW
FOR THE COMPLETION OF REGULATORY
REVIEWS AND APPROVALS. IN THE
WORKING DRAWINGS PHASE IN AN
INCREASE OF FIVE POINT FIVE
MILLION ONE TIME FOR
CONSTRUCTION. REFLECTING AN
INCREASE IN THE CPI. WELL AND
THEN. I FOR PATENT FIRE ALARM
SYSTEM UPGRADE HAS SUPPLEMENTAL
APPROPRIATION OF TWELVE POINT
TWO MILLION TO ADDRESS
ADDITIONAL I AM A SUBMITTED TO
COMPLETE THE PROJECT BASED ON.
RESTRUCTURING THE PROJECT BASED
ON LIMITED SWING SPACE
AVAILABILITY WITHIN THE HOSPITAL
DID A KOPEN- PRESSURES AS WELL
AS BLOOD PRESSURE IS A STATE OF
WITH R. I. S. T. WEIGHTLESS. IT
ALSO REFLECTS AN ADJUSTMENT TO.
OR IN A- DUE TO THE INSTRUCTING
IN THE CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN HONG
NOTHING FURTHER THAT. HELLO ANY
COMMENTS THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
NUMBERS CORE ISSUE TO WITH THE
L. A- WE'RE STILL REVIEWING THE
DEPARTMENT'S PROPOSALS AND WILL
FOLLOW UP IF WE IDENTIFY ANY
ISSUES THE FLAG. THANK YOU NEXT
WE WILL HAVE COMMISSIONS
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR DR TOBY
EWING. PRESENT ON THE
COMMISSION'S PROPOSALS. OR.
THANK MEDICARE MEMBERS ARE WE ON
GREAT I APPRECIATE THE CHANCE TO
JOIN TUESDAY TO BE DOING ON
BEHALF MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY
COMMISSION WILL BE VERY BRIEF WE
HAVE FIVE PROPOSALS FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION- I. PASSED AS YOU
KNOW THE- RECEIVES FUNDING IN
THE ANNUAL BUDGET TO SUPPORT
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH THROUGH
OUR SPD TO TRIP CRISIS. YEAH
IT'S GRANT PROGRAM. THAT PROGRAM
REALLY FOCUSES ON CRISIS
RESPONSE IT LIMITS OUR ABILITY
TO PROVIDE GRANTS ONLY TO COUNTY
BEHAVIOR HEALTH PARTNERS. AND
ONLY FOR PERSONNEL GRANT. THE
COMMISSION WOULD LIKE TO
TRANSITION THAT FUND PROGRAMS TO
PROVIDE MORE UPSTREAM STRATEGIES
FOCUSING ON PREVENTION AND EARLY
INTERVENTION IN ADDITION TO
CRISIS RESPONSE. AS SUCH WE HAVE
A BROADER ARRAY OF COMMUNITY
PARTNERS WHO ARE IN A POSITION
TO SUPPORT THOSE PREVENTION KIND
AND EARLY INTERVENTION
STRATEGIES. WE'RE LOOKING FOR A
SERIES OF MODIFICATIONS THAT
WOULD ALLOW GREATER FLEXIBILITY
NEEDS TO THE FUNDS TO ACTUALLY
MARC. TO EXPAND OPPORTUNITIES TO
PARTNER WITH PEOPLE INCLUDING
THE COUNTY BUT NOT LIMITED TO
THE COUNTIES. TO ALLOW THE GRANT
FUNDS TO BE USED FOR THINGS
OTHER THAN SIMPLY PERSONNEL. TO
COME. INTO RIGHT NOW WE CANNOT
USE THOSE FUND WE CANNOT REQUIRE
MATCHING FUNDS SOME PARTNERS
COULD PROVIDE MATCHING FUNDS.
AND LASTLY OUR SMALLEST
COMMUNITY PARTNERS REALLY
STRUGGLE TO PARTICIPATE IN
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAMS LIKE
A MODIFICATION IN NARROW
CIRCUMSTANCES BE ABLE TO RELEASE
THOSE FUNDS YOU NON COMPETITIVE
GRANTS. THE TICKET WHEN WORKING
WITH SMALLER COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ARE SMALL THE VERY
SMALLEST COUNTIES. THE ONE OF
OUR PROPOSALS IT'S TRAILER BILL
LANGUAGE TO MODIFY THAT. ONLINE
I'M GONNA REMOVE THIS BECAUSE
IT'S VERY CHALLENGING TO SPEAK
AND BREATHE. YEAH THOSE TWO
THINGS ARE PROBABLY ESSENTIAL AT
THE MOMENT. SECOND WE'RE ASKING
FOR AN AUGMENTATION OF FUNDING
TO SUPPORT THE ADVOCACY WORK
THAT THE COMMISSION AUTHORIZES A
WE PROVIDE GRANT FUNDS TO
ARRANGE A COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. BASICALLY TO
ELEVATE THE VOICE OF MENTAL
HEALTH PEERS FAMILY MEMBERS AND
CONSUMERS THE STRENGTH IN THE
KINDS OF SERVICES THAT ARE
AVAILABLE THROUGH OUR COUNTY AND
COMMUNITY PARTNERS. LOOKING FOR
TO DOUBLE THE FUNDING THAT IS
CURRENTLY AVAILABLE TO SUPPORT
THE WORK FOR IMMIGRANTS AND
REFUGEES AS YOU KNOW CALIFORNIA
IS FACING TREMENDOUS CHALLENGES
AS WE TAKEN AND- PEOPLE FROM
AROUND THE WORLD AND- BEING
TREMENDOUS. WRAP THINGS IT. E.
D. S. T. THICKLY FOR. DIVERSE
IMMIGRANT REFUGEE POPULATION
THEY WERE HOPING TO EXPAND
FUNDING FROM SIX HUNDRED SEVENTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR TO
DOUBLE THAT AN ADDITIONAL.
SEVENTY THOUSAND. ADDITIONALLY
ALTHOUGH WE DO PROVIDE FUNDING
THAT FOCUSES ON THE NEEDS OF
TRANSITION AGE YOUTH ADVOCACY
GROUP NEED YOUTH AND YOUNG
CHILDREN. IT'S BEEN SUCH A
TREMENDOUS INVESTMENT IN SCHOOL
MENTAL HEALTH THAT WHAT WE'RE
HEARING IS HOW IMPORTANT IT IS
FOR SCHOOL AGE YOUTH TO BE
ENGAGED IN ADVOCACY AROUND THE
WORK THAT'S HAPPENING. IN OUR
SCHOOLS AND OUR COMMUNITIES TO
MEET THEIR NEEDS AND SO THE
COMMISSION IS ASKING FOR FUNDING
TO SUPPORT. WAYS TO ELEVATE THE
VOICE OF SCHOOL AGE YOUTH THAT
THOSE INVESTMENTS ARE ACTUALLY
DESIGNED TO BE RESPONSIVE TO THE
NEEDS OF YOUNG PEOPLE. AT THE
SECOND ABOUT. A THIRD PROPOSAL
IS- WE RECENTLY LOST A
COMMISSIONER SHE SHE PASSED AWAY
RECENTLY AND SHE WAS A PEER. AND
SHE WAS VERY UNIQUE IN THAT SHE
HAD WORKED FOR COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH AND SHOULD WORK FOR THE
STATE GOVERNMENT. AND THAT
PERSPECTIVE GAVE HER A
TREMENDOUS. LEVEL OF EMPATHY AND
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT HAPPENS IN
OUR COMMUNITY MENTAL HEALTH
SYSTEM AND OUR STATEMENTS HEALTH
SYSTEM. AND IT REVEALED TO US
UNFORTUNATELY IT WAS HER PASSING
THAT REVEALED TO US. THAT WHILE
THE STATE HAS MADE TREMENDOUS
PROGRESS IN EMBRACING THE ROLE
OF PEERS. IN COUNTY BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH WE HAVE NOT YET DONE SO
IN STATE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. AND
SO THE ARGUMENT HERE IS THAT IF
WE REALLY WANT TO UNDERSTAND HOW
STATE POLICIES AND PROGRAMS. CAN
BE ALIGNED TO THE VERY REAL
LIVED EXPERIENCE OF PEOPLE WHO
HAVE STRUGGLED WITH THEIR MENTAL
HEALTH. ADDICTION AND SO FORTH
THAT WE SHOULD EMBRACE PEERS NOT
JUST IN OUR COMMUNITY BEHAVIOR
HEALTH SYSTEM. BUT IN STATE
GOVERNMENT AND SO WE'RE ASKING
FOR TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE AND
FINANCIAL SUPPORT TO WORK WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF CALAIS CHART
TO ACTUALLY BRING PEERS. IN THE
STATE GOVERNMENT IN LEADERSHIP
ROLES TO REALLY SHAPE THE
POLICIES AND PROGRAMS THAT WE
HAVE. IN CALIFORNIA WE THINK
THAT WILL BE INSTRUMENTAL IN
MAKING SURE THAT THE WORK WE DO
IS ACTUALLY ALIGNED WITH THE
REAL WORLD. EXPERIENCES THE
PEOPLE TRYING TO SERVE. FOR SOME
AND THIS IS VERY SIMILAR OUR
FOURTH PROPOSAL. IS AS MANY OF
YOU KNOW THE COMMISSION REALLY
FOCUSES ON DATA WE FOCUS ON
OUTCOMES WE FOCUSED ON
INCENTIVES. WE FOCUS ON REALLY
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND WHY THE
SYSTEMS THAT WE HAVE TODAY ARE
DELIVERING THE KIND OF OUTCOMES
THAT WE HAVE. AND HOW DO WE
CHANGE THE DESIGN OF PROGRAMS TO
BE MORE PERFORMANCE AND OUTCOME
ORIENTED. AND SO WERE WERE
ASKING FOR FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
IN ONE TIME FUNDS. THE PARTNER
WITH AN ACADEMIC PARTNER TO
ACTUALLY LAUNCH A BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH PERFORMANCE FELLOWSHIP.
AS WE'VE TALKED WITH OUR
COMMUNITY PARTNERS PARTICULAR A
COUNTIES. MANY OF THEM RECOGNIZE
THAT THEIR STAFF THEIR
LEADERSHIP THEIR MANAGER'S
ACTUALLY COULD BENEFIT FROM.
FOCUSED EDUCATION AND TRAINING
AROUND HOW WE CAN DO A BETTER
JOB DRIVING OUT COMES INTO THE
WAY WE DESIGN AND DELIVER
SERVICES AND SO WE'RE LOOKING TO
BUILD. A FELLOWSHIP THAT WOULD
BE THAT WOULD TARGET STATE
EMPLOYEES AND COUNTY. LEADERS
THE BEHAVIOR HEALTH SPACE TRULY
DRIVE PERFORMANCE AND OUTCOMES
INTO THAT WORK. ONE TIME FUNDING
WITH THE INTENT OF LAUNCHING A
PROGRAM THAT WOULD BE FUNDED
THROUGH REVENUES. ASSOCIATED
WITH PEOPLE SIGNING UP
PARTICIPATING IN THE FELLOWSHIP
BUT THERE ARE SOME START UP
COSTS. AND SO THE FUNDING WOULD
BE SPREAD OVER FIVE YEARS WITH
AN INTENT. BY THE END OF THE
FIVE YEARS IT WOULD BE SELF
SUSTAINING. AND LET'S SEE MY
FAITH IS. INCREASINGLY THE
COMMISSION IS CALLED UPON. TO
WORK WITH POLICY MAKERS AND
LEGISLATIVE STAFF AND OTHERS
AROUND LEGISLATION AND SO. WOULD
LIKE TO ADD A POSITION TO THE
COMMISSION TO IMPROVE OUR
ABILITY TO BE RESPONSIVE TO YOUR
NEEDS. WITH ADMINISTRATION
AROUND POLICY. AND THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT YOU SEE A LOT OF
ME THESE DAYS AND- YOU MIGHT NOT
WANT TO SEE SO MUCH OF MAY AND
SO WE'RE HOPING THAT MAYBE
SOMEONE ELSE COULD JOIN OUR TEAM
WHO COULD HELP US. DELIVER IT
OVER TO BE RESPONSIVE TO THE
POLICY OPPORTUNITIES AND
QUESTIONS THAT WE RECEIVE EVERY
DAY. THANKS VERY MUCH OF THAT
VERY BRIEF HAVING TO TAKE. THANK
YOU DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE.
MADISON SEVERAL DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE. WE JUST WANTED TO NOTE
THAT TO THE EXTENT THE
LEGISLATURE SEEK TO PRIORITIZE
ANY OF THESE PROPOSALS. THAT WE
WOULD BE INTERESTED TO
UNDERSTAND THE HOW TO LINES THE
PROPOSAL ALIGNED WITH.
ADMINISTRATION LEGISLATURE
PROPOSALS SUCH AS IN THE AREA OF
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE THANK YOU.
HELLO THE COMMENTS. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN VERSE CHORUS YOU
TO WITH THE L. A. WE'RE STILL
REVIEWING THE OASES PROPOSALS
AND WILL FOLLOW UP IF WE HAVE
ANYTHING FLAG. THANK YOU.
FINALLY COULD WE HAVE THE
COVERED CALIFORNIA AND
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE SPEAKERS
FOR THE COVERED CALIFORNIA. MAY
REVISED PROPOSALS PUT FORWARD.
THE SHOPPING ANI WITH THE HEALTH
AND HUMAN SERVICE AGENCY TO
PREVENT ON THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL. WE ADDRESS THE
UNCERTAINTY OF FEDERAL AMERICAN%
RESCUE PLAN ACTS ON CONTINUING.
TWO THOUSAND TWENTY TWO- THE
FEDERAL ACTION IS NOT TAKEN TO
EXTEND HARPER PREMIUM SUBSIDIES
FOR TWO THOUSAND TWENTY THREE
AND BEYOND. THE MAY REVISION
INCLUDES THREE HUNDRED AND FOUR
MILLION. FROM THE HEALTH CARE
AFFORDABILITY RESERVE FUND FOR
BUDGET YEAR AND THREE HUNDRED
AND FOUR MILLION GENERAL FUND.
IN TWENTY THREE TWENTY FOUR. AND
ANNUALLY THEREAFTER. REINSTATE
REINSTITUTE THE CALIFORNIA
PREMIUM SUBSIDY PROGRAM. THIS
STATE FUNDED PROGRAM INCLUDED
PREMIUM SUBSIDIES FOR MIDDLE
INCOME CALIFORNIANS WE DID NOT
QUALIFY FOR SUBSIDIES. UNDER THE
ACA. PRIOR TO THE ENACTMENT OF
OUR BUT- THE STATE SUBSIDY
PROGRAM DESIGNED FOR CALENDAR
TWENTY. CALENDAR YEAR TWENTY TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY THREE WOULD BE
SIMILAR TO THE TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY ONE PROGRAM DESIGNED.
WOULD PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
SUBSIDIES TO THE POOR 510026100%
FPL GROUP. BRING IN THEIR
REQUIRED CONTRIBUTION DOWN FROM
EIGHTEEN PERCENT. IN 200021216%
IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY THREE.
THIS CONCLUDES MY OVERVIEW AND
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS AT
THE APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. YES
JOSEPH DAWSON FROM THE PARTNER
FINANCE NO ADDITIONAL. WITH THE
L. A. O. WE WILL CONTINUE O GET
THE DETAILS OF THE PROPOSAL I'M
NOW WE DO WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THERE IS A STRONG POLICY
BASIS FOR DOING- INCREASED.
PREMIUM SUBSIDIES IN THE EVENT
THAT THE CURRENT ENHANCE FEDERAL
PREMIUM SUBSIDIES EXPIRE IN
DECEMBER- BOTH IN TERMS OF
IMPROVING AFFORDABILITY AS WELL
AS PREVENTING PEOPLE FROM-
LEAVING COVERAGE DUE TO THE
COSTS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU TO
ALL OF OUR SPEAKERS AND
PANELISTS HERE TODAY- I WILL
BEGIN AND SEE IF ANY SUB
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS
KEEP IT HERE AT. CHAIR FOR A FEW
BEFORE WE GO TO PUBLIC. COMMENT
WHICH SHOULD BE THE REMAINDER OF
THE HEARING HERE TODAY DO YOU
WANT A CHANCE TO ASK BOTH CD PH
AND DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS A QUESTION AND SO
WOULD APPRECIATE IF. YOU COULD
MAKE YOUR WAY FORWARD.
WE'LL BEGIN WITH CDPH SINCE
YOU'RE JOINING US VIRTUALLY IF I
CAN- YOU HAD MENTIONED
REAPPROPRIATION OF MONEY FOR TGI
WELLNESS AS WELL AS ALL CHILDREN
THRIVE. AND I ALSO BELIEVE THAT
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE WE HAD S.
T. D. FUNDING THAT HASN'T GONE
OUT. I'D LIKE TO UNDERSTAND WHY
IF I CAN AND- I'M AYE I WILL IF.
I MAY BRING UP WHAT PUBLIC WHAT
WE HEARD EARLIER THAT ARE TRANS.
USE 40% HAVE ATTEMPTED SUICIDE
SO I'D LIKE TO UNDERSTAND WHY
pTHIS MONEY HAS NOT BEEN. GOING
OUT. AS WAS APPROPRIATED LAST
YEAR. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR-
RELATED TO YOUR FIRST QUESTION
ON THE APPROPRIATION ITEM- THAT
TO DIFFERENT AREAS OF COURSE BUT
OUR OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY-
FOLKS ARE ON MINE- JASON TESTER
OR WROTE ON REDDIT CHRISTIAN I
THINK CAN PROVIDE A LITTLE MORE
DETAIL ABOUT- THAT REQUESTS-
CHASE IN A ROW ON. GO AHEAD
JASON. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
HIGHER- AND- I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION- CDPH RECOGNIZES WITHIN
THE STORK OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
LONGSTANDING AND ENTRENCHED
HEALTH INEQUITIES EXPERIENCED BY
SOME OF THE MOST MARGINALIZED
CALIFORNIANS- HOWEVER THE
COMPLEXITY OF THIS GRANT PROGRAM
COUPLED WITH THE PREVIOUSLY VERY
LIMITED EXPENDITURE AUTHORITY
WINDOW OF NINE MONTHS. MADE
STAFFING DESIGN AND PROGRAM
EVALUATION EFFORTS- JUST REALLY
IMPOSSIBLE OVER THAT SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME WE ARE- YOU KNOW.
THAT SAID THAT WE ARE- ENGAGED-
WE HAVE BEEN DISCUSSING- OPTIONS
WITH COMMUNITIES AND- WE HAVE TO
HELP COVER MEETINGS STAKEHOLDERS
CONDUCTED AN INFORMAL NEEDS
ASSESSMENT. OF TGI SERVING
ORGANIZATIONS AND THEIR
ORGANIZATIONAL CAPACITY AND- AND
WE REALLY WANT TO DO THIS RIGHT-
WE ARE LOOKING TO OUR THE
CALIFORNIA- REDUCING DISPARITIES
PROJECT AS A MODEL FOR NOT ONLY
ENGAGEMENT BUT ALSO IN. THE WAY
IN WHICH WE CAN ENGAGE IS SMALL
AND MICRO. ORGANIZATIONS SURE
THAT THEY HAVE EQUAL ACCESS TO
THE FUNDING AND THAT IS THAT IS
REALLY OUR OUR FOCUS THEY'RE
DOING THIS RIGHT BECAUSE WE
UNDERSTAND THE URGENT NATURE OF-
OF THIS. I HEAR THAT RESPONSE
AND I APPRECIATE WANTING TO DO
IT RIGHT I THINK FOR MANY OF US
IF THE DOLLARS ARE NOT BEING.
UTILIZED WHAT WE AREN'T DOING IT
RIGHT AND UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE
TOO MANY. GIRLS WHO ARE
EXPERIENCING CRISIS TODAY. SO
WOULD AGAIN JUST REALLY URGED
MINISTRATION TO WORKS TO. EXPAND
RESOURCES THAT WE HAD
APPROPRIATE. WITH THAT I WILL.
FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF STATE
HOSPITALS IF I CAN I'M A
DIRECTOR CLINTON AND WANTED TO
GET A SENSE FROM YOU ON THE I.
S. T. WAITING LIST OR ARE WE
GETTING CLOSER TO GETTING THIS
UNDER CONTROL I HEAR A LOT LOT
ABOUT WHAT THE WORK GROUP DID
AND OUR PLANS. BUT I'M- CAN YOU
GIVE US SOME ASSURANCES ON THAT
AND SECOND IF I CAN WE HEARD
EARLIER ABOUT- HOW. THERE ARE
RETENTION BONUSES FOR HOSPITAL
EMPLOYEES AND- OUR PSYCHIATRIC
HOSPITALS AND YET FOR MANY OF
OUR STATE HOSPITAL EMPLOYEES.
WILL NOT BE GETTING THIS
RETENTION BONUS I'M WANTED TO
HEAR FROM YOU WHEN WE HAVE SUCH
VACANCIES WHY WE WOULDN'T
CONSIDER. THIS FOR SAN. OTHER
OPPORTUNE FOR US TO REALLY BUILD
AND RETAIN. YEAH I DO WITH
RESPECT TO THE I. S. T.
SOLUTIONS- AND I S. T.
WEIGHTLESS AND KIND OF WORKED IS
TODAY AND AS YOU NOTED WE DID
CONVENE THE I. S. T. SOLUTIONS
WORK GROUP LAST YEAR I REALLY
LARGELY TO HAVE A CONVERSATION
WITH ALL OF OUR STAKEHOLDERS
ABOUT WHAT MORE CAN BE DONE TO
REALLY ADDRESS THAT. INCREASING
NUMBER OF REFERRALS TO INCREASE
CAPACITY AND REALLY TO CHANGE
THE ARC OF THE LIVES OF THOSE
THAT WE- AND THEM. AS WELL. HIS
LARGE THESE INDIVIDUAL ARE
INDIVIDUALS WITH SERIOUS MENTAL
ILLNESS WERE JUST CYCLING AND-
IN AND OUT OF THE JUSTICE SYSTEM
SO WE REALLY DON'T WANT TO JUST
TREAT THEM AS AN I. S. T. AND
SEND THEM BACK TO PAY SURCHARGES
WE WANT TO DO SOMETHING THAT'S
MEANINGFUL AND DIFFERENT. AND SO
THAT'S REALLY WHAT THE I. S. T.
SOLUTIONS PROPOSAL IS DOING IS
DOING ITS REALLY PROPOSING TO
ADDRESS THIS TIME QALINGE OFTEN
TO BECAUSE ONE IS TO TRY TO
REALLY ADDRESS THE I. S. T.
WAITING TIMES AND TO- AND TO
REDUCE THE WEIGHTLESS WHILE ALSO
PROVIDING. BETTER ACCESS TO ME
BAYSTREET AND DIVERSION IN THE
AND ABOUT SO THAT. WE CAN
PROVIDE THAT MOVE. IN AND OUT OF
THEIR JUSTICE. I WITH RESPECT TO
KIND OF WHERE WE ARE TODAY WE
ARE- WE DO CURRENTLY HAVE A WAIT
LIST OF EIGHTEEN HUNDRED NINETY
TWO INDIVIDUAL SO IT STILL IS
VERY HIGH. IT'S BEEN
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPACTED BY
COVERT- L. R. AND B. AS THE WE
AS THE COMMUNITY EXPERIENCES
SURGES SO DO WE WITHIN OUR
HOSPITALS. AND THAT RELATE TO IN
ORDER TO PREVENT THE
TRANSMISSION. FROM THE- TO
PREVENT THE TRANSMISSION BETWEEN
US AND THE JAILS WE'D HAVE HAD
TO FREEZE ADMISSIONS. AND I DOES
BECAUSE- A BACKUP WE DO THAT FOR
A VERY SHORT PERIOD OF TIME AS
YOU KNOW ONLY WHEN IT'S
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT. BUT IT HAS.
FURTHER IN DINNER ABILITY. AS
WELL AS WE ARE MUCH SLOWER IN
GETTING INDIVIDUALS INTO THE
HOSPITAL. AS OF THE NATURE OF
OUR- ENVIRONMENT WE HAVE TO
BRING INDIVIDUALS AND FOR NOW
WHAT'S CALLED THE MISSION
OBSERVATION UNITS TO BE ABLE TO
QUARANTINE THEM. AND TO OBSERVE
THEM AND TEST THEM AND SURE THAT
THEY DON'T HAVE PROBABLY BEFORE
WE MOVE OUT TO OUR VERY LARGE
CONGREGATE ENVIRONMENT SO. IT'S
REALLY BEEN A BIG CHALLENGE WITH
OVER THAT'S REALLY- IMPACTED OUR
ABILITY TO REALLY TACKLE THE
WAIT LIST. BUT THEN THE OTHER
FACTORS THAT THE ICE TO
REFERRALS CONTINUE. TO GROW.
HE'S A BEING REFERRED TO US AND
SO THE IS ALSO AND MAY IT HAPPEN
FOR US TO REALLY. BUILD OUR WAY
OUT OF IT IS THAT THE NUMBERS
CONTINUE TO GROW SO. REALLY
THIS- I. S. T. SOLUTIONS
PROPOSAL PROVIDES US YOU KNOW.
THE SUBSTANTIAL- MOUNTBATTEN'S
TO REALLY PROVIDE THAT COMMUNITY
BASED TREATMENT FOR INDIVIDUALS.
WHILE ALSO PROVIDING THE ABILITY
TO DELIVER EARLY ACCESS TO
SERVICES SO PEOPLE ARE GETTING
TREATMENT WHILE THEY'RE WAITING
FOR THAT. I WAS HOPING YOU COULD
ADDRESS THE SECOND PART OF THE
QUESTION REALLY FOCUSED ON. THE
EMPLOYEES WHICH WERE SELECTED TO
RECEIVE THE RETENTION BONUS AND-
ARE RIGHT NOW FOR NOT INCLUDING
ARE YOU ASKING ABOUT THE- WORKER
BONUSES THAT'S BEING PROVIDED
FOR HEALTH HEALTH CARE HOSPITAL
IN SKILLED NURSING THAT'S
CORRECT. SO AS WE UNDERSTAND
THAT IT DOES INCLUDE OUR
HOSPITALS- BUT IT IS GETTING
SOMETHING THAT WILL NEED TO GO
THROUGH THE BARGAINING PROCESS
AND SO COUNTY CHARGES IS I WILL
BE WORKING WITH OUR LABOR
PARTNERS. WONDERFUL FINAL
QUESTION IF I CAN YOU SPOKE
EARLIER ABOUT I S. T. DISCHARGE
PLANNING AND COORDINATION. AND
WAS HOPING TO UNDERSTAND A
LITTLE MORE AS WE ARE WORKING ON
THOSE TRANSITIONS. ARE ARE WE
COORDINATING CURRENTLY WITH C.
B. H. HIER ARE WE PLANNING WITH
THEM SO THAT THOSE WHO ARE BEING
RELEASED ARE. ROLLED ENGAGED IN
FULL SERVICE PARTNERSHIPS HOW DO
WE HAVE THOSE WARM HANDOFFS AND
UNSURE WERE- CREATING THE BEST
OPPORTUNITY FIRST. YEAH WITH
RESPECT TO THE I. S. T.
TRANSITIONS IT REALLY IS
SOMETHING THAT IS AN AREA OF
OPPORTUNITY TO REALLY IMPROVE
AND THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE'VE
CERTAINLY. IT WAS JUST GOT QUITE
A BIT AND R. I. S. T. SOLUTIONS
WORK GROUP AS WELL- THE WAY THAT
SO AS AN INDIVIDUAL COMES IN AS
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL OUR
ENGAGEMENT HAS PRIMARILY BEEN
WITH THE JAILS BECAUSE THEY COME
TO US FROM THE JAILS AND WE
RETURN THEM TO THE DOUBTS ALL OF
OUR DISCHARGE PLANNING HAS BEEN
WITH THEM. AND IN IN THOSE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE V. EIGHT
VA AS WELL AS THE I. STEEPLY
SINCE REALLY THINKING ABOUT THAT
AND ABOUT LONGER TERM RUN WHAT
HAPPENS TO THEM AFTER THEY
RETURNED TO JAIL. AND THEN
PROVIDING THAT INFORMATION TO
THE COUNTIES. I'M NOT ONLY TO
THE DEALS BUT TO OUR COUNTY
PARTNERS AS WELL SO THAT THEY
CAN START TO PREPARE AND FOR
THAT TRANSITION. BECAUSE A LOT
OF TIMES WHEN AN INDIVIDUAL GOES
BACK TO THE IT- THEY COUNTY JAIL
THEY CAN EITHER HAVE THEIR
CHARGES DROPPED THEY CAN GET
TIME SERVED THING HAPPENED.
QUICKLY WE RETURNED THEM AND-
THIS WILL BEST THE COUNTY TO BE
ABLE TO PREPARE FOR THAT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ALL OF OUR SPEAKER
SPEAKERS IF THERE ARE NO
ADDITIONAL MEMBER COMMENTS OR
QUESTIONS WE WILL NOW BEGIN
PUBLIC. WE DO HAVE A SUBSTANTIAL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO WOULD LIKE
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
THEREFORE I WANT TO URGE YOU TO
KEEP YOUR COMMENTS BRIEF SO THAT
WE CAN HEAR FROM EVERYONE. WE
WILL START WITH IN PERSON
COMMENT IN THE HEARING ROOM
PLEASE COME FORWARD TO THE
MICROPHONE IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
MAKE A CALL.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR-
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- DOUG CHIPATA
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FOR
THE UNION OF AMERICAN PHYSICIANS
DENTISTS WOULD ACTUALLY. I'M
ALSO THE CHAIR OF THE EXECUTIVE
BOARD FOR A CALIFORNIA ASKS ME.
I WANT TO SPEAK SPECIFICALLY TO
MAY REVISE AND SPECIFICALLY TO
DEPARTMENTS AT HOSPITALS- YOU
ALLUDED TO IT IN YOUR IN YOUR
QUESTIONS OF THE DIRECTOR. NINE
HUNDRED THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
IS PROPOSED BY THE GOVERNOR'S
MAY MAY REVISE. FOR HOSPITAL
RETENTION AND THEY THEY CITED
THAT'S GOING TO BE NEGOTIATED
THROUGH COLLECTIVE BARGAINING.
MISTER CHAIR A SOMEONE WHO
CHAIRED LAST TWO SESSIONS WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION A KELLY CHAR
. THEY ARE WELL AWARE THE
VACANCY PROBLEM ARE
PSYCHIATRISTS AND WE ESSENTIALLY
GOT NOWHERE WE'RE NOW TALKING
ABOUT ESSENTIAL WORK FORCE WITH
THEM WE HAVE TO GO WE HAVE TO
TRY AND MAKE A VERY COMPELLING
ARGUMENT THAT RE EVEN ESSENTIAL
WORKERS. SO IT'S DISAPPOINTING
THAT WE HAVE TO GO THAT VENUE.
WE WOULD LIKE TO PROPOSE AN
ALTERNATIVE ROUTE. WE HAVE
CORRESPONDENTS GOING ON ON THE
SENATE SIDE SO HERTZBERG IS
TAKING THE LEAD SENATOR DODD
MANY OF THESE JUST SENATOR
LAYERED- SO. VISIT STATE HOUSE
WAS A MESS A STAND WITH THE
PSYCHIATRIST HERE TODAY. SO I
WILL JUST TO TURN IT OVER TO
THEM AND HAVE THEM BRIEFLY. TELL
YOU WHAT'S GOING ON WITH RESPECT
TO VACANCIES AT STATE HOSPITALS
WHICH EXCEED 50% MISTER CHAIR.
WE HAVE DOCTOR BUSTER BOARD
PRESIDENT WHO CAN INTRODUCE OUR
DOCTORS THANK YOU SIR. THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN ARAMBULA AND I WANT TO
JUST SPEAK FIRST TO THE- THOU
REQUIREMENTS I HEARD EARLIER
WHICH REALLY DOVETAIL VERY
NICELY WITH. WITH WHAT- THANK
YOU PETA JUST SAID. THAT YOU
NEED A HIGH BAR AND EMERGENCY.
53% HI BAR IN MY BOOK NEED FOR A
KNOWN PROBLEM. IT'S KNOWN AS
STATISTICALLY PROVABLE YOUR 53%
THE SOLUTIONS TO FIX OUR GOAL.
ARE HAVE BEEN ESPOUSED BY JUDGE
MILLER. IN LETTERS AND- PRIOR TO
A EIGHT PAGE REPORT THAT WE DID
WITH CALLIE CHAR OVER EIGHT
MONTHS WHICH WAS IGNORED
ESSENTIALLY. SO THAT GOAL IS
OBVIOUSLY AS PER JUDGE MILLER
AND OR JOINT PAPER TO INCREASE
THE SALARY OF THE PEOPLE SO THEY
CAN BE COMPETITIVE. AND COME FOR
STATE SERVICE AND WE DON'T HAVE
TO HIRE THE FIT IN THE FISCAL
BENEFITS AS WAS MENTIONED IN THE
CELL CRITERIA ARE OBVIOUS.
BETWEEN CDC IDEA SIX HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS OF ANNUAL WASTE.
SO WITH THAT BEING SAID THE
SOLUTIONS ARE OBVIOUS YOU. BUT
WE NEED WE NEED A HIGHER
SALARIES AND SPECIALLY IN LIEU
OF PEPPER AND THE OTHER
IMPEDIMENTS TO RECRUITMENT WE
HAVE RIGHT HERE SEVERAL DOCTORS
FROM THE GESTATION CDCR. I LIKE
INTRODUCED INTO YOUR DOCTOR
KHANNA FROM NAP. THE STATE HAS
DOT ABBAS. FROM A PATENT DAY
HOSPITAL. AND THAT'S IT THEY'RE
GOING TO SPEAK TO THIS. THANK
YOU DR BUZZING. I DR MILA I'M I
JUST LIKE TO SAY I AM A
REGULATORS- STAFF PSYCHIATRIST
ON T. ON IN NAPA STATE HOSPITAL
MY NAME IS NEIL KHANNA. I'M AND
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF MINDS WE
HAD A CONTRACTOR ON THE UNIT
ABOVE MINE THAT LEFT AND THEY
HAVE NOT BEEN ABLE TO REPLACE
HIM. I SAW ALL THE ALL THE
PATIENTS WERE BEING COVERED BY
ONE ONE PSYCHIATRIST ON THAT
UNIT NORMALLY WE HAVE TWO
PSYCHIATRISTS ON EACH UNIT- SO
WE'VE- NUMBER OF US HAVE TO.
PICK UP THE EXTRA LOAD. I'M.
THIS IS KIND OF BECOMING THE
NORM I'M- FRANKLY I'M WE ARE
STILL WAITING ARM FOR SOME SORT
OF- RELIEF AND WE HAVE NOT HAD
ANY ARM THERE IS NO- RETENTION
SORT OF. BENEFIT RIGHT NOW
FRANKLY I'M LOOKING TO SEE
WHETHER IT'S WORTH FOR ME TO
STICK AROUND- THIS IS- THE
CENTURY THE WORKLOAD IS GOING
UP. THERE IS NO ACCESS CAPACITY-
YOU I NOTICE AND I JUST YOUR
MISSION ABOUT I. S. TEASE HER
EARLIER. I THERE IS NO CAPACITY
BECAUSE OTHER PEOPLE DON'T WANT
TO COME AND WORK AT THE STATE
HOSPITAL BECAUSE CURRENTLY. THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY AND FRANKLY THE
RETIREMENT THAT'S BEEN
COMPLETELY GUIDED OUR- MAJOR
MAJOR IMPEDIMENTS I THE SOLUTION
IS RELATIVELY SIMPLE- THE
PSYCHIATRIST ESSENTIALLY ARM
WANT TO HAVE A FAIR THEIR PAY
AND BETTER. AT RETIREMENT
BENEFITS AND RIGHT NOW THOSE
THINGS ARE HAPPENING AND IT'S
HARDER TO GET PEOPLE BECAUSE OF
THAT AND SO AS A BANDAID I THINK
WITH THE STATE HOSPITAL SYSTEM
IS DONE IS HIRE CONTRACTORS WHO
ARE PAID ABOUT TWICE AS MUCH BY
THE WAY- AND SO THAT'S BECOMING
ANOTHER ISSUE BECAUSE NOW PEOPLE
ARE SAYING YOU KNOW WHAT. WHY AM
I YOU EVEN EMPLOYEE. I JUST MOVE
ON AND BECOME A CONTRACTOR
MYSELF WHICH SOME PEOPLE HAVE
DONE- SO THESE ARE THE BIG BIG
ISSUES AND I THINK THE SOLUTIONS
ARE RELATIVELY STRAIGHTFORWARD-
I JUST HOPE THAT- THE STATE
HOSPITAL SYSTEM- BARGAINS WITH
THEIR UNION IN GOOD FAITH. AND
ACTUALLY. GET SOME OF THE STUFF
DONE THANK YOU. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON DR ARAMBULA JEREMIAH
MILLER AND- I AM DR CHUNG FROM
PATTON STATE HOSPITAL AND THE
PENN STATE HOSPITAL IS THE
LARGEST FORENSIC HOSPITAL IN THE
COUNTRY WE HAVE APPROXIMATELY
FIFTEEN HUNDRED BEDS- WHEN I
STARTED ALMOST FOURTEEN OVER
FOURTEEN YEARS AGO. WE WERE FULL
LARGELY PART OF THE COLEMAN
ORDERED WE WERE THE STATE RAISE
THE SALARY OF A PSYCHIATRIST TO
A LEVEL WHICH IN WHICH WAS
COMPETITIVE SO A LOT OF- YOUNG
PSYCHIATRIST LIKE ME AT THE TIME
UGH YOU KNOW YOUNG CAREER
PSYCHIATRISTS WERE. BEING DRAWN
FROM KAISER AND OUTSIDE
COMPETITORS TO COME TO THE STATE
THAT WAS THE JOB BECAUSE IT PAID
US WELL FOR WORK AND SO THE
STATE DIDN'T. BACK AND- THERE
WAS AT ONE POINT WHERE WE WERE
ALMOST ONE HUNDRED PSYCHIATRISTS
FULL AND NOW WE'RE DOWN TO
TWENTY NINE. TWENTY NINE WE THE
STATE PSYCHIATRISTS ARE THE
LARGEST JOB VACANCY OF ALL STATE
JOB POSITIONS WE ARE THE
ELEPHANT IN THE ROOM. AND
SIMILAR TO WHAT DOG AND DOG AND
DOCTOR BUT HE SAID YOU KNOW EVEN
THOUGH IT WAS. IN THE WHITE
PAPER CO AUTHORED BY K. WAS OUR
UNION EVEN. COMMENDED THE OFFICE
OF THE SPECIAL MASTER TO
INCREASE SALARIES TO MAKE US
COMPETITIVE- THAT WAS NOT DONE.
IN PRISON OFFICIALS SAID YOU
KNOW THAT'S GOING TO BE TAKEN
CARE OF IN BARGAINING AND YET IN
BARGAINING THAT WAS COMPLETELY
NON NEGOTIABLE PSYCHIATRIST
SALARIES THAT WAS OFF THE TABLE
WE COULD EVEN TALK ABOUT THAT.
SO HERE WE ARE AND WHY DO
VACANCIES MATTER IT'S BECAUSE
IMAGINE IF YOU WERE IN THE
HOSPITAL. YOU WOULD NOT WANT
YOUR UNIT YOUR ICU TO BE 45%
STAFFED NOT BECAUSE YOUR DOCTORS
INCOMPETENT BUT BECAUSE THEY
SIMPLY DON'T HAVE ENOUGH TIME.
TO TAKE CARE OF ALL THE
CRITICALLY ILL PATIENTS AND
THAT'S WHO WE TAKE CARE OF WE
HAVE THE MOST SEVERELY
CRITICALLY ILL PATIENTS IN THE
STATE MEAN THE STATE IS THE
LARGEST WE HAVE THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND. RIDLEY MENTALLY ILL
PATIENTS GOING UP YOU KNOW
SUICIDE RATES ARE GOING UP DRUG
OVERDOSES ARE AT ALL TIME HIGH
BY THE CDC OVER A HUNDRED
THOUSAND OVERDOSES ALL OF THESE.
THINGS IMPACT OUR PATIENT
POPULATION THEY ARE SO SICK SO
WHILE THE NUMBERS GO UP THE
NUMBER OF PSYCHIATISTS ARE
DROPPING. AND THAT'S NOT BEING
ADDRESSED AND SO I IMPLORE YOU
TO PLEASE ACT AND- AND HELP US
GET. TO A LEVEL THAT WE CAN
COMPETE IS BECAUSE THE REASON I
WERE VACANT IS OBVIOUS ON
BECAUSE OF OUR SALARIES ARE NOT
COMPETITIVE. IT WOULD ANYONE
WHO'S IN COMING OUT OF RESIDENCY
OR EVEN LOOKING FOR A JOB CHOOSE
. WORKING AT A STATE HOSPITAL
WERE MY PATIENTS WHO ARE THERE
FOR MURDER AND RAPE ARE THIS
CLOSE TO ME WE DON'T HAVE ANY
SECURITY ON THE UNITS WE HAVE A
WHISTLE AND AN ALARM SYSTEM THAT
WE HOPE WILL WORK THERE'S NO
HOSPITAL. ON THE UNIT. THE SEALS
WERE OUTSIDE OF THE FENCE I HAVE
SO MANY COLLEAGUES WHO HAVE BEEN
ASSAULTED. PERMANENTLY MAIMED.
ALL OF THAT IT'S A DANGEROUS JOB
AND NOW WE'RE EXPOSED TO COVE IT
SO FOR ALL OF THESE REASONS THE-
THE MONEY AND THEN ALSO. NOT TO
FORGET THE FACT THAT. THERE IS.
NO WELL THEIR OWN THEY'RE
GETTING PAID WHAT THEY'RE WORTH
WE ARE NOT. THERE AND WHAT THESE
CONTRACT POSITION THAT ARE PAID
MORE THAN TWICE AS MUCH SO FOR
EACH IN THE REPORT THAT. YOU
SHOULD HAVE THAT WAS WRITTEN BY
CALIFORNIA PD. FOR EACH
CONTRACTOR. THEY'RE MAKING
THEY'RE COSTING THE STATE ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS MORE PER YEAR PER
CONTRACTOR. I MEAN I WANT TO
KNOW IS IT. WHY ARE. SO MUCH
MONEY. IN A WE CAN TAKE IF. OF
WHAT WE'RE TAKING. TO THE CALL.
AND GET AS A SALARY THAT BRINGS
US UP TO. THE LEVEL OF
COMPETITION AND THAT'S WHY IT
MATTERS IS BECAUSE WE ARE TAKING
CARE OF SERIOUSLY MENTALLY ILL
PATIENTS WHO ARE SUFFERING
BECAUSE OF OUR VACANCY RATES.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU DOCTOR.
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR DR ADAM
I'M DOCTOR OF AUSSIE I ONE OF
THE CIVIL SERVICE AND STUFF LIKE
ARE JUST. I ONE OF THE CIVIL
SERVICE SERVICE STRIVE
PSYCHIATRIST TO- AT THE
CALIFORNIA HEALTH CARE FACILITY
CSE FAM LIKE I DID PRISON
PROGRAM IN STOCKTON. AND WHAT OF
THE I WILL OFF THE M. MENTAL
HEALTH CARE YOU CAN GET ANYWHERE
IN THE CORRECTIONAL SYSTEM SO
I'M HERE TODAY ON BEHALF OF MY
FELLOW PSYCHIATRIST CYCLE-
ENFORCER. ED YOUNG AND DOCTOR
AND I CANNELLA SAID BEFORE ME
AND DOUG AND OCTOPUSSY MENTIONED
THAT TO THE OF THE CDS MENTAL
HEALTH CRISIS GOING ON IN THE C.
C. R. INSTEAD SYSTEM. AND IT IS
NOT A PROBLEM THE ONGOING
CHRONIC SERIOUS PROBLEM BUT HE'S
NOT BEEN ADDRESS JOURNAL. AND
PART. OF THE STATE RIGHT TO
ADDRESS INFILL THE VACANCY WITH
THE CONTRACTOR TO. REGISTER
GUIDE. THANK THEM SO I GOT
THROUGH. ONCE I GOT JUST WHICH
IS ALSO ATTEMPTING FOR THE LARA
THE CIVIL I GOT TO QUIT THEIR
JOB AND GO JOIN THEIR BECAUSE HE
DON'T HAVE A VERY GOOD I'D REPLY
OFTEN DIED MY DATE FARMS AUDIT
I'M BENEFITS A GUARD ON
SIGNIFICAN. SO THEY ARE TRUCKS
THERE ANYMORE AND SEE A DOCTOR
M. JOHN GETTING SAID AS COMPARED
TO US IT A ACTUALLY LARA FOR A
FEW REPORT THE BOY.
ALLIES DIDN'T GET THEM ALL TO
THE LOWER LEVEL OF CARE THEY CAN
GET THAT. FAR DOWN THERE FOR
THREE MONTHS SIX MONTHS IT IS
KIND OF A REVOLVING DOOR YOU
KNOW THEY'RE NOT INVESTED. AND
THEY CAN JUST TO KEEP THE
PATIENTS NEAR REPORT OF A
MINIMUM JUST KEEPING THEM STABLE
NOT REALLY TREATING THEM AND GET
OUT AND TRANSITIONAL. COMMUNITY
THINK OF ALL THIS YOU KNOW AND
IS UNFAIR SYSTEM. AT OUR
INVERTER COMPENSATE TO GETTING
OUR SALARIES ARE NOT COMPETITIVE
WITH THE COMMUNITY. OTHER THE
LAW COME TO THE COMMUNITY. AND
THEY ALSO. THERE IS NO
CONSIDERATION NO COMPENSATION.
AND FOR THE FOOTBOARD WORKING
CONDITIONS DANGEROUS WORKING
CONDITIONS I WORK IN THE CITY'S
YARD LEVEL FOR FACILITY EVEN WE
HAVE LEVEL FOUR HOW MEXICANS.
PEOPLE YOU. AND THERE'S TWO
MENTALLY ILL WE HAVE A UNIT IT
DID. OF THE- BAR. I WAS A DOCTOR
SEE THEM. IT'S LIKE I HAVE A
BECAUSE OFFICER STANDING IN ME
EXACTLY IS THE WAY DR. SAID HAVE
A LOT. WHICH WE HOPE WILL VOTE.
AND RECENTLY WE HAVE A SONG ON
THE DOCK A LOT OF DID NOT WORK.
SORIANA PUTTING UP LIFE IN HIS
PUTTING A HEALTH AT RISK THERE
IS THAT THIS. THERE'S A
COMBINED. SO THE END OF YOUR
ALSO TIM TO LEAVE GENERALLY VERY
FEW PEOPLE. YOU'RE ONLY LIKE HER
FORTY PEOPLE LEFT WE HAD A LOT
GROSS ARE JUST A- TO IT AND WE
ARE ONLY. FOURTEEN AND AGAIN
SEES ARE LIKE NINETEEN AVAILABLE
SHOULD BE FILLED OF THE
CONTRACTORS. TRYING TO GET THE
SAME JOB. AND WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
IS IT IS IT IS NOT A RESULT FIX
BASICALLY THERE'S A SIMPLE AND
EASY FIX YOU NOTICED A FIXABLE
PROBLEM. JUST IT YOU KNOW
RAISING OUR SALARIES AND
COMPENSATIONS. THE COMPETITIVE
LEVEL TO THE COMMUNITY MAYBE
TWENTY FIVE OR SERVICE FOR ALL
DISTRICTS LIKE I JUST WORKING ON
GROUNDS. AND TO. BE REDUCING THE
NUMBER OF THE CONTRACTORS. THAT
EVERY SINGLE WE HAVE LIKE LIGHT
OR FORTY SIXTEEN EIGHTEEN
CONTRACTORS IN OUR FACILITY. A
LOT OF THEM ARE NEW GRADUATES
REGARDED AS YOUR DRUM RESIDENCY.
THEIR THEIR VIDAK WITH THEM YOU
WERE INITIALLY SHE WITH THEM.
AND WE ASKED THEM AND THEY LOOK
AT US AS A BY YOU. LIKE THAT YOU
GUYS DON'T HAVE A DIED WHEN YOU
GET HALF OFF SALE IF YOU'RE
MAKING. AND IF YOU'RE TRYING TO
RECRUIT THEM YOU'RE A BY THE WAY
SO THEY'RE TRYING TO RECRUIT US
YOU KNOW THE WHAT ARE YOU GUYS
DOING THIS YOU CAN. SO IT IS
LIKE YOU KNOW LIKE YOU SAY NOT
VERY. ALSO DO. DO YOU REGARD
LIKE TWO POINT THREE OR FIVE.
RAISE I MEAN IT'S KIND OF JOKES.
SO WE HAVE YOU CAN ABOUT A
PATIENTS BECAUSE PATIENT CARE IS
GETTING REALLY AFFECT. ONE OF
CARE. IF AS A DOG. YOU WANTED.
JUST INSTEAD OF DOCTOR I HAVE
THIRTY. A DAY. OFF AND THEN GET.
THE NUMBER BELOW UP HERE FOR.
WAS A SICK. ONE IF YOU GUYS
GOING TO GO DOWN I'M GOING TO.
YARDS I'M NOT TODAY IN THE ER.
THE THREE AYE DIVISION AYE ME.
DR I. BE FOR IT TO PROVIDE HELP
TO ALL THE FISHING. BUT I'M
THREE IG. THAT IS A VERY BAD.
SIGN AND NOT ABLE TO. AN
EFFICIENT KILL A PROLONGED
HOSPITAL'S. THAT A LOT OF MY-
TO. THE EUROPEAN TAX BILL MONEY
TO THE CONTRACT. DIDN'T GET IT.
WHEN USED BE IN THE HOUSE. IF
YOU TO FROM. MONSTER OF A SIX
MONTHS. NATIONAL NEWS BE THERE
SO. MONTH STAY FOR THREE. FIVE
YEARS. THERE'S A LOT OF MONEY.
JUST BECAUSE YOU'RE NOT FIXING
THIS RECRUITMENT RETENTION
PROBLEM AND IS IT EASY FIX FOR
THAT. AND WE ARE TALKING TO
EVERYBODY THAT STARTED GET. HERE
AND WE DO NEED YOUR HELP. THE A
FIXABLE THING PLEASE DO
SOMETHING. WE ARE. QUIT IN ORDER
LIBERTY GET HIS VISIONS OF YOUR-
THEY'RE GONNA BE DEPRIVED THEIR
TO. AND WE ALSO WANT TO- YOU A
EVERYBODY TO CAN THEIR- ARE
LOOKING TO DO. YOU WERE GOING TO
BRING HOUSE. WE ARE IN PRISON
LIKE PRISONERS EVERY DAY. CELL
PHONE WE DON'T HAVE ANYTHING
ELSE YOU'RE CUT OFF FROM THE
COMMUNITY. AND WE ARE EXPOSED TO
THE RISK OF VIOLENCE AND
EVERYTHING EVERY MINUTE YOU CAN
BEGIN ANY MINUTE. ARE YOU STILL
WORKING THERE OF COURSE PEOPLE
ASK IS WHAT IS WRONG WITH YOU
GUYS BUT- YOU KNOW THERE'S A
REASONABLE DOUBT. BUT IF NOBODY
CONSIDERS THAT EVEN THE SAFETY
THINGS OF ARTISTIC CAN GET OFF.
SO NO ONE'S GONNA COME YOU KNOW
THE COMMONSENSE NO DOCTORS GOING
TO COME TO WORK IN THAT READ
YOUR LIFE IS A RISK HEALTH IS
THAT IS STUPID I'M PREPARED YOU
DON'T HAVE ANY COURT RETIREMENT
PLAN. AND PEOPLE AROUND YOU'RE
MAKING MORE MONEY THAN YOU. AND
THE AS A DOCTOR WE WANT TO
PROVIDE GOOD CARE. YOU KNOW
BECAUSE IT'S ARE UNDERSERVED IN
MEDICINE. AND B. IF YOU CANNOT
PROVIDE GOOD CARE THAT BOTHERS
US TO. YOU'RE TALKING RUBBISH
AND RICE STILL BECAUSE THIS
SHOULD NOT EXTREMELY LIBERAL
EVER MENTALLY ILL PEOPLE THEY
DON'T HAVE MY SUPPORT SYSTEM
THERE'S A REASON THAT
ADDITIONAL. AND THEY HAVE NOBODY
TO SPEAK UP FOR THEM ONLY AT THE
DOCTORS OF THE PROVIDERS AND WE
GOT IN TROUBLE FOR THAT. THANK
YOU FOR. THANK YOU DOCTOR. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF
AN **** KICKING UP FIRST ON
BEHALF OF THE NURSE FAMILY
PARTNERSHIP ON THE VOTE ON THE
CALENDAR UNDER PUBLIC HEALTH
ITEM FIFTY SEVEN ON EVIDENCE
BASED ON VISITING WE'RE GLAD TO
SEE IT MINISTRATIONS INCREASE OF
THIRTY SEVEN AND A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS BUT WE CONTINUE TO
CRUISE UP PURSUING ADDITIONAL
FIFTEEN MILLION TO SERVE MORE
FAMILIES THROUGH THIS EFFECTIVE
PROVEN PROGRAM WE HOPE TO SEE
THE FUNDING REQUEST AND WILL
WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE IN THE
ADMINISTRATION ON THIS REQUEST.
THEN ON BEHALF OF CAL PAYS THE
STATE WIDE PROGRAM OF ALL
INCLUSIVE CARE FOR THE ELDERLY
WE APPRECIATE DH CS IS UNWINDING
OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY
DOCUMENT THAT CAME OUT THIS
MORNING AND THE PACE INCLUSIONS
HOWEVER PAYS PROGRAMS WILL NEED
TO CONTINUE TO ENROLL PATIENTS
SAFELY AND QUICKLY AND WE HAVE
REQUESTED TRAILER BILL TO ALLOW
FOR TELEHEALTH ASSESSMENTS TO
ESTABLISH PEACE ENROLLEES THAT
APPEARS THE EIGHT CS WILL ALLOW
HEALTH CENTERS TO DO THAT. THIS
IS CRITICAL TO KEEPING OUR FRAIL
ELDERLY POPULATION SAFE AND
SERVED THEN ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA ACCOUNTABLE
COMMUNITIES FOR HEALTH INITIATED
FOR DEEPLY GRATEFUL FOR THE
CHAIRMAN'S LEADERSHIP ON THIS
REQUEST PROVIDE FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS ONE LOCAL AC AGES THIS
WILL HELP COMMUNITIES CONTINUE
TO BRING TOGETHER DIVERSE
LEADERS TO IDENTIFY AND LOCAL
COMMUNITY HEALTH ISSUES AND WORK
WITH CLINICAL PROVIDERS ON
AVERAGE SOURCES ON SYSTEMIC
APPROACHES TO PRINT IMPROVING
HEALTH DISPARITIES THANK YOU.
THANK AFTERNOON AND HAPPY.
ANDREAS MIGUEL BEHALF OF PLANNED
PARENTHOOD IT'S A CALIFORNIA.
JUST WANT TO EXPRESS VERY VERY
STRONG SUPPORT A LOT OF
GRATITUDE TO THE ADMINISTRATION.
AND IMPLEMENTING AGENCIES. ARE
ON ISSUE THREE SEVEN THE
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH AWARENESS
EDUCATION RESEARCH ITEM. ISSUE
ONE OF THREE UNCOMPENSATED. CARE
FOR ABORTION SORT SERVICES AND
THEN ALSO THE VOTE ON THE ITEM.
FOR LATER- ITEM FOURTEEN SO
THANK YOU THE STAFF LOOK FOR TO
WORKING WITH EACH GUY ON THESE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN HAS COMMITTEE MEMBERS
FOR ALLOWING US TO PRESENT WE
WANT TO. WE ARE THE OF THE
FRIENDSHIP HOUSE SO WE'RE IN
URBAN BASED- NATIVE AMERICAN.
NATIVE LASKIN SUPPORTING A
COMMUNITY BASED URBAN INDIAN
HEALTH PROGRAM- ARE PROGRAMS
BASICALLY IMPACT THE A PSYCH
PSYCHOLOGICAL SOCIAL WELL BEING
OF OUR COMMUNITY M. AND WE WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THE SUPPORT AND
WE ENCOURAGE A PASSAGE OF THIS.
OF THIS THE MAY REVISION IN THAT
TO THE PROCEEDS WILL ALLOCATE
THE WILL SUPPORT. AND OUR
PROGRAMS ARE GRASSROOTS PROGRAM
SAID TO IMPACTED NOT ONLY THE
URBAN COMMUNITY HERE IN SAN
FRANCISCO BUT EVERY REGION OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND NOT
ONLY ARE WE REACHING OUT AND
IMPACTING THE LIVES OF A NATIVE
AMERICANS AND ALASKA NATIVES
WITHIN THE COMMUNITY. BUT OUR
IMPACT ACTUALLY. L. BEYOND THAT
IN WE REACH THE COMMUNITY M. FOR
MULTIPLE DECADES WE HAVE BEEN A
INTRO PART WITHIN THE COMMUNITY
AND OUR PROGRAM THE VILLAGE THAT
SAID THIS BUDGET WILL SUPPORT.
IS NOT ONLY GOING TO BE A MODEL
FOR US TO IMPACT TO COMMUNITY
MEMBERS AT THE GRASS ROOTS LEVEL
WE'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO CHANGE
THE LIVES OF THE INDIVIDUAL THE
FAMILY UNIT AND ULTIMATELY
LEADING DOWN TO A COLLATERAL
IMPACT AND FINANCIAL AND DRIVING
IN RESOURCES FOR. THE
COMMUNITIES IN THE STATE M. YOUR
PASSAGE OF THE BILL WILL GREATLY
IMPACT AND- WE WILL NOT TO. YES
SIR. IF YOU WANT TO GIVE US MORE
WILL BE MORE THAN HAPPY. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR ALLOWING US TO
BE HERE. THE MY THE THANK THE
GOVERNOR AND EACH AND EVERYONE
OF YOU. MY NAME IS A MATURE SUCH
EARLY I'M NOT A HOE FROM ARIZONA
BUT I'VE BEEN LIVING IN THE BAY
AREA FOR THIRTY. FOUR CENTS TO
SIXTY AND I'VE BEEN INVOLVED
WITH THE FRENCH APOS SENSE OFBY
THE BEGINNING AND I'M STILL
THERE. I'M GONNA. FORTY THREE
HERE'S WHAT SO WE GET SO MANY
PEOPLE COME TO FRIENDSHIP HOUSE-
I TRULY UNDERSTAND WHAT THE
EXPERIENCE AND THE HELP DONE
UNTRADITIONAL COUNSELORS ARE
HELPING TO GET BACK INTO THEIR
ROOTS THEIR CULTURE. AND NO. I'M
JUST AMAZING I WILL BE TURNED ON
AND EIGHTY IN SEPTEMBER BUT I
DON'T FEEL MY AGE BECAUSE I'M
SEEING ALL THESE PEOPLE GET IN
WELD AND THE- AND THEN IT JUST
KEEP ME ON THAT I KEPT GOING
AND- I STILL USE THE STAIRS SOME
PEOPLE USE. ESCALATOR BUT I'M
STILL GOING STRONGLY. THOUGH ALL
THE SUPPORT THAT WE CAN GET FROM
EACH ONE OF YOU WILL BE. A GREAT
DREAM COME TRUE. WE JUST
RECENTLY LOST OUR C. E. O. HELEN
WALKERS IS SHE'S PRETTY WELL
KNOWN. AND HER AND I WE WENT TO
BOARDING SCHOOL. WE WERE NOT
TREATED VERY WELL SO WE KNOW THE
PAIN TO UNDERSTAND. ANNA SO I
KNOW WHAT THEY COME OUR
INDIVIDUAL COME TO THE PROGRAM
ON THE WHAT YOU WALK IN THE
WITH. THOSE WE TRULY WELCOME
THEN IS THAT YOUR CHILD COMING
HOME ESPECIALLY FOR MOM. IS A
SUCH A- GREAT PHELAN
CELEBRATION. IN AWE YOUR CHILD
IS HOME YOU DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
ANYMORE. THOSE ARE THE PEOPLE
THAT WE GET AND THAT THE WOMAN
TO COME AND FUND THE MESS OF
BOMBLETS. AND SOME OF THEM LOST
THEIR CHILDREN BUT THEY GET
THEIR CHILDREN THROUGH VENTURE
PULSE. THE ALL A WOMAN AND
TREATMENT PROGRAM AND ALAMEDA
COUNTY IN OAKLAND WE HAVE FIVE
BIDS IN WHICH THEY CAN COME AND
STAY THERE AS LONG AS THEY WANT
WE'RE THE ONLY ONE HAVE LONG
TERM PROGRAM NOT AT THE PROGRAM
ON THE RESERVATION THE ONLY A AT
TWENTY EIGHT DAYS PROGRAM THAT'S
NOT EVEN ENOUGH FOR YOU TO GET
GO BACK ON YOUR FEET ESPECIALLY
WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE. SOURCES IN
THE BAY AREA. THAT BEING HERE
TODAY IS A REALLY HONOR. I WANT
TO THANK EACH AND EVERYONE OF
YOU. FOR SUPPORT US THE COMPLETE
THIS VILLAGE I REALLY LIKE TO
SEE IT. BEFORE I PASS ON OR-
LEAVE. THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR ADVOCACY. I NOW
THAT OKAY ALL RIGHT- I HAD A
WHOLE SPEECH PLANNED FOR MAY BUT
HAVE IT I DO BEST I'M SPEAKING
FROM MY HEART- GOOD AFTERNOON MY
pNAVAJO PUBLIC PAIUTE ENROLLED
MEMBER OF THE WALKER RIVER.
PAIUTE TRIBE OF SHARES NEVADA-
I'VE BEEN LIVING IN THE BAY AREA
MY ENTIRE LIFE SOI'M IN URBAN
NATIVE.I'M I'M THE CONTRACTS IN
COMPLIANCE MANAGER FOR THE
FRIENDSHIP HOUSE I AM ALSO ONE
OF THE VILLAGE PROJECT LEADS AND
I'VE OVERSEE OUR YOUTH PROGRAM
AND OVERSEE OUR WOMEN'S LODGE- I
WANTED TO THANK YOU GUYS FOR
JUST LISTENING TO US TODAY
GIVING US THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
SHARE OUR HEARTS WITH YOU AND
SHOULD SHARE OUR WORK AND URGING
YOU GUYS TO. YOU KNOW PROVE
THESE MAJOR REVISIONS I THINK
GAVIN- GOVERNOR GAVIN NEWSOM FOR
ALL OF HIS SUPPORT. NOT JUST FOR
UP. IN AGE BUT HE'S BEEN WITH US
IN THE PAST HE HAD A REALLY
CLOSE CONNECTION WITH- OUR CEO
WHO PATRICIA JUST TALKED ABOUT-
I WANTED TO SPEAK- FROM MY
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE AND BECAUSE
I HAVE THE EMPATHY OF BEING A
WOMAN AND RECOVERY. AND BEING A
MOM AND RECOVERY AS WELL- THOUGH
I DIDN'T GO THROUGH THE PROGRAM-
A FRENCH PALACE I KNOW WHAT IT
IS TO GO FIRSTHAND BEAST-
BETWEEN. CHOOSING WHETHER YOU
SEEK TREATMENT WITH OR WITHOUT
YOUR CHILD AND THAT'S SOMETHING
THAT WE DO- THE WOMEN'S LARGE
THAT PATRICIA DID TALK ABOUT
SERVICE DIRECTLY WOMEN WHO CAN
GO THROUGH RECOVERY AND HEAL THE
FAMILY FROM WITHIN. WITH THEIR
CHILDREN UP TO AGE AS OF THE
FIVE. WITH APPROVAL THESE MAJOR
REVISIONS IT WILL HELP US IT.
CONTINUE WITH OUR DIVISION
CONTINUE WITH OUR DREAM OF AND
SERVING THE AMERICAN INDIAN-
COMMUNITY. SO WE JUST ASK HER.
TIONAL. YOUR RESULTS FOR YOU
GUYS SUPPORT BECAUSE THERE'S ARE
BECAUSE THERE ARE ANY IS OUT
THERE THERE ARE PEOPLE OUT THERE
ALL OVER CALIFORNIA THAT TENS
THAT WE CAN SERVE THAT NEED OUR
HELP- GOING ALL THE WAY FROM OUR
YOUTH ALL THE WAY TO OUR ELDERS
AND THAT THIS PASSING A WILL
DEFINITELY HELP THAT- THAT. THE
PASSENGERS REVISION AGAIN IT
WILL- IT AFFECTS GREATLY FOR
THAT. THE CRISIS FOR THE MMI W.
THE MISSING MURDERED INDIGENOUS
WOMEN WHO- WE SEE A LOT OF THEM
GOING THROUGH OUR DOORS- THE B.
HAVE. PROBLEMS WITH DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE HUMAN TRAFFICKING HAS
BEEN SOMETHING THAT'S ON THE
RISE FOR OUR PEOPLE. AND OF WE
REALLY LIKED SAID NOT NIP IN THE
BUD BUT WE LIKE TO AT LEAST
INCREASE THE NUMBERS AND CREATE
VISIBILITY FOR US. SO THANK YOU
GUYS AGAIN FOR. THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR LETTING US SPEAKS IN FRONT
OF YOU GUYS. RIGHT THANK YOU
YET. THANK YOU. A GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS MY NAME IS
BERNARD GARCIA I AM NOW THE
WHOLE AND- BUBBLE FROM NEW
MEXICO- I ALSO WORK AT THE
LODGE- ACTUALLY I OVERSEE THE
LODGES WELL- I SEE A LOT OF THE
WOMEN COME IN AND I SEE THEM
BROKEN. I SEE THE KIDS BROKE IN-
IT BREAKS MY HEART. IT TAKES A
LOT AND WHEN THEY SAY THAT IT
TAKES A VILLAGE IT REALLY DOES
IT REALLY DOES- WE HAVE TO WORK
WITH THEM EVERY DAY COMING DOWN
WHETHER IT WAS ABUSE. WHETHER IT
WAS- DRUGS- TRAFFICKING YOU KNOW
WE GIVE THEM A SAFE PLACE TO
COME TO A SAFE PLACE WHERE THEY
CAN HEAL. YOU KNOW SOUL BODY AND
MIND. AND YOU KNOW IT'S NOT I
DON'T TAKE IT LIGHTLY I MEAN
I'VE BEEN HERE WITH VENTURE
PULSE ELEVEN YEARS. AND HELEN
WAS MY AUNT AND THAT'S NOT. THAT
WAS ONE OF THE REASONS WHY I WAS
THERE BUT- THE REASON IS BECAUSE
I FEEL IT WITH MY HEART. AND I
FEEL THAT WITH THESE THESE
DOCTORS HERE I COULD TOTALLY
FEEL EVERYTHING THAT THEY FELT
AND- BEING A PROVIDER BEING THAT%
SOME PERSON TO. WEAR THOSE WOMEN
TO FEEL SAFE IT MEANS A LOT AND
WE NEED A PLACE. A BIGGER PLACE
FOR THEM TO BE AND A BIGGER
PLACE THAT WE CAN HOUSE THEM AND
ENSURE THEM AND BRING THEM BACK
AS A FAMILY. AND INSANIYAT I ASK
THAT YOU SUPPORT. THE GOVERNOR'S
YOU KNOW BUDGET PROPOSAL BECAUSE
WE REALLY NEEDED AND WE REALLY
WOULD APPRECIATE IT AND- WILL
DO. ALL ARE REAL WE WILL DO OUR
BEST BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT WE DO
NOW BUT THAT WOULD HELP
TREMENDOUSLY SO I. I THANK YOU
FOR LETTING US BE HERE AND
SPEAKING. AND WE'RE GRATEFUL
FROM OUR HEARTS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. HI MY NAME IS JACKIE HAZAMA
A DRUG AND ALCOHOL COUNSELOR- AT
THE FRIENDSHIP HOUSE AND THANK
YOU GOVERNOR FOR HAVING US ON
THE BUDGET. I CAME TO THE
FRIENDSHIP HOUSE AND I WAS
ADDICTED TO DRUGS AND ALCOHOL
PAUL- I HAVE CHILDREN AND IT WAS
VERY SCARY. I WAS VERY CONFUSED
AND THE FRIENDSHIP HOUSE GAVE ME
SPACE TO HEAL- AND I LEARNED
SAID TO TREAT MYSELF- MORE
SACRED- I HELP MOMS THAT COME IN
AND- THEY THEY'RE IF THEY'RE
FRUSTRATED THEY'RE IF THEY'RE
UPSET THEIR CHILDREN THEY COME
IN THE- HIT THE CHILDREN COMING
CONFUSED AND I JUST GIVE THEM
SPACE TO HELP WORK THEM THROUGH
ALL OF THESE FEELINGS. AND THE
IS VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE DO YOU
KNOW WHAT WE WILL BE ABLE TO
CENTRALIZE OUR SERVICES AND WE
HAVE MORE RESOURCES IN SAN
FRANCISCO THAN ANYWHERE ELSE AND
SOME OF THE TOP. YOU KNOW TOP
THE LINE. UP RESOURCES IN THAT
AREA I THINK THAT IS VERY
IMPORTANT THAT- THIS. THIS
PROPOSALBECOME CONSIDER TO HELP
OUR IN OUR NATIVE- I'M I'M
JACKIE I'M A NEW CHARACTER- MY
MOTHER MY MOTHER'S FROM UP ABOVE
NOAM. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON FIRST AND FOREMOST I'D
LIKE TO SEND OUT A- THANK YOU TO
THAT CALIFORNIA'S STATE ASSEMBLY
THE GOVERNMENT NEWSOME- THE
PROPOSAL- I TO EMMA- ED. ALUMNI
FROM THE HOUSE- YEAH I WAS
INVITED HERE TODAY JUST ADDED
YARD INSTANT- EVERYTHING THAT
WAS SAID HERE TODAY. IT RANG A
BELL ON EVERY EVERY SINGLE TOPIC
. MY HEART GOES OUT TO ALL THOSE
THAT HAVE LOST DUE TO COVETED
AND WE WERE HERE TO YOU KNOW TO
TRY TO KEEP GOING WITH THIS AS
AS- I MET MISS PATRICIA. AND I
GOT A CHANCE TO MAKE MISS HELEN
BREAKFAST IS TO AS WELL- FOR A
LITTLE BIT AND- MISS VERNADSKY I
TRAINED UNDER HER FOR THE LAST
COUPLE YEARS AND NOW I'M UNDER.
HER HUSBAND YOU KNOW AND- THE
THING TO BE INVITED HERE TODAY
IS TO STAND UP. AND FIGHT FOR MY
FAMILY TO AS WELL THIS IS MY
FAMILY. AS WELL AS EVERYBODY
ELSE IN THIS ROOM YOU KNOW SO I
JUST WANTED TO SAY THANK YOU.
AND YOU KNOW SUPPORT THE BALLOT
IN THE- THANK YOU. HELLO MY NAME
IS PETER BRETT GET TRY MADA. OF
WITH THE FRENCH OPPOSED TO
SOCIAL ASIAN AMERICAN INDIANS
FOR OVER TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
WE'RE DOING SOMETHING VERY
UNIQUE. THE MAJORITY OF AMERICAN
INDIANS TODAY IN THE UNITED
STATES RESIDE IN CITIES. URBAN
AREAS HELLO IS THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE IS 72% IN CALIFORNIA'S
OVER NINETY PERCENT. OF NATIVE
LIVE IN CITIES ACROSS THE STATE. UNFORTUNATELY WE REMAIN
LARGELY INVISIBLE AND
UNDERSERVED GOOD THANK WERE
EXTINCT. WE'RE BUILDING A
VILLAGE AND URBAN VISION
AMERICAN INDIAN VILLAGE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE CITY. THAT'S WHY
PEOPLE ARE SO THAT'S WHY WE'RE
DOING IT- THE GOVERNOR PURPORT
OF FIFTEEN THE PROPOSAL WE'RE
BUILDING A SOCIAL SIR DUBLIN
OFFER MEDICAL. DENTAL BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH. YOU SERVICES ELDER
SERVICES AND MORE THAN ANYTHING
ELSE RIGHT NOW WE'RE HOMELESS
WE'RE GONNA HAVE A CULTURAL
CENTER OF PHYSICAL SPACE WE CAN
GATHER AND CONNECT AS COMMUNITY
. MY BROTHER'S HOLDEN THE STAFF
RIGHT HERE EAGLE FEATHER BUFFALO
. MANY OF OUR ANCESTORS THEY
SHED THEIR BLOOD THEY GAVE THEIR
LIFE WE CAN BE STANDING HERE
USING THESE THINGS AT ONE TIME
THESE WERE OUTLAWED FOR US TO
USE. WE USE CULTURE AS A
CORNERSTONE WE KNOW THE CULTURES
ARE MEDICINE. URGING YOU. TO
SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL
WE'RE NOT JUST CREATING A MODEL-
TO SERVE BAY AREA NATIVES WE ALL
OUR CLIENTS THE COME FROM
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY FROM
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. THERE'S NO
OTHER SUPERVISORS KNOW THE MODEL
LIKE THE ONE THAT WE USE FOR THE
OLDEST SOCIAL SERVANTS THE
SOCIAL SERVICE AGENCY LED BY AND
FOR NATIVE AMERICANS IN THE
COUNTRY. WE KNOW THAT WE'RE
CREATING A MODEL TO BE
REPLICATED NOT JUST AND OTHER
NATIVE COMMUNITIES BUT OTHER
COMMUNITIES PERIOD ACROSS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY SO WE URGE YOU. TO
SUPPORT THIS. RING WAY OF LIFE
PEOPLE NEED TO FEEL CONNECTED
PEOPLE NEED A SENSE OF BELONGING
AS WE URGE YOU TO SUPPORT THIS
WEEK THANK YOU FOR GIVING US
THIS TIME I HOPE THANK YOU I'M A
RELATIVE DOUBLETS YOU TO FOR TO
DO WE HAVE A LOT OF RESPECT FOR
OUR HEALERS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SEEING NO FURTHER PUBLIC
COMMENT IN THE ROOM WE WILL NOW
GO TO THE PHONE LINE FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. AS A REMINDER THE PHONE
NUMBER AND PASSCODE IT IS ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AND SHOULD BE
ON THE SCREEN. IF YOU ARE
WATCHING OVER THE INTERNET. THE
NUMBER IS AGAIN. ONE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO. EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. THE PUBLIC ACCESS
CODE IS ONE EIGHT FIVE ZERO.
ELEVEN HUNDRED. IF YOU ENCOUNTER
ANY PROBLEMS PLEASE CONTACT THE
ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE. AT.
916-319-2090 NINE. AND A STAFF
MEMBER WILL ASSIST YOU. OPERATOR
WE ARE READY TO BEGIN PUBLIC
COME. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. YOU
WILL THEN RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER MEET FACE BACK INTO THE
QUEUE. YOU'RE USING A
SPEAKERPHONE PLEASE PICK UP THE
HAND BEFORE PARKING THE NUMBERS.
ONCE AGAIN FOR PUBLIC COMMENT TO
THE ONE THEN THEY'RE WRONG. AND
WE HAVE ABOUT THIRTY FOUR PEOPLE
IN Q. RIGHT NOW AND WE WILL
START WITH LINE NUMBER EIGHTEEN
. DR ARAMBULA AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON TRACY OR TRADE ON
THE PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE AND
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PAST SUPPORT OF THE BUDGET
REQUEST TO ESTABLISH A
CALIFORNIA HEALTH EQUITY IN
RACIAL JUSTICE FUND. WE
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
INVESTMENTS AND HEALTHEQUITY IN
THE MAY REVISE HOWEVER ONCE
AGAIN DIRECTLY INVESTING IN
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO
ADVANCE RACIAL JUSTICE WHAT'S
LEFT OUT. EIGHT TO RACIAL
JUSTICE CONTINUES TO FAIL
CALIFORNIANS OF COLOR WE NEED
LOOK NO FURTHER THAN THE
INEQUITABLE IMPACTS TO COPE WITH
NINETEEN WHICH WERE DRIVEN BY A
LEGACY OF STRUCTURAL RACISM. THE
TOP DOWN PROPOSAL FROM THE MAY
RESIDE WITH GOVERNMENT
PRESCRIBING BOTH THE ISSUES AND
THE SOLUTIONS TO HELP THAT
INEQUITIES MUST BE BALANCED WITH
THE EXPERTISE. OF THE
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE MOST.
HEALTHEQUITY IN RACIAL JUSTICE
FUND WILL DO JUST THAT BY
PROVIDING DIRECT SUPPORT TO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO
IDENTIFY AND DEVELOP EFFECTIVE
STRATEGIES TO ADDRESS THE MOST
URGENT INEQUITIES AND INJUSTICES
IN THEIR NEIGHBORHOODS.
CALIFORNIA HAS RELIED ON
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO
HELP THEM BE IMPACTS OF COPING
NINETEEN INDUSTRY IS WORK WE
NEED TO KEEP UP THE FIGHT FOR
HEALTHEQUITY ON RACIAL JUSTICE
AND THIS TIME WE'RE RELYING ON
YOU TO ADVOCATE FOR INCLUDING
THE HEALTH EQUITY AND RACIAL
JUSTICE FUND IN CALIFORNIA STATE
BUDGET. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE
HAVE A LINE NUMBER THIRTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS GASOLINE
POWERED ON BEHALF OF JUSTICE IN
AGING WELL WE APPRECIATE THE
PROPOSALS TO IMPROVE ACCESS AND
AFFORDABILITY OF MEDIC HELD
PROPOSED BY THE ADMINISTRATION
WE BELIEVE THAT THERE IS A KEY
PIECE MISSING FOR OLDER ADULTS
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES. WE
WOULD URGE THE SUBCOMMITTEE AND
THE ASSEMBLY TO PRIORITIZE
REFORMING THE MEDIC HEALTHCARE
COSTS PROGRAM BY RAISING THE
MAINTENANCE NEED INCOME LEVEL
210038% OF THE FEDERAL POVERTY
LEVEL. THE RULES FOR THIS
PROGRAM HAVE NOT BEEN UPDATED
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY NINE AND
THERE FOR OLDER ADULTS AND
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES ARE
BEING FORCED TO LIVE ON SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH IN ORDER
TO ACCESS THEIR MEDICAL CARE. IN
PRACTICE THIS MEANS THAT PEOPLE
FORCED TO PAY 60% OR MORE OF
THEIR INCOME EACH MONTH TOWARD
CARE THE MEDICAL CARE COST
PROGRAM FORCES AGING ADULT
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND
THEIR FAMILIES TO MAKE
IMPOSSIBLE CHOICES BETWEEN
HEALTHCARE AND PAYING RENT AND
HAVING FOOD ON THE TABLE. THE
PROPOSAL IS IN LINE WITH OTHER
PARTS. WITH STRONG THE PROPOSAL
BEING IN THE STATE. A WE WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS OUR CONTINUED
OPPOSITION TO CARE COURT AND THE
FUNDING PROPOSED IN THE REVISION
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OPERATOR
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. ADELINE
NUMBER TWENTY FIVE IT'S GONNA.
GOOD AFTERNOON LINDA WAY WITH
WESTERN CENTER ON MOM POVERTY WE
SUPPORT THE ADMINISTRATION
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE DO A
REIMBURSEMENT RATE AS A STEP
TOWARD EQUITABLE COVERAGE
MEDICARE NAVIGATOR FUNDING
PERMANENTLY EXTENDING PRESENTED
THAT MEGYN KELLY AND GRANT SINKS
INTO A LEGAL AID ORGANIZATION
AND OPPOSE CARE COURT FINDING WE
ALSO URGE THE FOLLOWING
INVESTMENT THAT WERE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE NEIGHBOR VISION.
YOUR QUEST FUNDING TO UPDATE THE
MEDICARE SHARED COST PROGRAMS IN
THE LEAD JUST SHARED IN YOUR
THAN PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES
WITH INCOMES SLIGHTLY ABOVE THE
THREE MEDIC HOW WOMEN ARE
EXPECTED TO LIVE ON SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS A MONTH TO ACCESS
MEDICAL SERVICES IT'S NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE TO LIVE ON SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH IN
CALIFORNIA HIGHLIGHTING THE NEED
TO INCREASE THE MAINTENANCE
NEEDS LEVEL WITH AB NINETEEN
HUNDRED BE DISPLAYED AT THE
ECHO. WE ALSO REQUESTED FULL SB
SIXTY FIVE FUNDING IMPLEMENTING
MEDICAL EXPANSION TO ALL INCOME
VOLATILITY SOON AS POSSIBLE AND
PREVENTING COVERAGE. OFF TO AGE
OUT.
HUNTINGTON PREMIUM SUBSIDIES BUT
THIS APPEARS LIMITED TO MIDDLE
INCOMES ABOVE 4100% OF THE
FEDERAL POVERTY LEVEL I WOULD
REQUEST KINDLY GO TO LOW INCOME
FAMILIES AS WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU OPERATOR NEXT. NUMBER
TWELVE. THANK YOU- MY NAME IS
THE ONE THAT I'VE DONE I AM
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER OPERATES WANT TO THANK
THE GOVERNOR FOR INCLUDING
HEALTH NAVIGATORS FUNDING IN HIS
BUDGET- WE ASK THAT THE
LEGISLATOR LEGISLATURE ENHANCE
AND IMPROVE THE CURRENT PROGRAM
BY STOPPING THE COMMUNITY BASED
APPROACH OUTLINED BY AB TWENTY
SIX EIGHTY A NAVIGATOR IN THE
SECOND MEDICARE ENROLLMENT AND
RETENTION- YEAH LEGISLATURE TO
SUPPORT THIS KEY HEALTH. EQUITY
AND RACIAL JUSTICE POWER
EFFECTIVELY AND WE'RE JUST NOW
EXPANDING MEDICAID. TO MORE MORE
POPULATION. WE ALSO THREATENED
TO PUT ME. THAT THE GOVERNOR DID
NOT INCLUDE FUNDING TO INCREASE
THE- ON THE HEALTH. EXCEPT
MOBILE MEDIC. ARGUMENT YEAH OR
GREAT STATE DISPARITIES
ACCESSING MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
MATAGAL WE ARE LEGISLATURE TO
INVEST RESOURCES TO GET THE WORD
OUT. THE QUALITY THAT THAT GAP
AND THE FINALLY WE DO WANT TO
THANK THE GOVERNOR FOR INCLUDING
HELP FOR ALL IN THE BUDGET AND
THE LEGISLATURE. TO ENSURE
IMPLEMENTATION HAPPENS AS SOON
AS POSSIBLE WITHOUT A DOUBT FOR
THOSE WHO CAN CONTACT. THE
IMPLEMENTATION FOR ALL ADULTS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU OPERATOR
NEXT CALLER. NINE THIRTY. GOOD
AFTERNOON NICOLE WATERMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP WITH PARK LAST
YEAR'S INVESTMENT IN THE
pCHILDREN YOUR BILL HEALTH
INITIATIVE HOWEVER WITHOUT A
CLEAR PLAN OR DEDICATED FUNDING
IT WILL NOT SERVING THE CRITICAL
NEED INFANT TODDLER. WE
RECOMMENDED. IN EARLY MENTAL
HEALTH AND TRAUMA INFORMED CARE
INVESTMENTS WITH NO LESS THAN
TWO HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION IN
ADDITIONAL GENERAL FUND SPENDING
. THE SENATE INCLUDED CONTINUOUS
MEDICAL COVERAGE FOR CHILDREN
AGES ZERO TO FIVE AND THEIR
PRIORITIES AND WE ENCOURAGE THE
ASSEMBLY ALSO PRIORITIZE THIS
POLICY. WE THINK THERE GOVERNOR
FOR RECOMMITTING TO RECRUITING
TRAINING AND CERTIFYING TWENTY
FIVE THOUSAND NEW COMMUNITY
HEALTH WORKERS AND ALSO REQUEST
THAT CHILD HEALTH AND
DEVELOPMENT BE AN AREA OF FOCUS
FOR THIS INVESTMENT. FINALLY THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP SUPPORT
THE COMPREHENSIVE PRENATAL
SERVICES PROGRAM THANK REQUEST
TO- THAT MEDICARE COVERS SOCIAL
DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH SERVICES.
BREASTFEEDING SUPPORT AND OTHER
WRAPAROUND SERVICES THROUGHOUT
THE TWELFTH MONTH POST PREGNANCY
PERIOD. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE
HAVE ONE NUMBER TWENTY FOUR.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND HAPPY
BIRTHDAY DR GRANT ELECTRICITY AT
ONE BOARD BOND ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP AS WELL
SUPPORTING THE FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR ACCOUNTABLE
COMMUNITIES FOR HEALTH TO
ADVANCE HEALTH EQUITY AND
DISRUPTS CORRECTIONAL RESEARCH
BASED. UP AND COMING. THE
COMMUNITY COLLABORATION
ADDITIONALLY WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSED CONTINUED FUNDING FOR
THE NAVIGATOR GRANT PROGRAM TO
ENSURE FAMILIES DO NOT LOSE
THEIR MEDICAL COVERAGE AND
FINALLY THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP RESPECTFULLY OPPOSES
THE ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSAL TO
SUNSET THE CHILDREN'S HEALTH AND
DISABILITY PREVENTION PROGRAM
THE PREMATURE ELIMINATION OF THE
CHILDREN'S HEALTH AND DISABILITY
PREVENTION PROGRAM WILL CREATE
GAPS IN CARE AND REDUCE THE
QUALITY OF CARE FOR CALIFORNIA'S
MOST VULNERABLE CHILDREN. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE
HAVE Y. NUMBER THIRTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON DIANA
DOUGLAS WITH HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA REGARDING COVERED
CALIFORNIA PORTABILITY
ASSISTANCE HEALTH ACCESS URGES
THE ASSEMBLY TO SUPPORT
COMMITMENT FOR MUCH NEEDED COST
SHARING ASSISTANCE TO COVERED
CALIFORNIA ENROLLEES IF THE
FEDERAL A. R. P. SUBSIDIES ARE
CONTINUED. IF THE FEDERAL
SUBSIDIES ARE NOT CONTINUE THE
THREE HUNDRED FOUR MILLION
INCLUDES IN THE MAY REVISED
HEALTH DRASTICALLY SHORT OF
COVERING THE EXISTING FEDERAL
INVESTMENT IN IN FACT IT ALSO
STILL SIGNIFICANTLY LESS THAN
THE ROUGHLY FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
MILLION NEEDED TO EVEN THREE IN
OUR PREVIOUS STATE OF THE
PROGRAM. THE COST OF LIVING
HIGHER THAN EVER WE CAN'T AFFORD
NOT A COMMITMENT TO AN
AFFORDABLE MARKET PLACE. I'M NOT
ACCOUNT FOR WE SINCERELY. THE
PROPOSAL FOR INCLUDING THE
EXPANSION OF HEALTH FOR ALL THE
PEOPLE AGE TWENTY SIX OF FORTY
NINE. AND REMOVING THE FINAL
BARRIER PREVENTING QUALIFYING
CALIFORNIANS FROM ACCESSING
HEALTH CARE. HOWEVER WE DO
CONTINUE TO SEEK AN EARLIER
IMPLEMENTATION DATE AND MEASURES
TO ENSURE NO YOUNG ADULT AGE
OUT. ALLOWING FOR A JOB IN A
PROLONGED IMPLEMENTATION
TIMELINE OUR COUNTERPART
MITCHELL CALLS OF UNIVERSAL
COVERAGE FOR ALL STUDENTS WE
CAN. WE ALSO SUPPORT THAT
PROPOSAL TO FUND A MEDIC CAL
HEALTH. ENROLLMENT NAVIGATORS
PROJECT TO HELP MEDICARE
BENEFICIARIES NAVIGATE THE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM. IN RUN
SUPPORT AND REFORMING THE MEDIC
HEALTHCARE COSTS PROGRAM. THE
PROPOSAL IMPROVE MEDICAL FORTY
BILLION SHOULD BE PRIORITIZED BY
THE ASSEMBLY TO BE INCLUDED IN
THE FINAL STATE BUDGET. AND THEN
FINALLY WE SUPPORT REVISIONS
INCLUDING OF RESOURCES FOR THE
CONTINUED WORK OF THE HOUSE AND
THE HEALTHY CALIFORNIA FOR ALL
COMMISSION. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO HER COMMENTS
TODAY WE LOOK TO CONTINUING TO
WORK TOGETHER THANK YOU. NEXT
PLEASE. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND MEMBERS
TARGET BY ETHAN ON BEHALF OF THE
STEINBERG INTO TEAR WE WORKED
THRILLED TO SEE ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENT INTO MENTAL HEALTH
AND SUBSTANCE USE DISORDERS IN
THE NAY REVISED ON TOP OF THE
HISTORIC TWENTY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO BUDGET AND VISIONARY
COMMENT ON A COUPLE OF ITEMS WE
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THE HHS
CRISIS PLANNING PROCESS AND THE
SEVEN POINT FIVE MILLION ONE
TIME AND SIX MILLION ON GOING
PRETTY OP AT THE MERGING P.
SERVICES TO IMPLEMENT THE
NECESSARY TECHNOLOGY FOR THE
NINETY DAY CRISIS LINE. HOWEVER
WITH THE NUMBER GOING LIVE IN
JULY WE ALSO REQUESTED
ADDITIONAL EIGHT MILLION ONE
TIME AND GAPS FUNDING FOR THE
CALL CENTERS FOR THE FIRST YEAR
OF NINETY EIGHT WERE ALSO
REQUESTING THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
A SMALL PHONE PETERS SUSTAINABLY
FINDS THE NINE EIGHT EIGHT THE
MOVING FORWARD. WE ALSO CONTINUE
TO SUPPORT ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLAR HEALTH WORKFORCE
INITIATIVES AND ALSO SUPPORT THE
ADDITIONAL ONE POINT FORTY SEVEN
BILLION DOLLAR BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
WORKERS PACKAGE KNOWN AS FOCUS
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH. BEING
CHAMPIONED BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
BARRICADE CAN SENATOR WIENER AND
SPONSORED BY THE TIME THEY'RE
GOING TO TEACH AND THE
LEGISLATIVE VEHICLE. IS AT THE
NINE SIXTY FOUR. WE APPLIED
GOVERNOR NEW AND- ARE BURKE AND
EGGMAN THEIR- LEADERS. TO
IMPROVE THE LIVES OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE CALIFORNIANS YOUR
UPSTREAM. CLIENT CENTERED CARE
IN CARE COURT WE SUPPORT THE
ITEMS IN A REVISED AT THE POINT
ANY SYSTEM COMPONENTS CREATED
UNDER THE CARE COURT FRAMEWORK.
WITH FORTY CONTINUING TO PARTNER
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE IN THE WEEKS AHEAD.
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. YOU WILL GO
TO MY NUMBER FORTY TWO. MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS I MEAN
CAPACITY FOR THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION WE
APPRECIATE THE INVESTMENT
PROPOSED FOR CONSIDERATION
EXPAND ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH YOU THE ADMINISTRATION
AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS ON
IMPLEMENTATION DETAILS AND
TIMING. WE WANT THE FLAG ONE
ISSUE FOR YOU IN MAY REVISION
RELATED TO COUNTY MEDICAL
ELIGIBILITY OPERATIONS WHERE WE
BELIEVE THERE IS AN ERROR IN THE
CALCULATION OF THE INFLATIONARY
ADJUSTMENTS THAT RESULT IN AN
ESTIMATED SHORTFALL OF TWENTY
THREE MILLION GENERAL FUND. WE
THINK THAT THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
TECHNICAL ERROR AND OF REACHED
OUT TO DATE YES STAFF TO ENSURE
THAT IS CORRECTED. WE ALSO
CONTINUE TO JOIN WITH THE
COALITION IN OPPOSITION TO THE
PROPOSED SUNSET OF CHILDREN THE
CHILDREN'S HEALTH AND DISABILITY
PREVENTION PROGRAM WHICH WE
BELIEVE WILL HAVE AN IMPACT ON
THE HEALTH CARE SERVICES FOR
FOSTER CARE FOR FOSTER YOUTH AND
IT'S PREMATURE. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. MY
NUMBER FORTY. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS SHERIN REPORT WITH THE
CORPORATION FOR SUPPORTIVE
HOUSING ON BEHALF OF THE CORE OF
CORPORATIONS PROPOSING IN
HOUSING CALIFORNIA WE
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE THE CARE
COURT PROPOSAL COERCIVE MODELS
ARE FAR LESS EFFECTIVE THAN
VOLUNTARY PARTICIPATION IN
TREATMENT WEEK KNOWLEDGE THE
CRISIS OF CARE COURT BUDGET-
PROPOSAL IS INTENDED TO ADDRESS
AND RECOMMEND INSTEAD FUNDING
HOUSING SUBSIDIES BUT THE THIRD
OF COMMUNITY TREATMENT SERVICES
WHICH ARE BOTH PROVEN EVIDENCE
BASED MODEL. I ALSO WANT TO
COMMENT ON A NEW INVEST. FOR
TARGETED PROGRAM TO PREVENT AND
HOMELESSNESS AMONG OLDER ADULTS
AND PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
THAT IS AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
NECESSARY AND AB TWENTY FIVE
FORTY SEVEN- WE ARE ASKING FOR A
ONE TIME BUDGET REQUEST THAT'S
SEVEN HUNDRED FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS OVER FOUR YEARS. THIS
BUDGET PROPOSAL WILL IMPLEMENT
EFFECTIVE MODELS FOR IDENTIFYING
PEOPLE AT RISK OF HOMELESSNESS
AS OLDER ADULTS. AND PROVIDING
HOUSING SUBSIDIES THAT ALLOW
PEOPLE TO REMAIN IN THEIR OWN
INDEPENDENT HOUSING CONSISTENT
WITH THE MASTER PLAN FOR AGING.
WE EXPECT THIS PROPOSAL TO
PREVENT AND HOMELESSNESS FOR
ABOUT SIXTEEN THOUSAND I'M
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WE HAVE LINE NUMBER
FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU DR ARAMBULA GIFTED AND J. D.
AS ON BEHALF OF KAISER
PERMANENTE HEY WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF DHT ACTIVE PROPOSED
MAYBE LIFE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE
ON COMMITTING THE DEPARTMENT TO
ENTER INTO DIRECT CONTRACTS WITH
KAISER PERMANENTE FOR MEDIC
HEALTH SERVICES. THE PROPOSAL IS
A CAREFULLY BALANCED APPROACH
THAT WILL ALLOW HI THERE
PERMANENTLY THE EVENT HEALTH
EQUITY AND INCREASE ACCESS TO
HIGH QUALITY CARE FOR A BROADER
NUMBER OF MEDICARE BENEFICIARIES
IN A WAY THAT REDUCES
ADMINISTRATIVE COMPLEXITY
INCREASES STATE OVERSIGHT AND
ENFORCEMENT AND IS INTENDED TO
SUPPORT AND COMPLEMENT THE LOCAL
DELIVERY SYSTEM. WE AFFECT THE
PROPOSAL BE INCLUDED IN THE
FINAL. YOU CALLER PLEASE. WE
HAVE A NUMBER FORTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU HI DARBY
KERNAN WITH LEADINGAGE
CALIFORNIA WE SUPPORT ITEM
NUMBER NOT BEING IN A GENDER THE
AUGMENT THE WORKFORCE ALLOCATION
AND CAN GREATLY IMPROVE THE
TRAINING OF SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES STAFF WE ALSO SUPPORT
I INTEND FOR SKILLED NURSING
FACILITIES CONSOLIDATED
FINANCIAL REPORTING. IN ADDITION
IT'S CALIFORNIA BRACES FOR YET
ANOTHER GAME EVEN. LEADING HER
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL THAT HAS
BEEN IN THE NEIGHBOR. WHICH IS
THE OF A LONG TERM CARE MUTUAL
AID PROGRAMS WHICH TO SUPPORT
RESPONDED BY LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND LONG TERM CARE FACILITIES
THAT THE PHILIPPINE EVACUATION
SURGE CAPACITY ANDOTHER
DISASTER RESPONSE. IT IS
SOMETHING THAT EACH GUY HOLDEN
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY AND CAL
ONLY ASH- SHOULD ALL BE WORKING
TOGETHER ON. AND THEN ON BEHALF
OF AMITY FOUNDATION WEST CARE
AND GREAT THREE. WE HELLO THE
THREE- PROPOSED LICENSE FEE
INCREASE FOR SUBSTANCE USE
DISORDER PROGRAM WE REQUEST A
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR BACKFIELD
OVER FIVE YEARS TO. FIFTY
INCREASED LET'S BE INCREASE WILL
PUT BUSINESSES OUT OF- THIS WILL
CREDIT PROVIDERS OUT OF BUSINESS
AND WE NEED THEM MORE THAN EVER
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LEVINE NUMBER FIFTY.
REMEMBER CAPTAIN MARKRAM HALF OF
A FEW CLIENTS FIRST ON BEHALF OF
THE DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES THAT
WORK ON THE COLBERT UNWINDING
ISSUE UNDER DTS TWO ONE THANK
BOTH DR WOULD ADVOCACY AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES FOR INCLUDING INCLUDING
THE MAINTENANCE OF OUR 10% RATE
INCREASE FROM LAST YEAR WITHOUT
THESE MONIES MANY OF OUR HOMES
WOULD HAVE BEEN FORCED TO.
CONSIDER CLOSING THEIR DOORS
UNDER GTX CALENDRICAL THE WANT
TO THANK THE DEPARTMENT FOR
DELAYING THE MOVE OUR HOME TO
MEDICAL MEDICARE MANAGED CARE
FOR THE WE ARE STILL PROPOSING
TO HAVE A ONE YEAR DELAY IN
WHICH YOU CAN DO THE WORK THE
LEGISLATURE EXTRADITION ON THAT
BUT CERTAINLY DO APPRECIATE THEM
LISTENING TO OUR CONCERNS ISSUE
ON BEHALF OF THE ACTIVE HELP THE
ORGANIZATION THAT OVERSEES THE
STATE'S FEDERAL FAMILY PLANNING
DOLLARS ONE THING THE
ADMINISTRATION COULD INCLUSION
OF THE REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
PACKAGE YOU DON'T WANT TO BE
CALLED SURE ACCESS TO ABORTION.
IS PROTECTED AND EXPANDED ALSO
ONE AFTER BEING WHO THE REQUEST
FROM YOU ACCESS FOR TEN MILLION
ONE DOLLARS TO BACKFILL BURKE
RECENT CERTIFIED IN LOSS OF
CRITICAL FEDERAL FAMILY PLANNING
DOLLARS IN CALIFORNIA FAMILY
PLANNING SAFETY THAT WHOLE IF WE
FAIL TO SECURE THESE ONE HOWEVER
WE HAVE TWO HUNDRED AND FIFTY
COMMUNITY HEALTH. WHY. T. I.
TREAT COVERAGE. ON BEHALF OF THE
PERSON ASSOCIATION. THE MINUTE.
PROPOSAL ADDITIONAL DAHLE O THE
- YOU BEHAVIOR HEALTH INITIATIVE
WOULD VERY MUCH UNDER THE NEED
AND INTENT BEHIND OF. OKAY IN
THE- LEGISLATURE TO FOCUS THE-
MY ON SHOW TO BE ABLE TO. IN
THEIR- YOUNG CHOI AND THEIR
FAMILIES ARE EXPERIENCE MANY OF
THE SAME ISSUES COMING OUT OF
COVIDIEN WE BELIEVE. THEY SHOULD
BE AN ADDITIONAL FOCUS WE
ENCOURAGE THE LEGISLATURE TO
PROVIDE NO LESS THAN TWO HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION FOR THE
POPULATION. AND TOOK ONE OF MY
COMMENTS WITH THOSE OF US WERE
REMEMBER CHILDREN NOW REGARDING
THE- CONTINUE WITH MEDICARE
ELIGIBILITY FOR CHILDREN ZERO TO
FIVE. FOR. WITHOUT RELATION AND
TO MAINTAIN IN THE BUT AND
FINALLY I'M OF THE LOCAL OPEN
CAL WE TO WORK WITH ALLEGED.
INDIAN ON THE DIRECT CONTRACTOR
KAISER ON THAT ISSUE ALEX FIFTY
A PROPOSED AMENDMENT TO THE
PROPOSED TRAILER BILL AND AGAIN
WISH TO CONTINUE WITH THE WITH
THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE
LEGISLATURE AS WE MOVE FORWARD
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE HAVE
LINE NUMBER FIFTY Q. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
THE AMAZING PART OF THE
FOLLOWING VOTE ONLY ITEM AND
ISSUES ARE PROPOSED IN THE MAY
REVISION AND ASSOCIATED SPRING
FINANCE FINANCE WEATHER. THE
ONLY ITEM TWENTY ONE WE'RE
FINDING FOR EIGHTY FIFTY SEVEN
IMPLEMENTATION ISSUES ZERO THREE
FOUR THREE MILLION DOLLARS TO
FIND H. I EAT COMPLIANCE ISSUE
ONE ZERO THREE FORTY MILLION FOR
UNCOMPENSATED CARE FOR
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH SERVICES IF
YOU TO EAT REGARD. SETTLEMENT
EARTH ISSUE TO SEVENTY FOUR
REGARD THE EQUITY IN PRACTICE
TRANSFORM PROPRIETOR GRANT.
ISSUE TO SEVENTY FIVE THE
ELIMINATION OF THE MEDIC HOW
EIGHTY NINETY SEVEN PROVIDER
RATE REDUCTION I WOULD LIKE TO
THIS ITEM GO. ALSO INCLUDES AND
SPECIALTY PHARMACY SERVICES AND
FINALLY THE GENERAL FUND BOX
BUILT THE PROPOSITION FIFTY SIX
PROGRAM ON PAGE NINETEEN WITH NO
ISSUE NUMBER PROVIDED. MY FAMILY
IS PLEASED TO SEE A FOCUS ON TO
AND- OR- RATHER INTO MY- IN MY
ROOM KIND ABOUT THE AND DOOR OUR
POP. UNDER COUNTY. A HOPE THERE
WOULD BE ADDITIONAL DETAIL
AVAILABLE REGARDING THE
GOVERNORS CARE KAMI WORKFORCE
PROPOSAL FROM JANUARY SAM I
WOULD HAVE LIKED TO SEE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR HEALTH
CARE WORKFORCE PROGRAMS SUCH AS
FUNDING FOR ADDITIONAL REVENUE.
SLOTS HELP WORK. GUARDING YEAH
WILL MEET THE FOR THIS SHORTAGE
ALREADY MANIFEST IN MANY
UNDERSERVED REGIONS IN THE STATE
ADMINISTRATION WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS ON
HEALTHCARE WORKFORCE BEFORE THE
BUDGET FINAL THANK THE TIME AND
PERFECT MISTER. THANK YOU NEXT
CALL. YOU HAVE MY NUMBER FORTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS ADRIAN SHELTON
WITH THE CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE OF
CHILD AND FAMILY SERVICES WE
WANT TO EXPRESS THEIR SUPPORT
FOR A FEW ITEMS TODAY FIRST SAID
THE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICE OVER.
ABILITY COMMISSION THAT IS A
FISCAL LETTER WE SUPPORT THE
MODIFICATION TO THE INVESTMENT
IN MENTAL HEALTH WELL THE ACT OF
TWENTY THIRTEEN OF SPECIFICALLY
THE TRAILER BILL A AND BACK. OUR
SOME. ORANGE BETTER THAN THE IN
THE FIELD I ALSO WANT TO EXPRESS
FOR ITEM NUMBER FORTY IN THE
YEAH PROPOSED TO SHIFT THE
OVERSIGHT OF SUICIDE PREVENTION
VOLUNTARY CONTRIBUTIONS FUND
THAT THE NINE EIGHT EIGHT
NATIONAL SUICIDE PREVENTION
LIFELINE GROUP TO DH YES WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF ITEMS THREE
DEPARTMENTS HEALTHCARE REQUEST
TO SUPPORT IMPLEMENT SPEECH TO.
IMPORTANT WHEN A STANDARD FOLLOW
UP APPOINTMENTS FOR BOTH OF THEM
SUBSIDIES DISORDERS. AND LASTLY
TO MAKE COMMENT ABOUT CHARACTER
AND LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE
CONGRESS. ABOUT HOW WE ENSURE
THAT NEW LOW COST ARE INCLUDED
IN THE FINAL BY PROPOSAL. AND
PRO. I BELIEVE OUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
LEVINE NUMBER THIRTY FIVE. HELLO
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
A SOME OF THEM AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR STATE ALTEA PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATES ON BEHALF OF
THE ORGANIZATION I'M CALLING IN
EXPRESS OUR DISAPPOINTMENT IS
THAT WITH THE WHO HELPED ME MAKE
THIS. IN THE MAY. SUFFER HELLO.
DURING THE CALL THE NINETEENTH
AND THEN IN THE TO THE-
EMERGENCY PRICE. OUR STATE
SUFFERS FROM ON THE ANNUAL. NOW
MORE THAN TO INVEST ASSIST.
SHOULD RETURN. COMMUNITY TIMES
OF. THROUGHOUT THESE CRSES
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
WERE AND CONTINUE TO BE THE
TRUSTED FIRST LINE OF CONTACT.
MOST COMMUNITY WE ARE QUITE THE
LARGEST ANY MINUTE. THE ONE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR ONGOING
FUNDING FOR THE HEALTH EQUITY IN
RACIAL JUSTICE FUND DIRECTLY
FUNDED COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS CLINICS AND TRAVEL
ORGANIZATIONS MEET THEIR LOCAL
NEEDS RELATED THAT DRESS THAT
COULD BE AN ATTRACTIVE NATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. PLEASE WHY
NUMBER FIFTY THREE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS AND HAPPY
BIRTHDAY CHEN ARAMBULA MY NAME
IS OSCAR SANDOVAL ON ON BEHALF
OF YOU UP YOU KNOW COALITION FOR
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA OR ELSE BE.
SUPPORT OF THE INCLUSION OF THE
HEALTH EQUITY AND RACIAL JUSTICE
FUND IN THE STATE BUDGET. DURING
THE PANDEMIC MANY PEOPLE LIVING
IN OUR STATE RELIED ON COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS TO KEEP UP
THERE. NOW IT'S TIME THE STATE
HELPS FUND THOSE ORGANIZATIONS
WE CAN KEEP SUPPORTING THE
STATE'S MORE PAUL COURSE. WE'RE
ALSO GOING PORT OF EIGHT TWENTY
SIX NINETY SEVEN. EIGHTY TO
TWENTY SIX NINETY SEVEN QUITE A
LOT OF THE OPPORTUNITY. TO CARVE
OUT FOR RECEIPTS W.'S- OR
COMMUNITY HEALTH WORKERS ALSO
KNOWN AS BURMA PUT US. IN THE
WAY THE ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
UNABLE TO DO SO BY NOT JUST
FOCUSING ON CODIFYING THIS FALL
BUT ALSO BEING MINDFUL ABOUT HOW
WE BUILD THE PROPER METRICS TO
ACCOUNT. THE W. PROMOTE A
BENEFIT. AB TWENTY TWO NINETY
INCLUDES PROVISIONS RELATED TO
ENSURING HEALTH PLANS CONDUCT
TARGETED EDUCATION AND OUTREACH
TO INFORM BENEFICIARIES OF THEIR
NEW BENEFIT. AND CONDUCT
ASSESSMENT OF THE BENEFIT TO
MEASURE SUCCESSES AND POTENTIAL
CHALLENGES THAT WILL NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED THEM. IF WE OKAY
SUPPORT TWENTY MEDICAL MAINLY WE
SUPPORT THE EARLIEST
IMPLEMENTATION DAY POSSIBLE FOR
THE REMAINING EXPANSION AS WELL
AS A TO ENSURE THERE IS NO GAP
IN COVERAGE FOR THE AGING OUT
POPULATION. THANK YOU CAN. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. YEAH MY
NUMBER FIFTY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
DONNA THANKS REPRESENTING A LOS
ANGELES COUNTY BOARD ISSUE YOURS
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF YOURS MAY
BE COMPARABLE A ONE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS IN. LOS ANGELES. THANK YOU WILL GREATLY ASSIST
THAT. IN ACQUIRING ENDORSE
CAPITAL RUN. AND WILL ACCOUNT
BROAD INNOVATIVE. TO
INCARCERATION PROGRAM. THIS
INCLUDES DIVERTING THE MOST
VULNERABLE AND OFTEN THOSE
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED BY
THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
AWAY FROM JAIL INTO TREATMENT
AND ULTIMATELY PREVENTING
INDIVIDUALS. FROM ENTERING THE
POTENTIAL PIPELINE IN THE STATE
PRISON SYSTEM. WE STRONGLY URGE
YOUR SUB COMMITTEE TO APPROVE
THIS FUNDING AND FOR TO BE
INCLUDED IN THE FINAL BUDGET OUT
OF TWENTY TWENTY TWO. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. RIGHT NUMBER
FIFTY FIVE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS LYNN CURSING I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF MATERNAL AND CHILD
HEALTH ACCIDENTS TO THANK THE
GOVERNOR FOR INCLUDING
NAVIGATORS IN THE BUDGET WITH A
REVISION OF TERM PRECIADO
ASSEMBLY DISCOUNTS NOT AN
IMPROVEMENT- TO MOUNT AN-
APPROACH. I MUCH APPRECIATE THE
CHAIRS INCLUSION IN THE REMARKS
ABOUT INCLUDING THOSE FOR
COVERED NOW THAT COULD BE
UNCONSCIOUSLY CUT OFF OF THAT
ACCOUNT EVEN WHILE IN TREATMENT
THOSE TWENTY SIX TO TWENTY EIGHT
YOU'RE UNDOCUMENTED. AND IT.
PORTLET PART REFORM AND FOR.
WRITTEN THE GOVERNOR'S BUDGET
FOR THE MANY PEOPLE WE SEE CAN.
BY THIS. LIQUOR IT. EXPERT IN
ORDER ACCESS ACCOUNT. WE SUPPORT
CONTINUE ELIGIBILITY FOR CHILL
ZERO OF DURING CRITICAL YEARS
THE BANK IS A FOR ITS FOR C.
SERVER. TWELVE MONTHS OF
EXPANSION THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU THANKS FOR. LEVINE
NUMBER FIFTY SIX. SH GOOD
AFTERNOON KAREN MEMBERS MY NAME
IS TO LOOK AT RISK AND I'M
CALLING FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS MONEY
TO WALLET IN APPRECIATE THE
FIFTY MILLION PROPOSED. AND BUT
- HEALTH FOOD WE WERE JUST TO
SEE THAT NO I JUST FUNDING WOULD
PROPOSE LET ME REVISE. WE ARE
REQUESTING A HUNDRED TWENTY IN
THE TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
BUDGET BURKE HEALTH FOOD OUTLETS
REFLECT WITH THAT WOULD BRING
DAY I DO. HI AN IMPLANT PLACED.
INCORRECT HI HOW. AND THE
STANDING DEMAND AND BANKS ON OUR
THE BANK SERVING THAN ONE POINT
ADMIN PEOPLE AS COMPARED TO
BEFORE THE PANDA. AND FOOD BANKS
ARE ALSO TELLING US THAT THEY'RE
SPENDING THREE TIMES MORE ON
BRIDGE THE FOOD INTO A TWENTY
ONE AND ON TOP OF THAT BUT YOU
KNOW FEDERAL FOOD SUPPORT IS
MORE THAN ABOUT 2075% YET
THERE'S THE CONTINUE TO ELEVATE
. I FOR THAT. BUT A HUNDRED
MILLION FOR CALPERS WHICH IS THE
WAY. SUPPORTING OUR AND GETTING
OUT OUR TEAM. AND IN ADDITION WE
EXPECT THE PRESCRIPTION FOR THE
SENATE BUDGET PLANS INCLUSION
FOR A HUNDRED EIGHTY MILLION ONE
TIME REQUIREMENTS PASSED THE
ENHANCEMENT FOR FOOD BANKS AS
WELL AS FOR MAKING A STATE
DISASTER COULD. PROBE UP
PERMANENT. WHICH IS MUCH NEEDED.
ON THE AT THE END OF FOOD BANKS
ARE STRETCHED IN THEIR FIRST
GAME AND SO THIS S MUCH NEEDED
AND ESPECIALLY ALSO AT TO BE
READY AND NIMBLE FOR
UNFORTUNATELY WHEN OF THE
DOCTORS TECH. MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO. WITH YOU IN THE
BUDGET LEADERS TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE CENTURY OUR STATE BUDGET
AROUND THE NEEDS OF OUR STATE
MOST VULNERABLE RESIDENTS. THANK
YOU OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE
. WHY NUMBER FIFTY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN ARAMBULA
NUMBERS KIND OF IN THE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
ALCOHOL AND DRUG PROGRAM
EXECUTIVES WE HAVE COMMENT ON
ITEMS WE SUPPORT THE EXPANSION
ABOUT NETWORK PORTS FUNDING AT
FIFTY ONE MILLION WE ARE GONNA
HEALTHCARE SERVICE THAT OUR
TREATMENT PROGRAMS ARE
STRUGGLING WITH- HIRING AND
RICKY- PATIENT WORK IN THE
COMBAT MINUTES CRITICAL WE
CONTINUE TO OPPOSE THE PROPOSED.
3% MY. WITH WORK PROGRAM. YEAH
WE REQUEST THE BACKS TWIN
MILLION FIVE YEARS TO PREVENT
THAT THE INCREASE THE WITHOUT
ABOUT ALL THAT WILL REDUCE THE
ACT THAT THE TREATMENT PRO AT
THE SAME TIME AS NEEDED INCREASE
THE AND DEATH BY- OVERDOSE OR
STAFF IT AND I'M WITH THE TRIP
OF. IF YOU'RE YEAH. ON OVER THAT
THE CRUX BY BE COVERED UNDER THE
NEW. WHICH IS GREAT DOUBLE
STRAIN- LOCK OUT WE HAVE A
CONCERN ON THE CARE COURT BY
JUST. ABOUT PROVIDED THE FOR
THAT WE URGE THE THERE NEEDS TO
BE A CAP THAT AND I'D SERVICE
OFF ABOUT IN BEYOND THE BLACK
CARE. YOU I'M THAT FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE COMMENT.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
RIGHT NUMBER SIXTEEN. THANK YOU
MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS MORE
ATOP ON BEHALF OF FOR TAX
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF ITEM
NUMBER THREE EIGHT EIGHT IN THE
DPH BUDGET RELATED TO SICKLE
CELL DISEASE TREATMENT
INFRASTRUCTURE WE ARE
APPRECIATIVE AND SUPPORTIVE OF
THE FIVE MILLION DOLLARS
PROPOSED FOR THIS PROGRAM THE
COAST SEATED A PAIN AND REYES IS
THAT A FLEX CALIFORNIANS.
EDUCATE ACT PATIENT. LISTICLES
DISEASE ARE AWARE A AND HAVE TO
SPECIAL TEAM BASED CARE IN THEIR
AREA. BY CONNECTING PATIENTS
EARLY AND OFTEN WITH DEDICATED
CLINICS WE CAN REDUCE MORE
EXPENSIVE HOSPITAL AND EMERGENCY
CARE. SO WE STRONGLY SUGGEST
INCREASING THE PROGRAM
ALLOCATION TO THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS AND BELIEVES THAT IS A
COST EFFECTIVE INVESTMENT FOR
THE STATE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OPERATOR NEXT CALLER PLEASE.
EVERYONE NUMBER SIXTY ONE. THANK
YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS AND
HAPPY BIRTHDAY MISTER CHAIR
MICHELLE GIVEN THAT THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT THE
LEGISLATURE INCLUDE PUBLIC
HEALTH WORKFORCE RECRUITMENT
RETENTION TRAINING PROPOSALS ARE
. AT THE- IN A WORKFORCE IT'S
PREPARED TO RESPOND TO COPE WITH
NINETEEN AND OTHER PUBLIC HEALTH
THREAT IN ADDITION WE CONTINUE
TO OPPOSE THE ADMINISTRATION'S
PROPOSAL TO SENSE THAT THE CCP
PROGRAM HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT GAPS
IN CARE OR SERVICE REDUCTIONS
FOR CHILDREN IN ADDITION TO
CONCERNS AROUND THE NATION OF A
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT IT IS
THE RESULT OF THE- BILL. WITH
THE CODE IN NINETEEN OUT REGION.
FOR TO SHIFT YOU HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS FROM. THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH TO THE OFFICE OF
COMMUNITY PARTNERSHIPS AND
STRATEGIC COMMUNICATION. WE
WOULD UNDERSCORE CONCERNS RAISED
BY THE ALLEY- REGARDING A
POTENTIAL LACK OF COORDINATION
AND DUPLICATION. AT AND IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE KEY PARTNERS
IN IN ANY OUTREACH AND
COMMUNICATION EFFORT. I IN
REGARDS TO VOTE ONLY ITEMS WE
SUPPORT ITEM FIFTY SEVEN TO
INCREASE FUNDING FOR THE
CALIFORNIA HOME VISITING PROGRAM
AND BACK INTO HEALTH PROGRAM.
WHICH PART I TO FIFTY EIGHT FOR
LOW INCOME CHILDREN AND ITEM.
THINK THANK YOU. THANK YOU
OPERATOR NOT STOLEN. HAVE MY
NUMBER FOURTEEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JOE THE TABLET
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE LEGAL
AID SOCIETY OF SAN MATEO COUNTY
AND- CALLING IN SUPPORT OF- ITEM
THAT WAS NOT INCLUDED IN THE
MAIN PROVISION. MODIFICATION
COMMITTEE. COST AS STATED BY
SEVERAL ORGANIZATIONS ALREADY
THAT ONCE AN INDIVIDUAL HAS A
SHARE OF COST IT CAN BE- OVER
50% OF THEIR INCOME AND THEIR
EXPECTED TO LIVE. SIX HUNDRED
DOLLARS. WHICH NOT REALISTIC FOR
CALIFORNIA- THEREFORE WE
ENCOURAGE WE ARE JUST COMMITTEE
TO INCLUDE THE PROPOSAL I'M NOT
FINAL BUDGET THANK YOU. THANK
YOU OUR PLEASE. MY NUMBER FORTY
THREE. THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS KELLY MCMILLAN I'M
CALLING BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
DENTAL ASSOCIATION WE'RE PLEASED
TO SEE THE THIRTY ONE POINT
SEVEN MILLION DEFICIT IN A
DENTAL TRANSFER. B. I MEAN
NOTHING I DID SERVICES UNDER DTI
DOMAIN NUMBER THREE IN A TWENTY
TWENTY ONE WILL RECEIVE THE FULL
INCENTIVE PAYMENTS FOR SERVICES
ALREADY RENDERED THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT ASPECT IN PRESERVING
THAT TRUST BETWEEN PROVIDERS AND
MEDICARE PROGRAM ALSO CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION PORT OF DHS PROPOSED
TO EXPAND A LITTLE PROCESS
AROUND BRANIFF IT THIS IS BEEN A
LONG STANDING UP AND DOWN.
ACTION IS APPROVED IN THE FINAL
BUDGET CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION IS
SEEKING AN INCREASE IN THE
SCHEDULED MAXIMUM ALLOWANCE
WHICH WOULD ROUGHLY EQUATE TO AN
ADDITIONAL THIRTEEN MILLION AND
DH CS PROPOSAL THANK YOU FOR.
THANK YOU. YEAH LINE NUMBER
TWENTY NINE. HELLO MY NAME IS
STEPHANIE FOR CARGO I'M A
PHYSICIAN ASSISTANT A LOT WITH
B. CELL CLINIC AT COMMUNITY
MEDICAL CENTER IN PARTNERSHIP
WITH YEAR FRESNO. WE ARE BOTH OF
MARKETS THE ROOM VISITS AND HOT
ADMISSIONS CRITICAL THOUGHT
QUITE. I'M HERE SUPPORT OF. THE
WAY THE FINAL. MILLION DOLLARS
TO BE INCLUDED IN THE FINAL
BUDGET. YOU COVER THE X. IN ALL
CAN THE PROFILE. OVER THE NEXT
THREE OR FOUR NETWORKING BUT THE
COST OKAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER. HAVE LINE NUMBER
SIXTY THREE. YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA
JUST WANT TO THANK DIRECTOR THAT
FOR- THAT THE PROBABILITY FOR
FINANCING WE ARE CURRENTLY
REVIEWING THE PROPOSAL AND THE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE AMOUNT WE
APPRECIATE THE ABILITY FOR A
TALK. I. FOR TO THE CONTINUED
CONFLICT ABOUT WITH THE
DEPARTMENT AND OPEN ONE .COM OF
THOSE MADE INCLUDE- BECAUSE
BECAUSE AND ACCOUNTABLE THANK SO
MUCH AND EVERYONE HAS HAPPY
BIRTHDAY DOT. THANK YOU NEXT
PLEASE. HELLO I AM PERSPECTIVES
THAT. IN THANK YOU CHAIRED
COMMITTEE THAT LINE MEDIA BEHALF
COW STATE IT'S AND COUNTY HERE
PROVIDING COME IN REGARDS TO THE
- AND WEIGHTLESS AND ALTHOUGH. A
WEEK TO CONTINUE. OKAY WHICH IS
THE MAY REVISED TO SIX HUNDRED
THIRTY EIGHT MILLION ON GOING TO
PROVIDE OR ACCESS INTRIGUED.
IMPROVES STATE CLASS IN THE
CURRENT. YOU NEED A PATH TO
ADDRESS HELLENIZED LATELY.
ADDITIONALLY WILL KNOWLEDGE
APPROVED INCLUDING THE REVISE
TO- JUST TRY PLANNING IN RECORD
SHARING WITH BEING HEALTH AND
YOU TO ON BACK AND- AS WELL AS
THE STATE. ON IMPROVING CALL.
IRMA NATION. WE LOOK FOR. IN
MINISTRY ON IRONING OUT THE
DETAILS ABOUT THESE PROVISIONS.
HOWEVER WHILE WE APPRECIATE SOME
OF THE UPDATES IN THE MAY
REVISION AS IT RELATES TO THE
INCLUSION OF A HALF TOTAL NUMBER
I. IN THE CENTRAL COUNTY. HAPPY
SEATED WE REMAIN FUND ABOUT TO
K. WHICH IS COUNTY DO NOT FROM
ON AT TO REDUCE THE AYE D.
POPULATION WELL WE RECOGNIZE THE
FUNDING. PENALTIES WOULD BE
APPROPRIATED BACK COUNTY
ULTIMATELY THAT IN NO WAY
INCREASE THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF
FUNDING INVESTED AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL TO ADDRESS THE GROWING
NEED TO THEN CREAKING I KEEP. A
XIN AND THOSE SUFFERING WITH
MENTAL ILLNESS. AGAIN HE'S ACT
CRAIG THE MINISTRATIONS ON GOING
INVESTMENTS AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CAN. WORK WITH. AFTER THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE HAVE LINE
NUMBER SIXTY TWO. MY NAME IS
MOHAMMED SANI MCCARTY AND I'M
CALLING FROM FRESNO CALIFORNIA
I'M ONE OF THE BUY BACK IN ON
THE ACT OF FRACTIONAL PROVIDING
A QUICK BECAUSE- FOR. WHAT FOR
MEDICAL BECAUSE THOU WHO ARE
THESE IS NEEDS TO VOWED TO
DEEPEN FOR WE ALSO MODE
KICKABOUT WE NEED. I IN
CALIFORNIA YOU CAN. HM WITH THE
GROWTH LEAPING THAT BANKING HE
HAS AT STARTED TWENTY I PLEDGE
TIME I. CENTER LETTER STATES OUR
I'M- CALLING IN SUPPORT FOR
REPEAL THE ONE COUPLE TO PET THE
I'M TO COMPETE DOWN WAY BACK AND
DINEEQUITY CALIFORNIA FOR THE
CODE THAT OKAY. ARE INCLUDE AN
CARE OF THE SAN OF THE TO THE.
EIGHT
KERN MEMBERS PRINTER ISSUE
PRESIDENT CEO OF THE GOLDEN WEST
CHAPTER OF THE ALS ASSOCIATION.
AFTER ARAMBULA AND MEMBERS OF
THE SUBCOMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR STEADFAST SUPPORT OF OUR
MLS WRAPAROUND PROGRAM SINCE
TWENTY EIGHT. WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH WELL
NOT PLEASE AGENDA WE'RE
SUPPORTING ALS WRAPAROUND GRANT
PARK LIMITATION FUNDING REQUEST
AB FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS A YEAR
FOR FOUR YEARS. ARE YOU SUPPORT
ADDITIONALLY USE PRE. PUT ONE OF
THE BEST ON ONE SOUTHERN. THE
FIRM'S WILL ALSO SUPPORT FIVE
SATELLITE CLINICS TO SERVE THOSE
ANALYST PATIENTS IN MORE REMOTE
AREAS OF THE STATE AND HELP
OFFSET PATIENT POLITICS FOR
DURABLE. DID YOU COMMUNICATE IN
A QUICK MANNER THAN EITHER A
CENTRALLY. CAL ALS COULD TO
INCREASE AS DOES THE INTENSITY.
NEEDED TO APPLY CARE AND SUPPORT
FOR PEOPLE LIVING WITH A LS. YOU
SOME. OR THANK NEXT THIS. WE
HAVE LINE NUMBER THIRTY THREE.
YES THANK YOU THIS IS MAN CAN'T
I MEAN BACKING OF DIRECTOR OF
THE HAND THE PHILLY ACCOUNT OF
CALIFORNIA WE ARE COMMENTING TO
COURT AND THE NURSE PROPOSAL WE
BOTH GO HOW FOR. DENIGRATE AND-
IF IT WILL BREAK. HEALTH ACCESS
FOR PEOPLE WITH LEADING THE
FIGHT. IN ADDITION WE ARE IN
STRONG SUPPORT. OF THE FIVE
MILLION ANTHONY RISE FOR THAT
ONE TIME APPROPRIATION TO EXPAND
THE NETWORK AND- HOW. YOUR AND-
I'M GOING TO GET THERE MILLION
ADEQUATE QUESTION THE BLEEDING
DISORDERS CAN HAVE EXTENT X.
WITH CONCRETE CARE YOU HOT IN
PATIENT ON BELIEVE I MEAN IT'S
CRITICAL TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
TREATMENT AND IMPROVE OUTCOMES
FOR. THANK YOU. ALL WHAT. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER. IN THE NECK
CALLER WE HAVE IS LINE. SEVENTY
FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS A BENEFIT THAT
I'M I'M CALLING ON BEHALFOF THE
STATE GOING TO CONNECT COMMUNITY
ORGANIZING PROJECT HAPPY BUT-
GRANULES. ARE JUST WANTED TO-
GRATITUDE TOWARDS THE GOVERNOR
FOR INCLUDING NAVIGATORS IN THE
BUDGET- MY CUP OF THE PREVIOUS
RECIPIENT OF THE PILOT. AND ALSO
WHY I. HANDS THE CURRENT PROGRAM
BY A DOCK THE CAN BASED-
OUTLINED IN AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
ARE WE STRONGLY BELIEVE THE MAN
SAYS THAT COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATION THAT SUPPORT
INDIGENOUS IMMIGRANT EACH PARTY
WITH DRESSING THAT WAS TAKING
CULTURAL. I'M NOT A ALSO PUT
MEDIC ROMAN AND RICH. PARTY WE
WORK ON THE EXPANSION RIGHT NOW
FOR OLDER ADULTS AND WE ASK THE
LEGISLATURE TO OFFER SUPPORT AND
MISSED. HOUSE AT B. AND RACIAL
JUSTICE PARTY THANK YOU SO MUCH
. THANK YOU MEXICO PLEASE. WE
HAVE ONE NUMBER SIXTY EIGHT. ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA AND I
THINK HEALTH NETWORK
DEPENDENCIES THE GOVERNOR TO
EXPAND THE HEALTH NAVIGATORS
PROGRAM UNDER THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES. WE DO
HOWEVER WATCH URGED THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THE
LEGISLATURE TO ENHANCE AND
IMPROVE THE CURRENT. CURRENT
PROGRAM IS OFTEN THE COMMUNITY
BASED APPROACH OUTLINED IN AB.
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY. ASSIST DAY
CALIFORNIANS WITH MATT HOW
MOMENTS AND RICH. AND WE ARE
STILL. TO HE HEALTH EQUITY. AND
WHILE WE ARE OPEN TO THE ADMIN.
SUPPORT FOR THIS WE ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT THE OVERALL LACK
OF TARGETED INVESTMENTS REDUCE.
VERY SUCH AS JOB WHICH MEANT
HELP EQUITY RATIO JUSTICE FIND
OR INVEST TO. MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICE ACCESS AND MEDIC HOW. WE
ASK THE LEGISLATURE TO SUPPORT A
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR ONGOING
INVESTMENT FOR THE HEALTH EQUITY
AND RACIAL JEFF ON. THE FUND
WOULD PROVIDE DIRECT GRANTS TO
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
CLINICS AND TRIBAL ORGANIZATION.
SO THAT THEY CAN MEET OUR LOCAL
NEEDS RELATED TO REDUCING THE
SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF HEALTH
AND RACIAL JUSTICE. WE THOUGHT.
PICTURE TO PROVIDE FUNDING TO
AND HOW AWARENESS OF MY HEALTH
SERVICES THAT ARE ACCESSIBLE
THROUGH MEDI CAL SO THAT WE MAY
BEGIN TO CLOSE SOME OF THESE
ACCESS YEAH. LAST WEEKEND THE
SUPPORT OF OUR STATE RIGHT
PARTNER I PLEDGE TO DO THE
FOLLOWING EXPANDS MEDICARE ALL
CALIFORNIANS REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS OR AGE AND WE
URGE EARLY IMPLEMENTATION WITH
NO AGE OUT. AN EXTENSION OF THE
COMPANY PERINATAL SERVICES
PROGRAM TO ALIGN WITH MEDI CAL
PREGNANCY ELIGIBILITY PERIOD
FROM SIXTY DAYS TO THREE HUNDRED
AND SIXTY FIVE DAYS. AND FINALLY
REFORMING THE MEDIC HEALTHCARE
COSTS PROGRAM TO RAISE THE
MAINTENANCE INCOME LEVELS TWO
HUNDRED AND 38% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY LEVEL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. RIGHT
NUMBER SEVENTY FIVE. MISTER
TERRY MEMBERS ROB LANE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
BEHAVIOR HEALTH AGENCIES WE'RE
HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE GOVERNOR'S
MAY REVISION AND BETH MATCH THE
CONCEPT AND ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE
ISSUES PRESENTED TODAY BUT WE'RE
WAITING TO SEE THE FINAL TRAILER
BILL. IN GENERAL WE WANT TO DRAW
ATTENTION TO THE LACK OF FUNDING
INCLUDED FOR WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT FOR COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. WHILE WE ARE PLAN
STATE THAT ENDED THAT CAN.
BUYERS ARE STILL SUFFERING FROM.
CHRI IS. ADDITIONALLY I'M
IMPRESSED TO KEEP UP WITH THE
DEMAND AND AFTER FURTHER
INVESTMENT IN. RELATED TO NINETY
EIGHT CRISIS IMPLEMENTATION
INCREASE RATE FOR QPCR. AND
PAPERWORK REDUCTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE
HAVE A LINE NUMBER SEVENTY SEVEN. NUMBER SEVENTY SEVEN YEAR OPEN
- HELLO THANK YOU SHARE AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF ALMOST AND PARTICULAR-
MY NAME IS LAUREN O'CONNOR AND
I'M HONORED TO SERVE ON THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF THE WOMEN
NATION CALIFORNIA. ORGANIZATION
THAT SUPPORT. WOMEN ON THE
FRONTLINE DOING CRAFTWORK
ORGANIZED GRASSROOTS ORGANIZING
AND COMMUNITY BUILDING AND
POLICYMAKING WHAT THE BIGOTRY SO
LEAST POLICY AND THEY'RE WORKING
WITH MANY OF YOU. IN SACRAMENTO
. PARTNER FRIENDSHIP HEALTHCARE
GO AND THE VILLAGE AND IN
PARTICULAR THE WOMEN BLOODSHED
ARE HONORED TO BE DOING SO-
DELIGHTED AT THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL FOR THE FIFTEEN MILLION
. HEY WE ARE THE CALL A COUPLE
MAYBE THREE WEEKS AGO WITH
SENIOR ADVISER KATHLEEN JANET
AND- TRAVEL ADVISOR CRISTINA
WRITER WHERE THE HUNDRED METER
FOLKS WHO WERE TRIBAL RESENTFUL
AFTER. YEAH HOW BECOME PROPOSAL
THE HUNDRED NOW SO THAT THE
WHOLE STATE OF AND ALL OUR
RESOURCES CAN COME TOGETHER TO
SUPPORT THE AMAZING WORK YOU ALL
DOING IN FACT I KNOW YOUR-
EXACTLY. I KNOW THAT BEING OUT
FOR RECALL ON THIS CALL WHICH IS
AND HOW BY LEADERS KNOW THE
PROBLEM THAT BECAUSE THEY'RE
LIVING WORKING IN AND THEN. I
YOU HAVE BUT AN ONGOING LANE USE
THAN SERVE OUR BACK THANK ALL
FOR YOUR AND CARE. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. BUT LINE
NUMBER SEVENTY SIX. GOOD
AFTERNOON KELLY BURKE FAMILY
HAPPENED URBAN COUNTY THE
CALIFORNIA I'M COMMENTING ON THE
CHARACTER OF ALL COUNTIES WILL
NEED ADEQUATE AND SUSTAINABLE
FUNDING FOR EMPLOYMENT CARE
COURT AND SHE PROGRAM LIKE THAT
WE ANTICIPATE ACROSS.
DEPARTMENTS INCLUDING THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER COUNTY COUNCIL PUBLIC
GUARDIANS AND CONSERVATORS AND
COUNTY SOCIAL SERVICES. THANK
YOU MATT BUT THEY CONTINUED WORK
WITH CAO THANK ESTIMATES. URBAN
URGED LEGISLATURE TO INCLUDE
ADDITIONAL AND ONGOING RESOURCES
IN THE FINAL BUDGET TO ADDRESS
NEW COUNTY RESPONSIBILITIES AND
OBLIGATIONS. WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING- THAT FURTHER
CONVERSATIONS OF THE LEGISLATURE
IN ADMINISTRATION PUNK HARDCORE.
THANK YOU AND HAPPY BIRTHDAY
CARE. THANK YOU NEXT CALL PLEASE
. WE HAVE A LINE NUMBER SIXTY
NINE IT'S GOT HAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR SHARE
GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE SCIENCES IN SUPPORT OF THE
FOLLOWING VOTE ONLY ITEM. ITEM
TWENTY TWO REGARDING THE REQUEST
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF MANAGED
HEALTHCARE TO EMPLOYMENT SB
THREE SIXTY EIGHT BY TEN
ACKERMAN NON WHICH REQUIRES
HEALTH PLANS TO PROVIDE IN A
ROW. HELLO BALANCE TOWARD THEIR
DEDUCTIBLE AND ARE OUT OF POCKET
MAXIMUM. IN ADDITION COURT ITEM
TWENTY FOUR PROVIDING REQUIRED
BY THE TEAM MADE THE EMPLOYMENT
AB THREE THAT CHAIRMAN.
IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT IT IS
EQUALLY IMPORTANT THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION ADEQUATELY FUNDED
THE IMPLEMENTATION OF THE
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT DEL AND SO
WE SUPPORT ITEM TWENTY TWO AN
ITEM TWENTY FOUR. THIS JAN THE
SUPPORT AND WEBER FORTIETH ZERO
REGARDING THE NAY PREPAY
PROPOSAL BY THE DEPARTMENT OF
HEALTH CARE SERVICES TO EXEMPT
CONTINUOUS GLUCOSE MONITORS FROM
BACKING OUT SB NINETY SEVEN
PROVIDER RATE REDUCTION. NOW ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN DIABETES
ASSOCIATION. ARKHAM DIABETES
ASSOCIATION ALSO SUPPORTS THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES NEIGHBOR VISION
EXEMPTION OF CONTINUOUS GLUCOSE
MONITORS FROM MEDIC CAL AB
NINETY SEVEN PROVIDER RATE
REDUCTION BUT WE ALSO URGE THE
ADMINISTRATION TO EXPAND THE GM
ACCESS TO INDIVIDUALS WITH HIGH
IQ DIABETES. WILL BE ALSO. IN
CAL BT PENSION PROGRAMS TO
STRENGTHEN THE STATE FOCUS ON
PREVENTING DIABETES BEFORE IT
HAPPENS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN HAPPY BIRTHDAY THANK
YOU. NEXT CALLER PLEASE. YOU
HAVE LINE NUMBER SEVENTY NINE IF
I HAD. THANK YOU AND- THANK YOU
TO THE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE
AND STAFF MY NAME IS DIANE
DETECTION TIME FROM THE CENTER
FOR INHERITED BLOOD DISORDERS.
AND I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
REPRESENT MARY BROWN WHO IS A C.
E. O. OF THE AT THE KOTEL
DISEASE FOUNDATION WE AND OUR
ORGANIZATIONS AND MANY TEAMS OF
PEOPLE HAVE WORKED TOGETHER TO
BUILD A NETWORK OF. TICKLED CARE
. SUNDAY BY AN INITIAL INVEST OF
MILLION DOLLARS- IT BACK IN
TWENTY EIGHTEEN OUR OUR
CHALLENGE WAS TO BUILD FIVE
CLINICS TO BEGIN THE THIRD
ADULTS WITH SICKLE CELL IN
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE THEY THEIR
LIFE EXPECTANCY WAS SHORTER THAN
ANY OTHER STATE IN THE COUNTRY
ALL THE WAY DOWN TO AGE FORTY
THREE. SO I WITH THE HELP OF THE
STATE AND WITH OUR- GOALS OF
BUILDING SITE CLINICS DOING
WORKFORCE EXPANSION ALSO DOING
SURVEILLANCE AND DATA IN
EDUCATION WE REALIZE THAT THERE
WERE ACTUALLY OVER NINE THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS WITH THE BELT IN
STATE AND SO WE EXPANDED OUR
GOAL TO TEN CLINICS WHICH WE
ACHIEVED JUST IN THE LAST SIX
MONTHS WE'VE HIRED. INDIVIDUALS
TO HELP MAN CLINIC. WE'VE ALL
TRIED COMMUNITY WORK AND
CONTINUING TO DO DATA AND
SURVEILLANCE AND EDUCATION. WE
ARE ASKING FOR AN INCREASE FROM
FIVE MILLION TO THIRTY MILLION
AS YOU'VE HEARD FROM MANY OTHERS
OF. CAN THE NETWORK AND
DEMONSTRATE NOW IS PATIENTS ARE
BEGINNING TO COME TO THESE
CLINICS THE INCREDIBLE-
IMPROVEMENT IN QUALITY OF LIFE
DECREASED HOSPITALIZATION AND ER
AND DECREASED UTILIZATION OF
HOSPITAL SERVICES WE ARE- BROWSE
THE CDC HAS RECENTLY REGAINED. A
RELEASE THEIR DATA THIS IS NOT
OUR DATA BUT THERE'S A
DEMONSTRATE THAT WITH THE FIRST
FEW PATIENT WE'VE OVER. A FEW
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR THE
STATE AND WE ESTIMAE THAT OVER
A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR
EVERY TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED ADULTS
WITH SICKLE CELL WILL BE SAVED
BY THE STATE WHICH CURRENTLY
PAYS OVER A BILLION DOLLARS IN
HOSPITALIZATION AND ER. THESE
CLINICS MOVE CARE FROM HOSPITALS
AND ER'S OUT INTO THE COMMUNITY
OUT INTO THE CLINIC IMPROVE AND
PRESERVE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR
LIFE EXPECTANCY. FOR PATIENTS
AND WE WISH TO THANK. THIS FOR
THAT A UNUSUAL AND- COURAGE TO
SUPPORT IT WE HOPE WE'VE PROVED
YOU PROUD AND WE HAVE BECOME A
NATIONAL- ASIDE FOR INNOVATION
AND WE'RE PROUD TO DO SO FOR
OUR- NINE THOUSAND PATIENTS WITH
SICKLE CELL THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THANK YOU FOR.
INCREASING IN THE MAY RE REVISED
TO THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS TO OUR
NETWORK AND THE BEST WISHES TO
EVERYONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. YOU HAVE MY
NUMBER THIRTY ONE. MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS AMY BLOOMBERG ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL ASSOCIATION HAPPY
BIRTHDAY MISTER CHAIR CCHA
APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR
CONTINUED COMMITMENT TO
EXPANDING THE KARRAKATTA ME
WORKFORCE WITH ONE POINT SEVEN
BILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT TO
EXPAND THE NUMBER OF NURSES
SOCIAL WORKERS PSYCHIATRISTS AND
OTHER KEY. STATE J. APPLAUDS THE
GOVERNOR NATHAN HAYDEN FOCUSED
ON THE USE BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
CRISIS WE'RE EXPERIENCING WITH
THE TWO HUNDRED AND NINETY
MILLION DOLLAR INVESTMENT AND
SUICIDE PREVENTION AND CRISIS
RESPONSE PROGRAMS AND A VARIETY
OF HEALTH AND WELLNESS PROGRAMS
FOR CHILDREN YOUTH AND THEIR
FAMILIES. CCHA CONTINUES TO EARN
YOUR SUPPORT FOR TO BUDGET
REQUEST NOT INCLUDED IN THE MAY
REVISION NUMBER ONE INCREASING
MEDIKAL FEAT FOR SERVICE RATES
FOR HOSPITALS HIS RATES HAVE
BEEN FROZEN FOR OVER A DECADE.
R. EIGHT NONPROFITPRIVATE THE
HOSPITALS ARE STATING THAT
HOSPITALS THAT ARE 62% NOT
ACCOUNT AND CARE FOR SOME OF THE
SICKEST CHILDREN IN THE STATE
OUR COST SEVENTY. FORTY FIVE.
AND EVERYTHING REPORT. THAT OVER
50% OF HOSPITALS IN THE STATE
ARE OPERATING IN THE RED.
MEDIKAL FEE FOR SERVICE RATES
NEED TO BE INCREASED SO THAT OUR
HOUSEHOLD CAN CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE CARE TO UNDERSERVED
COMMUNITIES. THESE RATE
INCREASES ARE CRITICAL NEED TO
BE ADDRESSED NOW. OUR SECOND
REQUESTED TO EARMARKED FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE ACCESS
AND INFORMATION BUDGET. AND THEN
FOR HOSPITALS. BUILDING ON THE
GOVERNOR'S YOUTH BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH FOR TROUBLE IN THE NAY
REVISED IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT THE
STATE AND BASS AND OUR PEDIATRIC
WORKFORCE. AND THESE INVESTMENTS
INCLUDE PEDIATRIC SPECIALIST AS
WELL AS CHILD PSYCHOLOGIST AND
CHILD PSYCHIATRISTS. CALIFORNIA
AND THE NATION HAVE A SEVERE
SHORTAGE OF CHILD PSYCHOLOGISTS
AND PSYCHIATRISTS. AND
INVESTMENTS ARE NEEDED NOW TO
ENSURE THAT CHILDREN AND YOUTH
IN CRISIS CAN RECEIVE CARE IN A
TIMELY MANNER. THERE ARE ONLY
THIRTEEN PRACTICING BOARD
CERTIFIED OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRISTS FOR
EVERY ONE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CHILDREN WHILE THE AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF CHILD AND ADOLESCENT.
PSYCHIATRY ESTIMATES THE NEED
FOR THREE TIMES THAT NUMBER.
CHILDREN AND THAT YOU. HAVE TO
WAIT FOR WEEKS OR EVEN MONTHS TO
RECEIVE CARE CALIFORNIA NEEDS TO
DO BETTER AND MAKE THESE
CRITICAL INVESTMENTS NOW. ALSO
WITHOUT SPECIFIC EARMARKED
FUNDING FOR WORKFORCE FOR
CHILDREN'S HOSPITAL. THE
SEVENTEEN PEDIATRIC RESIDENCY
PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA EIGHT OF
WHICH ARE PROVIDED IN
COLLABORATION WITH CCHA
HOSPITALS WILL RECEIVE VERY
LITTLE FUNDING FOR THEIR
TRAINING PROGRAM. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION OF THESE
IMPORTANT REQUEST. THANK YOU
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. YOU HAVE MY
NUMBER FIFTY EIGHT. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR FRANK THEN TRUMP
HAPPY AMERICAN COLLEGE OF OBGYN
STITCHES NINE THE GOVERNOR'S
PROPOSAL TO INCREASE THE
REIMBURSEMENT FOR DOOR SIR
YOU'RE THE SAME LEVEL OF PERSON
CAN JUST FOR THE HIGH DOES HELP
WE INSPECT WE MET UP SERVICES.
THEREFORE THANK YOU FOR NOT
ROOTED IN THE REVISED AND THAT
IS TO ENHANCE THE MEDICAL GLOBAL
STATIC RATE THAT MEDICAL
PROVIDERS CAN BE JUST WILL
COMPENSATED FOR IT ACTUALLY
COVER THE COST OF THEIR SERVICES
CURRENTLY SERVICES COVERED BY
THE GOAL OF SKEPTICAL GENETIC
CAL A REIMBURSABLE JUST FIFTY
TWO POINT 4% OF THE SAME
SERVICES COVERED BY MEDICARE.
MONEY GLOBAL PAYMENT POLICIES
GET INTO DRIVING PROVIDERS OUT
OF THE MEDICARE MEDICAID PROGRAM
OKAY WE LEADING TO A SMALLER
POOL HEALTHCARE PROFESSIONALS
CARING FOR LOWER INCOME PATIENTS
THIS IS TROUBLING WHEN THERE'S
ALREADY SUCH A DEVASTATING
MATURE MARC MCNULTY CRISIS WE
NEED TO DO WHAT WE CAN TO
ENCOURAGE ACTUAL STEP TO
PROVIDERS TO TREAT THIS MOST
VULNERABLE POPULATION. I DON'T
SURE BIBLE STUDY BIBLE PROVIDERS
ARE COMPENSATED PROPERLY IS A
WAY TO DO IT FINALLY I'LL BE
HAPPY TO BE AMERICA I LIKE TO
EXPRESS APPRECIATION OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING TO SUPPORT
THE WELLNESS AND BEHAVIOR HEALTH
AND YOUTH AND PARENT. THIS
EIGHTY FIVE. IN MY FOURTH
PROGRAMS WITH A PORTION USED TO
EXPAND PARENTS SUPPORT AND
TRAINING AND THE FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS TO DEVELOP VIDEO SERIES
REPAIRS TO STRENGTHEN THEIR
SKILL. SETS WHICH- WE THE CAN
DEFERRED CONTINUE TO CONSIDER
PURPLE. TO THAT LOCAL. CAN
PROVIDE CARE ALL THE TOOLS THEY
NEED TO SIX. THANK YOU FOR YOUR-
THANK YOU. THE CALL. WE HAVE
NUMBER EIGHTY. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS MARY BROWN AND THE
PRESIDENT AND CEO OF THE SICKLE
CELL DISEASE FOUNDATION AND I'M
ALSO REPRESENTING YOUR LAN TO
RANDALL THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FROM THE REST FRESNO FAMILY
REGIONAL CENTER. I'D LIKE TO ASK
TO INCREASE THE ONE TIME
APPROPRIATION TO THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS TO COMPLETE THE SICKLE
CELL DISEASE NETWORK OF CARE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. LEVINE NUMBER EIGHTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU AND HAPPY
BIRTHDAY MISTER CHAIR THIS IS
ALEX CALLING CALLING ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA CHRONIC CARE
COALITION OF THE COALITION IS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY FOUR DMH. IT'S A FUN
MEMBER. FOUR SEVEN ARAMBULA
PERTAINING TO STEP THERAPY THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. SEVERINA BURKE EIGHTY
EIGHT. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THIS IS SERRA PAYING WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES CALLING ABOUT THE CARE
COURTS PROPOSAL I WANT TO ECHO
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES FROM THE
URBAN COUNTIES POCKET FONG- WE
DO NEED FOR FUNDING IN ORDER TO
MAKE THIS PROGRAM SUCCESSFUL AND
THERE ARE SIGNIFICANT IMPACT ON
COUNTY FUNCTION ALSO KEEP POLICY
DECISIONS NEED TO BE MADE SO
THAT WE CAN ASCERTAIN WHAT THE
COSTS WILL BE AND HOW TO BE MOST
SUCCESSFUL WITH A HIGHLY
VULNERABLE POPULATION. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND HAPPY BIRTHDAY
THANK YOU NEXT CALLER PLEASE. WE
HAVE ONE MORE IN Q. AND THAT IS
WHY NUMBER EIGHTY NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON I AM JENNIFER FIELD I
AM AN ADULT LIVING WITH SICKLE
CELL DISEASE AND ON BEHALF OF
THE VICTIMS OF THE TREATMENT
STRUCTURE ISSUED EIGHTY- I'VE
TALKED WITH SUPPORT INCREASE IN
THE ONE TIME APPROPRIATIONS FROM
FIVE MILLION TO THIRTY MILLION
TO COMPLETE BUILDING THE NETWORK
OR DON'T. WHAT'S THE CONTENT OF
THESE ACROSS THE STATE THANK YOU
FOR YOUR. TIME AND FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION OF THIS REQUEST.
THANK YOU. OPERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANY REMAIN OUR REMAINING COLORS
. WE DO NOT HAVE ANY MORE IN Q.
AS OF RIGHT NOW MR CHEN I WILL
TAKE THAT AS THE INCLUSION OF
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR TODAY I WILL
TAKE A SECOND THANK THE
ADMINISTRATION ALL OF THE
DIRECTORS THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE L. A. L. E. D. G. S.
TECH. THE SERGEANTS STAFF WHO
HELPED TO PREPARE ALL OF THE
MATERIALS MOST IMPORTANTLY THE-
WE WILL BE ADJOURNED FOR TONIGHT
AND HOPEFULLY YOU'LL JOIN US
TOMORROW FOR HUMAN SERVICES.
THEY MIGHT.